largest. Why is the FBI protecting the greatest pedest um the
the largest scale pedtoist in human history? >> Simple
because of who's on that list. >> So, you finished that
December 2023 interview with a challenge to the FBI and harsh
words for Republicans in Congress for not getting the Epstein
files out to the public. You can see this clip >> pants
and let us know who the are. >> Put on your big boy pants
and let us know who the are. You said you emphasized that the
president and FBI director each had complete authority to release
Epstein's client list. You said Epstein's black book is under
the quote direct control of the director of the FBI. Look at
this clip. >> This is way off the topic, but who has Jeffrey
Epstein's >> black book? >> Black book. >> But
who
that is that that I mean there's >> Well, that's under
direct control of the director of the FBI. >> All right.
So, you were sworn in as director more than 200 days ago. Now,
the black book is under your direct control. So, why haven't
you released the names of Epstein's co-conspirators in the and
trafficking?
>> all right. All right, we're through. We're through these
couple things. We're through what? Might be ready to move on
to some politics here, guys. Do we do the full house full judiciary
hearing >> on uh on Jeffrey Epstein? We had a full house
judiciary hearing here, guys, on the Epstein files with Cash
Patel. Cash Patel testified yesterday and he's back today. He's
back today to talk about the Epstein files. All right, but it's
there's a lot of testimony that gets really explosive in this,
so it's actually going to be good. I've watched a couple of the
clips. The clips are >> Email from Admiral Rogers, the
head of the NSA. You can see it was December
says to Jim, John and Jim, Jim Clapper, John Brennan, Jim Comey,
and he says, "I asked my team if they've had sufficient access
to the underlying intelligence, sufficient time to review that
intelligence.
On both points, my team raised concerned."
further states, "My folks aren't fully comfortable."
Few hours later, there's an email back to Admiral Rogers. This
one is from Jim Clapper and it says this, "It is essential that
we be on the same page and are supportive. All of us are supportive
of the report in the highest tradition of
that's our story and we're sticking to it. We may have to compromise
on our normal modalities. This is one project that has to be
a team sport. That's our story and we're sticking to it. Compromise
compromise on normal modalities. That's a fancy way of saying
that's the government speak for we're going to have to change
the rules. In fact, we're not going to follow our own rules.
And that's exactly what they did to get the objective they wanted
to undermine President Trump. Now, how how did it specifically
take place? The whistleblower said that the government officials
ignored concerns about discredited information. And what was
that discredited information? What was the discredited information
that they didn't ignore ignore the concerns about? What did they
use that discredit
>> course, it was the dossier. The now famous steel dossier
that was paid for by the Clinton campaign when they hired the
law. >> Wait, what? Why is Jim Jordan yapping about Russia?
What the What is What is happening? I thought I just had a stroke
and I was watching the wrong hearing. We had Jim Jordan yapping
about Russia. Is it What year is it? Perkins Kuey who hired Fusion
GPS who hired the foreigner Christopher Steel who wrote all this
garbage and lies down that was is what was used to changed the
intelligence community report. And what happens next? What do
Jim, John, and Jim do do next? They go to Trump Tower on January
6, 2017 to brief then President-elect Trump about the dossier.
Again, >> going through Nunes memo. I think this is actually
talking about Nunes memo. He's trying to like talk about cash,
>> Financed foreign author dossier that the whistleblower
knows is garbage and that they know is garbage. >> This
is going to be the >> there's one final step >> I
think >> one final step >> which Cash Patel authored
as far >> Comey leaves that meeting with the president
and immediately leaks to the press that they've briefed the president
on the discredited information. They've briefed the president
on the dossier and thereby given it somewhat some credibility
and create creating the basis and the predicate for all they
did to the president. They leaked false information. They leaked
classified information. They used and leaked discredited information.
And they didn't follow their own rules. All to sabotage President
Trump's first term. And but for this guy, Cash Patel, but for
this >> I told you. Told you. New Year's memo. >> Never
have known this information. The good people of this great country
would not have known what took place 8 years ago when they were
trying to undermine the guy elected by We the People. And I want
to thank Attorney General Bondi. She set up a special strike
force, a special team to look into this and see if there's any
criminal liability that exists in what took place. Now, in addition
to getting the truth to the people, Director Patel is getting
the bad guys off the street. He's moved agents out of Washington,
got the focus off of politics here in DC and has instead I was
going to say, why did you lead with something he did like five,
six, seven years ago? Seven. Yeah, like seven years ago. Why
are you leading with that instead of anything he's done as FBI
director, Mr. Jordan? Is it because his tenure as FBI director
has been marred by nothing but mediocrity and failure? >> Dead.
Putting bad guys behind bars. 21,000 violent criminals uh have
been taken off the streets, which is 125% increase from the comparable
period in the previous administration. He's rescued 4,000 kids.
He's got 1300 predators who he's arrested. He's also ended the
weaponization of the FBI. No more spying on parents at schoolboard
meetings. No more pre-dawn raids on pro-life Catholics. No more
retaliation against whistleblowers.
>> Oh god. He's he guys, he's uh he's ended the weaponization
of the FBI. Let's pay no attention to the lawsuit pending that
he basically was firing people for not being loyal to Trump.
All right, >> we got we got a whole section of the stream
later tonight where I've got what what do we have here? We got
what MSNBC on the political FBI >> government agency
most. >> We've got a lawsuit over here from this is the
same thing. This is the uh the former director of the the former
interim director of the FBI filed a lawsuit against them. And
then we have this article from July July 10th on how Cash Patel
was using polygraph tests as and asking people about like whether
or not they're loyal, who they voted for, and what's this one?
This is uh two FBI agents just earlier this week, maybe earlier
today, yesterday, came out and were reporting that they were
fired for
what? Uh
uh two H. I thought this was um loyalty. This is loyalty test.
>> I think this is loyalty test. I think this is loyalty
test, but I didn't actually read this, so I assume it's in the
same vein as all of this stuff. Okay, but >> All that is
to say, all that is to say really quickly, Cash Mattel ended
the politicization, the weaponization of the FBI. Okay, he ended
it by violating the Hatch Act repeatedly. Okay, if you guys don't
know, the Hatch Act is there to make sure that the FBI stays
apolitical, that there are actually specific criteria that they
need to maintain about not asking political questions, not getting
to the politics of its members, right, in order to not make the
FBI corrupt. And he's given us information that Chris Ray didn't.
Maybe said better, he's given us information that Chris Ray wouldn't.
Director Ray didn't tell us that there were 26 confidential human
sources at the capital in January 6, 2021, even though he was
repeatedly asked about that by members of this committee. Director
Ray didn't tell us that there were 17 of those confidential human
sources who entered restricted space. Four went in the capital.
None of them were arrested. They weren't authorized to do that.
They broke the law. None of them were arrested. Lots of American
citizens were arrested. But the guys whose salary, excuse me,
whose American tax dollars was used to pay these guys who broke
the law, none of them were one was recommended for charging and
was not charged. Remember, >> is he complaining that like
that CIS are not getting arrested?
>> Hey, we have we had like a bunch of, you know, confidential
informants in these organizations and we didn't arrest them.
Isn't that [__] up, guys? Uh, maybe. I don't know.
Probably only if they got caught. If they got photographed inside.
>> When Chris Ray told us that the Richmond field office
memorandum on pro-life Catholics was just a one-off. Turns out
he wasn't being square with this then either. Director wasn't
square with us. He told us that multiple other offices were involved
in targeting the Catholics. We got that information from Director
Patel. The we learned from Director Patel the FBI actually surveiled
a priest, tried to get the priest to devolve information, break
the priest's penitent relationship and confidence that exist.
And Director Patel is saving taxpayers money. He's not going
to build a new headquarters outside of DC. He's going to keep
the headquarters right here in the capital city. Save Americans
money. Save the taxpayers money. In eight months, in eight months,
Director Patel has given us the facts. He's ended the weaponization
at the FBI. He's taking bad guys off the streets and he's saving
taxpayers money. But my guess is the Democrats won't focus on
all that good news. They'll focus on politics. They'll stick
with Comey and Clapper and Brennan and continue to try to undermine
President Trump. That I yield to the ranking member for an opening
statement. Thank you very much, Mr. Chairman, and welcome. Director
Patel, you and I have not had the opportunity to meet and uh
alas, you failed to respond to the eight oversight letters I've
sent you over the last seven months. Um, so we do have a lot
of questions piling up for you, but I want >> This is Raskin,
right? I didn't I didn't hear it just now. I think it's Raskin.
>> Let's start with >> Listen, I you know, I've asked
you to get in here a couple times. It's nice of you to finally
join us. >> A word of praise. The first FBI director was
Jay Edgar Hoover, who uh steadfastly refused to hire women, African-Americans,
and other minorities as agents. And although he was a closeted
who lived in domestic partnership for decades with Clyde Tullson,
he also participated in anti-gay crusades, he aggressively promoted
what we would today call white Christian nationalism. And he
would undoubtedly be turning over in his grave to see as one
of his successors a first generation Indian-American and a proud
Hindu. So I congratulate you on being
I congratulate you on being our DI FBI director. You're you you
make our country proud. Okay. We had these white supremacists
in there before. Congratulations on being the first Hindu American.
The first American the first Hindu Indian-American leader of
the FBI >> a breakthrough in this sense and being a beneficiary
of the civil rights movement
>> Cash Mattel is sitting there like bro shut the up. He's
like doing the the cutthroat side like shut the up ras what you
trying to get me killed bro you trying to get me killed right
now what are you doing? >> Opened up the FBI and the federal
workforce to lots of people who never would have been hired in
its first decades. Alas, you share Jay Edgar Hoover's dangerous
obsession with blind loyalty over professionalism and effective
public policy. For Hoover, it was blind loyalty to him and keeping
his secrets. For you, it's blind loyalty to Donald Trump in keeping
his secrets. During your confirmation, it was widely noted on
all sides that your primary qualification was your unwavering
loyalty to Trump. Unlike other directors, you had no work experience
at the FBI, but you had made over a thousand media and political
appearances in support of Trump's campaign. Your Senate confirmation
vote was 51 to 49, the closest in history, with your opponents
warning you were not qualified and had no interest in actually
developing the qualifications for the job. I hoped that they
were wrong. Uh, alas, they were not. While most other new FBI
directors drew on their experience as FBI agents, you didn't
have that. But you did write a picture book trilogy for children
ages five and up based on
>> Don't hit him. Don't hit him with the children's book,
bro. What are you clashing with President Trump's political enemies.
In your book, you describe your literary alter ego, Cash the
Knight, as a wacky, easily bored wizard carrying out King Donald's
vengeance by driving his enemies out of the kingdom. In the books,
King Donald >> How the [__] does this guy get
elected head of the FBI when he wrote a children's book with
this >> besieged by the evil Hillary Queen? >> He
literally wrote a children's book where Donald Trump is king.
There's a plot against him and he's the person like smiting all
of Donald Trump's >> town but saved in the end by Cash.
Dan Catch goes on to catch mules who are stealing the 2020 election
for the great King Donald from Sleepy Joe. And then in the third
book, Cash takes down the dragon of the jalapenos nicknamed the
DOJ. Your supporters had hoped that you >> The dragon of
the jalapenos guys.
No, that's act those are actual things Cash Patel wrote. Like
>> dragons and the jalapenos. >> That's real. Yes.
This is like That's what got him the job. >> He wrote something
Trump could actually read. What? Put the correct my pronunciation.
It's chilapinos, isn't >> You're You're right. >> No,
it's jalapenos. >> Why did it start with a J? >> Graduate
from imagining yourself a romantic fairy tale knight to actually
running America's premier federal law enforcement agency. Alas,
just as we've learned how dangerous it is to put a sciencedy
antivaxer in charge of our public health, we've learned how danger
it is to name as director of the FBI a man who thinks of himself
as a fairy tale knight who keeps a fireb breathing dragon named
DOJ at home to forcibly drive villains out of the kingdom. When
Charlie Kirk was assassinated while his killer was still on the
loose, you decided you didn't need to be at FBI headquarters
in Washington to work with your team while the chaotic manhunt
unfolded. You spent your evening dining in a swanky Midtown Manhattan
restaurant and tweeting out false information that the subject
of the shooting was in custody. A statement you had to retract
1 hour. >> The subject for the horrific shooting today
that took the life of Charlie Kirk is now in custody. Thank you
to the local and state authorities in Utah for your partnership
with the FBI. We will provide updates when available. Subject
in custody has been released after an interrogation by law enforcement.
Our investigation continues. The subject. Not a subject. The
subject.
The Oh, man. It really really [__] you up when you're
uh What is this? >> What are these? What are these called
in grammar? The Is it uh >> Are they I don't think they're
predicates. They got to be articles, >> No, it's not articles.
>> Articles. Yeah, articles. Articles. When you don't use
the right subject predicates. Okay. >> Wrong article. Wrong
article. Cash
>> Your performance was so disturbing. >> Still printing
out tweets. Did we not bully them hard enough the last time they
did this? Are they so hard in Congress in business? >> Yeah,
they got like the golf checks, the golf check tweets. Okay, the
huge golf check tweets. >> Is that a industrial-sized highlighter
for this one or did they print it out with the highlight? >> They
had to printed it out. They had to have printed it out. Okay,
they had to have tourniquet comes in and says he said subject
because he was still still imagining he was imagining he was
still in his king's court while he tweeted that. Okay, he was
still in writer mode.
>> Oh, okay. >> Was Cash the Cash the Brave? >> Even
the mega base was alarmed though who just >> Oh my goodness.
No, he was a wizard in the first book apparently. That was what
Raskin said. Although then he said night later on, so I'm a little
confused. just a few months ago sat in your chair as a Republican
witness observed that you performed terribly and he called for
your ouster. The FBI FBI might be able to survive your delusions
of grandeur and the explosively volatile temper that was on display
yesterday in the Senate. But the intractable problem is that
you are running the FBI not as a law enforcement agency charged
with keeping the American people safe, but as a political enforcement
agency working directly for the president's vengeance campaign.
7 months in, it's impossible to overstate the destruction, chaos,
and demoralization you've brought to the FBI and its workforce,
and the resulting danger your actions have caused to our country.
You've been systematically purging the FBI of its most experienced
and qualified agents, division leaders, and experts in counterterror,
counter intelligence, and cyber security. Precisely the people
who have the expertise you lack and which the FBI in the country
need. They've been expelled from the ranks of the bureau simply
because they did their duty investigating crimes, including those
committed by the mob that attacked the capital on January 6,
2021, and beat the hell out of more than 140 police officers,
or simply because you suspected them of being >> No, fell
pal. That's too far. >> Insufficiently loyal to Donald
Trump. You illegally sacked Brian Driscoll, the former acting
director of the bureau and a decorated counterterrorism expert
who worked at the FBI for nearly 20 years. According to Driscoll,
Driscoll, you told him your own job, quote, depended on the removal
of agents who worked on the cases against the president, regardless
of whether the agents chose to work on those cases or not. You
added, quote, "The FBI tried to put the president in jail, and
he hasn't forgotten it. You forced out the leader." So, that's
insane, right? That this Driscoll guy has come out and said,
"Cash Mattel just told them straight up, yeah, uh, me remaining
FBI director is actually predicated on me getting rid of Trump's
political enemies." Like I want to see Cash Pat Mattel say that's
absolutely not true. I want him on the record under oath saying,
"Yeah, yeah, no. I I didn't say that. I'd never say that, guys."
>> No, that's really believable when you look at the cover
of his kids book. I DM'd it to you. >> Oh god. What? What?
I told you he's a
Oh
god, bro. This guy is the head of the
>> Oh my goodness. What? What are we doing, guys? What's
going on over here? >> Salt Lakey Hotel. >> I like
I like Donkey Hotel.
>> either one. Okay. Um, no. He's a He's a wizard, though.
Famous Wizards. Merlin. That's too easy. I >> City Field
Office Metabs.
>> Oh, that would be funny to read the whole book on stream.
Art by Laura Vincent. Okay. >> Assassination forced out.
the leader of the Salt Lake City field office metab just weeks
before Charlie Krook's assassination, depriving the FBI of an
experienced counterterrorism expert described by her colleagues
as absolutely the best and legendary. She would have led the
FBI's manhunt had she not been fired when Trump decided they're
rounding up immigrants. >> This is actually a great tack
from uh from Raskin here, right? Hey, you're actually you the
reason you're soing incompetent is you fired a bunch of the people
who would have led the FBI in finding this guy. The reason that
you you got lucky and they got called, but the reason you guys
couldn't find them on your own, the reason you couldn't follow
any leads is the actual people who would carry out this investigation
have been let go. You fired your best people because they investigated
Donald Trump and you're a loser. It's a It's a very smart tactic.
I like this. >> With no criminal records was more important
than preventing crimes like human trafficking of women and girls,
drug dealing, terrorism, and fraud. You ordered the 25 largest
field offices to divert thousands of agents away from chasing
down violent criminals, sex traffickers, fraudsters, and scammers
to carry out. I'm shaking my head viferously at Saan.
Can we get Can we get Okay. Sarroman the white, but he's Sauron
the brown. Okay. And the first Urukai he pulls out is Dan Bongino.
Okay. Who Who do we whom do you serve?
Sarad.
Yeah. Okay. Thank you. >> This immigration crackdown. Director
Patel, you treated the men and women at FBI with disrespect and
paranoia. You've assembled a roving band of freelancing henchmen
within your office and charged them with conducting unauthorized
investigations, targeting and harassing career FBI employees.
Amazingly, you've forced senior leadership to repeatedly take
polygraph tests to prove their political loyalty and pushed out
leaders who refuse these demeaning.
We're uh we're going to actually look at that. There's an article.
Okay. We've got an article on him using polygraph
polygraphs to test people.
And now we're seeing one very clear >> No, no, no. This
is an allegation from July. By the way, this is an allegation
from July. Some senior official some senior officials who have
taken the test have been asked whether they said anything negative
about the FBI director Cash Patel. Like, yeah. >> Why you
want to build a political FBI? The Epstein files. You want an
FBI blindly loyal to Trump and to you as his enforcer. So you
>> like, sorry, just really quickly. This is why
it's concerning and we can't necessarily trust the FBI. Like
it's one thing to not trust institutions when those institutions
are largely like self-sufficient in a lot of ways, when they
largely are not being politicized, when when politicians know
that their their fellow politicians or the people in the FBI
will blow the whistle on them if they try to reach their tendrils
in and influence things. Not that it can happen. I believe it
did happen. And I believe that was actually what James Comey
was about when he reported that Loretta Lynch had that when he
basically talked about the Hillary memo and what Loretta Loretta
Lynch had been saying to him. I think that was the politicizing
slight politicizing of the FBI, but it was like done in a way
where it wasn't supposed to come back to the Clintons and it
was like, you know, kind of like ah it would be best if we didn't
do this and like but it's not a serious investigation, right?
No, it's not really. Okay. Could you like say it's like a matter?
Like that's that's the level of like that was a political scandal
at that point, right? was was the Clintons asked Loretta Lynch
and the FBI to refer to her investigation as a matter instead
of an investigation. That was the insane levels that like blew
up that elector. Oh my god, can you believe the bias of the FBI?
And now it's like, yeah, we're straight up doing polygraphs to
make sure that you're loyal to the FBI head and to Donald Trump.
And apparently that wasn't even enough to get me in on this and
and hear about this that they're using polygraphs. This is nuts,
right? This is this is like crazy insane levels of polit politicization
of weaponization. Anyway, uh yeah, so it's I just think it's
it's it's kind of wild to me that I don't know that we are where
we are. It's wild that this it's just eight years ago, right?
It's not even eight years ago yet. No, it's a little more than
eight years ago where we we actually like also the the tarmac
meeting happened too, but the the tarmac meeting and the the
matter bit I believe come back to back. I believe the matter
thing is what she discussed with Bill on the tarmac. I'm saying
what the ask was I believe. Okay. And that's like the that's
the bias showing there and that's what people were freaked out
about. This is Indian management style straight out of the gangies.
Okay. Now that's just overt. Bro, can you chill? Can you guys
chill in the Indians? >> You can continue your cover up
of a massive international trafficking ring with more than 1,000
victims betraying all of the survivors of this violence. Before
you got into this job, you called for full release of Epstein
files, telling podcaster Benny Johnson that the only reason the
list was not released by DOJ and FBI was quote because of who's
on that list. Upon your confirmation, you promised that quote,
there will be no cover-ups, no missing documents. >> Oh,
does Mr. Does Senator Rasin not know that Donald Trump is a White
Hat who a 15-year-old just to get the FBI more information on
Jeffrey Epstein? Does he not know that? We solved that one already,
Mr. Rasin. We solved that one. Donald Trump's innocent. >> No
stone left unturned. And anyone from the prior current bureau
who undermines this will be swiftly pursued. This spring, you
ordered hundreds of agents to pour over all the Epstein files,
but not to look for more clues about the money network or the
network of human traffickers. You pulled these agents from their
regular counterterrorism or drug trafficking duties to work around
the clock. Some of them sleeping at their desks to conduct a
frantic search to make sure Donald Trump's name and image were
flagged and redacted wherever they appeared, whether an email,
a text, a letter, an interview, a photograph, or a video. In
May, Attorney General Bonti reportedly told Trump that his name
had indeed appeared multiple times throughout the Epstein files.
And not long there after in July, you and the Attorney General
released a memo claiming that quote, "No further disclosure would
be appropriate or warranted." in a few short months. How did
you go from being a crusader for accountability and transparency
for the Epstein files to being a part of the conspiracy and cover
up? The answer is simple. You said it yourself. Because of who's
on that list. Donald Trump's relationship with Epstein over the
years is well documented. A week ago, the oversight committee
released Trump's disturbing birthday book, Note to Epstein, written
over a drawing of a woman's naked body, referring to a quote,
wonderful secret. The oversight committee obtained the >> Dude,
have you guys ever thought about how congressional oversight
committees are sort of like snark discords? Have you ever thought
about this? You guys ever have you? This is like actually just
snarking. Like, why is this guy so obsessed with Cash Patel?
Can anybody tell me why he's so obsessed? He's just like learned
everything about Cash Patel just so he can talk him. It's kind
of gross. the note from the Epstein estate, not from the FBI,
raising questions again of whether the FBI has been withholding
documents. While you're unleashing the FBI to cater to Trump's
desire to shut down the Epstein inquiry, the first nine months
of the Trump presidency have seen a spate of political violence
and domestic terror events. We saw deadly attacks on political
figures on both the left and the right. the brutal assassination
of Minnesota Democratic House Speaker Melissa Hortman and her
husband in the attempted murder of Democratic state senator John
Hoffman and his wife who miraculously survived a combined 17
gunshots. We saw an arsonist set Pennsylvania Governor Josh Shapiro's
residence on fire. And of course, last week we saw the horrific
cold-blooded assassination of Charlie Kirk in Utah that has shaken
the nation. One minute after Charlie Kirk was shot in the neck,
um a 16-year-old shooter in Evergreen, Colorado, radicalized
by white supremacist ideology online, opened fire and critically
wounded two other students at Evergreen High School. We've seen
lethal anti-semitic violence including the murder of two young
Israeli embassy staff. >> Also, for a second, my headphones
are clicking. One second. >> Okay, I'm back. All right.
Um, >> welcome back. >> Oh, I'm not back. Didn't
hear whatever that was. >> You are not back. >> Not
back. Hello, Mr. There we go. >> I can hear you. We're
back now. Yeah. Well, my headphones were back. Okay, we're back.
I can't remember what I was just going to say. >> Evergreen
High School. >> Oh, the white supremacist shooter. That
was the same day. I didn't hear that. I didn't see anything showing
that it was a white supremacist ideology that radicalized them.
>> Oh, the high school shooting. >> Yeah. I mean,
I heard about the shooting. I just didn't hear the outcome that
was like a white supremacist shooter or something. I just didn't
I didn't hear about that. Maybe I need to see some evidence of
that or like I just I hadn't seen it because it was obviously
the Charlie Kirk was way bigger, right? So >> yeah, yeah,
yeah. >> We've seen lethal anti >> Hassan post something
>> violence, including the murder of two young Israeli
embassy staffers just blocks from the capital and then in the
attack on a gathering of Jewish people in support of hostages
held in Gaza in Boulder in June. We've seen continued mass shootings
at schools like the domestic terror incident at a Catholic school
in Minneapolis last month, which killed two children and wounded
18 others. And in August, a man fired more than 500 bullets at
the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention, killing a police
officer who was a Marine veteran and a father. People like Melissa
Hortman and Charlie Kirk should be able to participate in politics
as elected officials or active citizens without being shot down
in cold blood in the United States of America. People should
also be able to go to elementary school, to middle school, to
high school, to work, to the mall, and to church, without being
shot down in explosions of gun violence. The >> No, no,
there's no reason. Listen, those those elementary schoolers have
an a second amendment right to be shot down. Okay? They they've
got a second amendment right to have that happen. All right.
Can we can we respect the constitution? Mr. Raskin,
>> Important position at the FBI requires a leader who
puts public safety and national security and the rule of law
first. I'm afraid, Director Patel, you've given us reason to
believe you've used the powers of the FBI to serve Donald Trump
and his agenda of partisan retribution. You've broken your promise
not to do that. You've betrayed Jeffrey Epstein's victims and
survivors. You've turned your back on the career law enforcement
officers of the FBI and as a result you've left us you've left
all of us less less safe than before. Mr. Chairman, I yield back.
>> Gentleman yields back. That opening statement may have
been longer than any book the director's ever written or anyone
else has written. Um without objection, all of the opening statements
will be included in the record. We will now introduce today's
witness. Mr. >> Yeah, the director wrote children's books.
Jim, that's probably why this took a little bit longer. We're
talking about FBI corruption here, Jim. Something you used to
care about, Jim. Mr. Patel has been the director of the FBI since
February of 2025. He previously served as chief of staff at the
Department of Defense, deputy director of national intelligence
with the National Security Council and and also as a congressional
staffer as a federal prosecutor where he focused on national
security cases and he also worked as a public defender in the
state of Florida. We welcome our witness. Appreciate his work
and thank him for appearing here today. Will we begin by swearing
you in? Director, would you please stand? Uh raise your right
hand. Do you >> Okay. Okay. It is ADL that did the research
that is leading to a lot of people reporting on the high schooler,
the shooter having a deep fascination with
and um like those leanings of
>> Well, I will have to see the evidence because I I feel
like anything published by the ADL is questionable. Yeah, I I
would have to see that evidence now. >> Penalty of perjury
that the testimony you're about to give is true and correct to
the best of your knowledge, information, and belief. So, help
you God. That the record >> Okay. Okay. I see. witnesses
answered in the affirmative. You can be seated as you are. Um,
you know, you've been through this, you've been through this
yesterday, did a fine job. Please note that your written testimony
will be entered into the record and it's entirely accordingly.
We ask that you summarize your testimony. Uh, director, you may
begin. >> Good morning, Mr. Chairman, ranking member Rasking
and members of the committee. I want to begin today by discussing
the appalling assassination of Charlie Kirk. It's important for
this FBI to be transparent without jeopardizing our investigations.
So, a little bit of the timeline is important. Charlie Kirk was
unfortunately assassinated on September. >> Wait, why?
Hold on. The timeline is not important. None of no part of his
timeline is ever important. He just reruns like basically we
were spending a lot of money, guys. That's all he talks about
every time. >> 10th, we immediately the next day released
images early in the day in local time in Utah to start the public
partnership in our manhunt for the assassin and culprits. At
um approximately 5 pm local time, I arrived on the ground and
walked the crime scene myself and we flew multiple FBI assets
in and out to process DNA simultaneously while bringing in evidence
response technicians, hostage rescue teams, and >> new
guys. JTO cash stare, right? Cash stare. Let's go. Let's go.
>> To assist state and local law enforcement with their
investigation. At 8:00 p.m. local on September 11th, the FBI
collected and populated and promulgated at a press conference
a video of the suspect on the grounds. We also released enhanced
images. Due to that release that I directed and ordered, the
suspect involved was apprehended and in custody at 10 p.m. local
time. That's less than two hours after we did the video release
and the photo release. So, within 33 hours, that individual suspect
was in custody. And his family, who has since been interrogated,
specifically stated two FBI interrogators that because of the
video that the FBI released at my direction and because of the
photographs that they released, they identified their son. They
can. >> Dude, there's no way the bar is Well, we released
a a a video of him walking and and a photo and that's why the
FBI got this guy. Okay, that's the that's the expertise I bring
to the FBI. We released a photo of this dude and then his family
turned him in. That's our hard-hitting investigative approach.
>> Good police work. That's just good. >> Fronted
their son.
>> When he swung by their home and that's what led to his
apprehension. Um, we are still, the FBI has that investigation
ongoing and it continues to be ongoing. And I want to thank the
state of Utah and the state and local authorities there. And
I also want to thank the attorney general and President Trump
for directing resources to allow us to conduct that investigation
as we have under this administration. The FBI has arrested more
than 23,000 violent criminals. 23,000 in 7 months. That's twice
as many year to date last year. We've taken over 6,000 firearms
off the streets. 6,000 guns are no longer in the hands of criminals.
In 7 months, we've identified and found and located 4,700 child
victims. That is a 35% increase year-to- date last year. We've
arrested 1,500 child predators. That is a 10% increase year-to-
date last year. In just 7 months, we've assisted our partners
with countless counterterrorism operations around the world.
We've captured at the FBI four of the most top 10 wanted fug
>> uh this didn't happen. tourniquet. Um, I think Cherry
said the only reporting she saw in it so far was from the ADL,
but she literally had just Googled it like 10 seconds earlier.
She didn't say that the ADL is the only per people who have said
this. Just stop losing your mind. >> I said that the other
places were sourcing the ADL.
>> Right. There's I was looking at like USA Today. I was
looking at several other like posts and they're sourcing the
ADL's research. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> There might be
more out there, but yeah, that was just my like initial finding.
>> Yeah. in the world in 7 months. To put that in perspective,
that's as many as my predecessor nabbed in the entirety of the
Biden administration. We got four. We got more coming. On top
of that, in two weeks, thanks to the help of the CIA, we collected
and captured one of the individuals responsible for the horrific
Abigate bombing that led to the murder of 13 service members.
We did that in two weeks. They didn't do it in the four years
of the entire priority prior administration. Nationwide, we've
been executing our operation summer heat, the FBI's national
focus. This guy is losing his This guy realizes he's gonna get
fired. He's like, I have to make myself self sound competent
now. I got to talk about all the we've done, guys. Violent crime
based on intelligence driven operations.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Ask the citizens of Seattle, Miami,
Memphis, Charlotte, Chicago, New Orleans. Um to specifically
highlight New Orleans and Nashville. There has been a 250%
increase in violent crime arrests in those cities alone and other
mid- major cities that I've just listed. In just a few short
months, we have already unleashed a thousand FBI personnel across
this country. Every single state across this country is getting
a plus up. This is a fiction that the FBI is short or that we
are compromising the men and women in the field. They do not
need to be in Washington DC. So, we're sending them into the
field to each and every one of your states. Because of that,
crime is at an all-time low. We had to do it because of the explosion
of crime. And maybe the most important stat for Americans to
realize, in just 7 months, we are on track to produce the lowest
murder rate in modern US history by double digits. Those are
results not of mine. Those are results of the men and women of
the FBI. If you want to criticize me, bring it on, but do not
attack the brave leaders in the field. We are also working >> Why
would the murder rate have anything to do with the FBI? That's
totally That's maybe the most moronic. That's like literally
him explaining that he doesn't understand how police work happens.
He doesn't understand his job. He doesn't understand the FBI's
job. I
>> 24/7 365 on the opioid epidemic that has killed more
than hundreds of thousand people a year. We have seen 1600 kg
of fentanyl off the streets so far in 7 months. Year-to- date
25% increase. To put that in perspective, that's enough to kill
a third of the American population, 120 million Americans. 100,000
kilograms of men gone off the streets. Earlier this year, I highlighted
in Cincinnati, Ohio, how we're getting creative to chase down
those that were willing to do harm to our citizens. Not just
by striking at the heart of the fentinol producers, but the fentinol
precursor companies in China. And we indicted for the first time
multiple companies and individuals. >> Check his stats.
He's so stupid. They were taking credit for stuff that was already
happening. So just like more normalization from COVID, like more
like crime rates were dropping from basically like 3 four years
ago. Like the whole time I'm guessing stuff was just steadily
decreasing, right? M speech was so long I don't really remember
him criticizing the FBI and more just criticism of cash. Yeah.
No, he wasn't criticizing. He was just criticizing Cash Patel
and Cash Patel's policies. That was it. >> Not just in
America, but in mainland China that are producing the ingredients
that produce and make fentinel that kill our children. And we're
going to keep going. Counterterrorism work, cyber attacks, and
foreign adversaries are something the FBI must never sleep on.
And we are not sleeping. In the counter intelligence space alone,
this year, year to date, 30% increase in counter intelligence
arrests from the DPRK, Russia, Iran, and China. And I want the
American people to know in this setting, there's a lot of work
that the brave men and women of the FBI are doing. just can't
get into but they don't stop our cyber threats, ransomware attacks,
those harming our children online. We have nearly a 20% increase
in indictments arrests in 7 months alone. >> Uh cacophonies,
the FBI is behind like long-term strategy like a year-over-year
crackdown. He couldn't possibly take credit for a year-over-year
crackdown
this year. We're going after those that harm our malware, infrastructure
systems, telecom systems, and energy structure. Combating salt
and vault typhoons are just a little bit of the examples we're
doing. Maybe most importantly under the counterterrorism and
domestic terrorism umbrella are nest violent extremist and those
that label themselves 764 who wish to go online and convince
children to maim and mutilate themselves and commit and we are
producing record numbers of arrests under that umbrella organization.
We even stopped an individual in the 764 network who wanted to
conspire to kill an adolescent girl. He is now in custody. Transparency
remains one of my main priorities at the FBI and this is what
I've done in my seven months at the helm. We've produced more
than 33,000 pages of documents to Congress to a variety of committees,
including, I believe, 12 uh 7,500 to this committee alone, if
memory serves me. >> Oh, somebody get me a bigger version
of cash there, then I'll re-upload it. I have like a low quality,
like a low resolution image, but give me a higher resolution
image. I'll fix it. 500 by 500 if you can. >> Correct.
To put the 33,000 in perspective, my predecessor in seven years
produced 13,000 pages in total to the United States Congress.
His predecessor in four years produced 3,000 pages in total.
I repeat, I have produced 33,000 pages in 7 years to this Congress
and will continue to do so. I'm dedicated to restoring the trust
and the mission and the integrity of the FBI and we cannot do
so without congressional oversight and I promise you I will continue
to do so. On the Epstein case, the original sin on the Epstein
case was how it was handled by Mr. Aosta when he first brought
the case in 2006 7 and 8. The original case had a very limited
search warrant, had a very limited search window, had a very
limited investigative window. I was not there when those search
warrants and that investigation was launched. I would not have
done it that way. They were limited to only three to four years
of investigations from 97 to approximately 2001 and 2002 to 2005.
Mr. Aosta allowed Mr. Epstein to enter into a plea agreement
where he served weekend jails for trafficking minor women. He
also was allowed to relieve jail to go home on the weekends.
Plus, he allowed a defer a non-prosecution agreement to be this
guy's just blaming everybody else for Bro, just release the files.
Like, all the stuff that they the that Raskin was like grilling
you for is all you've done as FBI director. He's not grilling
you over the FBI's incompetence over the past 20 years. He's
saying, "Hey, you said you'd release these files. You haven't
done it." >> He signed as part of that plea deal, prohibiting
future investigations from that prosecution and from that evidence
and prohibiting the collection of further material. That is the
original sin. We are working with Congress to produce more than
any administration ever has material on Epstein. And I welcome
the challenge to tell us that we are not being as transparent
as the law allows. We even went to court and asked the judges
to lift those prosecutorial agreements and to lift those court
order seals and they denied us three times. Congress is welcome
to do the same and join the fight. And I'd lastly like to focus
on operation that the president led in DC. Because of this, we
are taking this fight in DC to every single city across the country.
2100 arrests in the last month alone. DC has seen a 60% decrease
in gun crimes, 75% decrease in carjackings, and 53% decrease
in homicides in our nation's capital. And rightly so, we're bringing
that fight to the streets of America. I want to thank you for
your support, and I'm proud to be the director that leads this
FBI into a new headquarters building that they've needed for
decades, saving the taxpayer three and a half billions of dollars,
and also providing our workforce a safe environment. If you don't
know the calamity that is the Hoover building, I invite each
and every one of you to walk around. And I'll give you a tour
myself and you can see where the cement falls on the heads of
our our employees that is only to be saved by netting just to
give you an example. Thank you for support to our mission and
um I do want to highlight one thing about DC >> [__]
Who cares? >> It's because the FBI gathered sources and
evidence that we were able to through our source network identify
the horrific murder of the DC intern Eric Tarpinian. And I've
spoken to his family and um you know we are working to bring
them justice and Mr. Chairman in my 16 years now my 17 years
of government service if anyone has any questions about my service.
>> That's the case. Why did Trump say DC's crime rate is
at an all-time high? Uh Trump's going to say everything's at
a all-time high because he wants to use the National Guard to
go into cities, right? He wants to actually like weaponize. He
he wants to actually push military presence into cities. So Cash
Patel is kind of undercutting him here in a pretty brutal way.
Uh I'm guessing this will go very similar to how it went for
Tulsi Gabbard. Well, Tulsi Gabbard said Iran has no s no signs
of a nuclear weapon. And then Trump goes, "No, she's wrong."
And she goes, "Yeah, I was wrong. I just are total." I'm guessing
Cash will do the same thing. Sorry, you were about to say something.
>> No, I'm just laughing.
>> Okay, awesome. Bring it on. >> Yeah, thank you,
director. >> I love I love when people laugh at my jokes.
Happens so rarely. >> We will now proceed into the five-minute
rule. The chair recognizes the gentleman laugh. I get it.
>> Director, delighted to have you here. You are a breath
of fresh air. As you outlined, and I won't repeat it, uh the
accomplishments, you did so with the same resources as your predecessor,
roughly. Is that correct? >> I believe so. Yes. And so
how much of that uh has to do with taking people out of the backside
of the FBI and moving them into the field into doing the job
for which we primarily pay the FBI? >> It's exactly what
we needed done. Onethird of the FBI's workforce resided in the
national capital region before I got there. One third of the
crimes do not happen in Washington DC. >> Not anymore.
>> Not anymore. So 1,000 personnel of the FBI were deployed
across this country on a permanent basis. And every single state
in this union is getting a plus up, not a reduction, a plus up
of 1811s of intel analyst and support staff. And that is why
the crime rates are going down in record numbers. >> Well,
thank you for doing that. And and you know, it's it's perhaps
the hardest thing for a bureaucrat to do is to lower the headcount
around them that support them. And I appreciate your willingness
to do it different than your >> I'll just be real. Um
the Republican circle jerk comments we're probably going to skip
past. Okay. I'll give this one a little bit of time, but I'm
guessing we're mostly going to just sweep by these. I don't super
care except Hold on. There is one. No, no, no, no. There is one
Republican that we will listen to, okay? And that's our boy
>> Thomas Massie. Okay, we'll watch when Thomas whenever
Thomas Massie comes up. We we in this house, we salute Thomas
Massie, okay? The the the portrait of Thomas Massie. We love
this guy. All right. Only Republican with any amount of spine
left. We love this dude. >> You a lot of what you you uh
covered earlier was the find the discovery and
this is the beginning of what we need. But my questions today
by this administration the kind that in the wake of the tragic
murder of Charlie Kirk. >> Nice. Hold on. >> Thank
you, Mr. Chairman. Back my four >> Thank you. Gentleman
yields back. Gentleman from New York is recognized. >> Thank
you, Mr. Chairman. Welcome, Director Patel. In the wake of the
tragic murder of Charlie Kirk, Donald Trump said, uh, quote,
"Violence and murder are the >> He's from New York. He's
kind of got the accent a little bit. Uhoh. >> Tragic consequences
of demoniz. >> Mr. Nadler, please. Novetching
voices here. We don't want it. We don't want it, Jerry." >> Those
with whom you disagree. day after day, year after year, in the
most hateful and desicable way possible. Close quote. I would
note for the record that Donald Trump has famously dis demonized
practically every person he has ever disagreed with. And therefore,
using his own logic, he has put their lives at risk. I should
know. >> Oh, come on. Hello. >> About two weeks ago
when I announced my >> Was that Was that an internet hiccup?
Did you guys all get that? Was that just me? Hold on. Did that
go through everything else? We good? We back. Hello. Hello. I
don't hear Cherry, which is not good. >> Hello. Hello.
>> You have a hiccup. I saw like a >> this video
buffer. Okay. I thought I thought everything hiccuped because
I saw Chad hiccup as well. >> My decision not to go. When
I announced my my decision not to seek re-election, many people
on both sides of the aisle, including the chairman, offered me
wellwishes and thank me for my service. Donald Trump, on the
other hand, took the true social to call me a quote psychopathic
nut job, among other things. Yesterday, I received a threatening
note filled with anti-semitic comments and hateful attacks that
mimic some of the same language used by the president. I am sure
many of us on this committee face similar threats every day.
We have seen political assaults on both the left and the right.
The attack on Charlie Kirk, the attempted assassination of the
president, the murder of the Democratic speaker of the Minnesota
House, the assault on Paul Pelosi, and the attack on the capital
on January 6, for example. Director Patel, do you agree that
there is political violence from both the left and the right?
>> There is too much political violence. >> You agree,
yes or no, that there's >> There is too much political
violence based on ideologies from either side. >> Do you
from either side? Okay. Are you aware of the study by the Kato
Institute, a well-known conservative group that found that 69%
of the violence is from the right? >> I'm not familiar
with that study. >> You're not familiar? Okay. I I I would
commend it to you. Are you aware the administration's threatened
to use violence as an excuse to crack down on liberty and freedom
of speech? >> Yeah. I don't Dude, what is going on with
the audio here? You guys getting this? Hold on. Hold on. >> Between
the two guys. >> Say that again. I'm sorry. >> Are
you aware the administration >> The audio is like totally
off has threatened to use violence as an excuse to crack down
on liberty and freedom of speech? Nobody at the FBI is doing
that. >> I didn't ask you about the FBI. I said the administration.
>> I think the I think the video is just like that. I think
it's just a video. >> The FBI said the administration.
>> I speak for the FBI.
>> I would like to add to the record an article from today's
New York Times titled Trump invokes Kirk's and
measures to silence opponents. In the wake of Charlie Kirk's
President Trump and his allies have laid out a broad plan to
target liberal groups, monitor speech, revoke visas, and designate
certain groups as domestic terrorists. Ask unanimous consent
to insert this into the record. Thank you. Politicizing the murder
of Charlie King to go after free speech is uh >> not a
legacy I believe >> Charlie King >> Charlie King
>> Charlie King would have wanted >> Wait, he said
it twice. Oh, it wasn't even just a momentary uh >> ohizing
the murder of Charlie King to go after free speech is not a legacy
I believe Charlie King would have wanted. >> Dude, uh Republicans
are going to lose >> Moving on, I want to address another
topic. The FBI has traditionally played a key role in prosecuting
public officials for corruption. But I fear that at a time when
the president is accepting planes from cutter for his post-presidential
personal use, issuing pardons to major donors, and personally
profiting from the office of the presidency, the FBI may be abandoning
its commitment to investigating public corruption. Since its
creation in the wake of the Watergate scandal, the public integrity
section has been one of the crown jewels of the Department of
Justice, investigating and prosecuting corruption among the nation's
public officials and acting as a key safeguard against politicized
prosecutions. This section's work has been supported by an elite
squad in the FBI devoted specifically to rooting out corruption.
But according to reports, the public integrity section has now
been decimated and the FBI's public corruption squad has been
dismantled. I would like to submit for the record a New York
Times article entitled FBI dismantles elite public corruption
squad. I ask unanimous >> Oh Jesus. I wish sometimes I
really wish these guys would actually just ask direct questions.
Sometimes they do soapbox way too long. Like lots of these would
be good as questions. Like did you actually dismantle this squad?
Like what happened with the squad? I would want to know, but
he's been talking for so long. >> Like uh Cash could just
pick like one of a dozen different questions he's asked at this
point to to actually like engage with. So >> these actions
are an invitation to corrupt politicians to break the law since
they know that the government is asleep at the switch. Last month,
Senator Warren and I along with dozens of other members of Congress
wrote to you and Attorney General Bundy expressing grave concern
over your decision to effectively legalize corruption and politicize
prosecu prosecutorial decisions and he ask unanimous consent
to enter this letter into the record.
>> Thank you. I don't have time today to walk through all
your questions, all of our questions and concerns, but will you
commit to answering this letter in short order so that we can
understand what factors led to this decision and how it has impacted
the ability to hold corrupt officials accountable? I will review
I will review your letter with my team and respond as soon as
>> you will respond. Thank you. I yield back uh the balance
of my time. >> Gentleman yields back. Gentleman from Arizona
is recognized for five minutes. >> Thank you, Mr. Chairman,
and thank you, director, for being here. I appreciate >> So,
Cherry just didn't even ask a single question to Cash. He just
he just Sorry, he asked one single question right at the end
and just like ranted for a >> The change in the FBI and
the tone since you've been there. Um, we heard the ranking member,
however, describe uh the FBI under your leadership as being resorting
to political enforcement and you personally as being paranoid.
I would just suggest that perhaps that is the projections of
the ranking member himself and not you, sir. I want to refer
to something that was >> okay. I don't care. I I'm never
going to care. Um, some dude, next dude to come up from the Democrats
actually is a clip of of Cash Patel talking to Benny >> Thank
you kindly, Mr. Chairman. Uh, Director Patel, before you joined
the FBI, you railed against it for covering up Jeffrey Epstein's
human trafficking ring. Let me refresh your memory with this
clip. >> Oh, it's Rasin's next again. It >> has Epste's
list. They're sitting on it. That doesn't seem like something
you should do. You're protecting the world's foremost predator.
That seems like an evil thing to do regardless of who may be
embarrassed in the release of that list. Why is the FBI protecting
the greatest pedest um the the largest Why is the FBI protecting
the greatest pedest um the the largest scale pedest in human
history? >> Simple. Because of who's on that list. So,
you finished that December 2023 interview with a challenge to
the FBI and harsh words for Republicans in Congress for not getting
the Epstein files out to the public. You can see this clip. >> Boy
pants and let us know who the are. >> Put on your big boy
pants and let us know who the are. You said you emphasized that
the president and FBI director each had complete authority to
release Epstein's client list. You said Epstein's black book
is under the quote direct control of the director of the FBI.
Look at this clip. I mean, this is way off the topic, but who
has Jeffrey
>> but who that is that that I mean, >> Well, that's
under direct control of the director of the FBI. >> All right.
So, you were sworn in as director more than 200 days ago. Now,
the black book is under your direct control. So, why haven't
you released the names of Epstein's co-conspirators in the trafficking?
so it's now it's just entirely on him.
>> Of young women and girls. The Rolodex, which is what
everybody colloquially refers to as the black book, has been
>> Oh, no. You're talking about what the journalist got
five years ago. No, that's not what we're talking about. We're
talking about what you were talking about there. The black book
under the direct control of FBI >> We have released more
material than anyone else before. >> That's that's that's
an odd sector. Oh boy. He's just going off in a general direction.
The >> B administration, Obama administration had the exact
opportunities to release this material and they never did. And
if you are selling the men and women of the FBI, hang on. You
said we're not going after child predators. 1,500 child predators
arrested this year. >> You get to be the liar on the podcast
or the liar now. Where are you the liar? Cash, where are you
lying? You're lying in one of these places. Just tell me which
time you lied. >> I'll
make sure I'm going to reclaim my time if you could instruct
the witness. Um, why have you changed your position there? You
were saying it's under the direct control of the FBI director
and all of it should be released. Why? Why? >> Everything
that has been lawfully permitted to be released has been released.
And as I told you, the investigation was limited. And let me
make something crystal clear. I never said Jeffrey Epstein didn't
traffic other people, other women, and they're not other victims.
This is the investigation we were given from 2006, 77, and 8.
And the search warrants from 2006, 77, and 8. That's what we're
working with. >> Wait, have you released all of the stuff
that the FBI has seized from Epstein's house? The computers,
the emails, the file cabinets, the documents. What about the
financial records? Have you released all of that? >> Everything
the court has allowed us to >> Which court are you talking
about? >> Three separate federal courts have come in and
said, >> "We're talking about the evidence you've got.
It's got nothing to do with what those courts have. >> Do
you have any idea how the law works? Do you want me to break
the law in a federal judge's order? >> No, I want you to
follow your own word, Director Patel. You said up there it was
under the direct control of the FBI director. He had the black
have direct control over. We have gone to court. You have completely
sentenced everything. >> the uh the answer here is just
cash lied. He would make anything up on those podcasts to sound
good. He just totally lied. And now he's kind of been confronted
with how reality works, right? But now it's really funny that
he has indignation for Mr. asking when he had no idea how reality
worked. He was the He's the one who made the statements. You
He's just hitting you with your own statements, Cash. Okay. Come
on. >> You have direct control over. You said >> have
gone to court and everything we have direct control. >> Complete
your sentence. You said >> fully release, they're releasing.
He'd like to complete his answer. >> You You began the
sentence. Everything you have direct control over, I And then
you stopped that sentence. You've released everything that you
have direct control over. >> I have direct control over
and can lawfully release. If you're not familiar with the court
orders, that's not my fault. Look at that. I'm perfectly familiar
with them, but how did we prosecute um Galain Maxwell? >> She
was she was prosecuted with the investigatory material that was
collected from 2001 and 2005 because of the non-prosecution agreements
and the court orders on the investigations and search warrants.
We were not able to develop new information. And oh, by the way,
Jeffrey Epstein was out for 12 years and the Obama Biden administration
did nothing to look at his work, his network. If you want to
blame me, that's fine. But now you're blaming the men and women
who conducted this. >> Stop that. I'm not blaming anybody
other than you. You're not keeping your word. You said that you
would release all of the materials. >> Anyone released
more information on MC than I have? Has anyone Comey did right.
>> Much much more I'm excuse me much more has come out
in the days since the American people in Congress have been demanding
it. But it's coming out in dribbs and draps. Why don't you just
release the entire file as you promised to do? >> I literally
just told you there are multiple federal court orders. I'm not
going to break the law to satisfy your curiosity. You didn't
join us when we filed court to release the court orders. You
could have. You have lawyers. You could have shown up. You didn't
do that. >> That's a tiny fraction of the material we're
talking about. It is tiny. >> How do you know that? Have
you seen everything? It's all mire. The >> time of the
gentleman has expired. The gentleman from California is recognized.
>> Well, thank you, Mr. Director. Just to be clear, how
many of the Epstein files were released in the four years of
the Biden administration? >> Okay, that looks good to people
on his side, right?
Court order. You didn't join us. You and your lawyers, you didn't
join us. Yeah, it does. >> Uh it it could look good. >> I
don't even know what it means, but it >> Yeah, I don't
I don't know. Like, is he talking about Rasin personally or I'm
actually not sure. Yeah, I think he's talking about him personally,
right? Because I mean, everyone's looking back and I'll tell
you from
just from outsider, it looks like when a lot of people say the
Congress passed a thing to keep Epstein files concealed, when
he points at this dude and he's like, "You didn't join us." I'm
like associating all of those things together. I'm thinking,
"Oh, okay. FBI director is pursuing to try to be able to release
some of these things and this guy is pretending like he wants
to but he's not helping. >> Um yeah. Yeah. Well, I mean
it looks good to it looks like that. Yes. The reality is and
I think the direction you push in is you were just lying before
you became FBI director because you had no idea what would actually
be required here, right? Like probably a lot of the other FBI
directors could be just as bound as you are now, but you had
no idea about it and you were just lying to gain your position
to gain favor with the Trump White House. That's that's I think
the direction he could have gone in because it's just obvious
to me that he was lying the whole time. >> Well, that's
the direction he tried to go in, right? You're trying to say,
"Oh, look, back then you said you could do it and now Cash is
like I'm going up like legal battles. I have to go against these
like court orders. You're not helping me in these court orders.
You're one of this you're one of the sitting Congress people
who is not helping going through these court orders." I think
that looks really bad on that dude. If that's true,
>> I need like a correction on that. >> Yeah. I have
no idea what the actual fact of the matter is. I have no idea
if like would you even have authority to join that in any way
as a private >> Exactly. I need to understand like why
does it sound like that lands? >> Cuz cash has been working
on anything he can do to sound good. And that's the the one opportunity
he's got right there. >> I that's like the first time he's
ever sounded good to me. >> Oh, hold on. Obstacle says
Jtock. I'm just reading that the FBI has been trying to release
grand jury testimony which the judges have been denying, not
investigative material. Okay. So, none of the actual like anything
to do with a black book, anything like that. It's just been testimony.
So, the black book that he said he could release is not getting
blocked by a judge. Interesting.
All right. >> And then I just had to pull up a quick picture
of Jamie Rasin. How I used to remember him. I don't really I
keep forgetting his name. Okay. When are we getting the perm
back? Jamie, when's the perm coming back? I don't like this haircut.
I want the perm back. Can we get Jamie his perm back, please?
Wait, there's no way he uh Oh, he he had cancer. Oh, I feel terrible
now. Oh, I feel I feel terrible. Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Uh-oh. Hold on.
That Wait, that explains the That explains the do-agg picture.
That explains this one. Okay, that now I understand where this
came from. Now I get it. This makes way more sense now. I thought
this was just photoshopped or something. Uh-oh. >> Oh,
hell no. >> Prison mic over here. Let's go. Okay.
>> And how many have you released? I >> I don't have
the number, but it's got to be thousands of pages of stuff. >> I
I was going to ask you uh to begin whether Americans are safer
today than they were 9 months ago, but you cited dramatic increases
in criminal arrests since you've taken office, a dramatic decrease
in crime that's resulted. Who would have thought that taking
criminals off the streets would reduce the crime rate? But but
uh somehow we have stumbled upon that that new truth. But it
begs the question, what was the FBI doing during the four years
of the Biden administration to to to see that dramatic an increase
in work under
>> a little bit I I would like to see cash take both sides
of this and say or like kind of both sides to say actually the
FBI, you know, it's an organization I'm a part of. I understand
I they do great work, right? Don't just sh on the FBI before
you had it. It's an institution you're the head of. You do take
responsibility. you are the figurehead of this institution. You're
responsible for its whole history, whether that's fair or not.
So, I I hope he doesn't just go, "Oh, well, under the Biden administration,
they're like really they're just, you know, they're basically
just smoking pot and hanging out. They didn't do anything." >> The
simple answer is I'm letting good >> I hope not be cops.
>> Increase in work under under your >> simple answer
is I'm letting good cops be cops. We're working with our state
and local law enforcement. We're energizing our partnerships.
We're bringing on more task force officers. When you have more
cops in the streets, when you're using groundbased intelligence,
when you're not weaponizing law enforcement and focusing on DC
and focusing on the rest of America, this is what happens. It
is not a significant mind shift in terms of how we maneuver the
FBI. >> We just let cops be cops. We just got to let the
cops be cops, guys. Okay? That's the secret to getting all the
crime cleaned up. We just let the cops be
>> Let cops beat their wives. >> They've wanted to
do this work since they signed up. We're just letting and u we've
seen many prominent Democrats oppose your efforts to restore
law and order to the streets of our nation's capital. I mean
all of us here >> pray for Mrs. Points. Okay. Pray >> seen
a dramatic change for the better here in Washington DC
not remain a cop. >> Our nation's capital and all of us
here have seen a dramatic change for the better here in Washington
DC. Why are so many Democrats attacking you for that? >> Sir,
Democrats have been attacking me for a decade as is the fake
news media. They didn't like the fact that I exposed a Russia
gays host and the largest weaponization of the FBI DOJ in US
history. We proved it to be true with congressional oversight.
>> Really? Like more than McCarthyism.
The the crossfire hurricane on the on the one what is it? The
um Oh, it's a it's like a Why can't I remember the name? It was
like a Patriot Act subpoena. What is it called? FISA. The one
FISA warrant. One FISA warrant on the Carter P on Carter Page
is worse than all McCarthyism apparently guys. The biggest scandal,
the biggest corruption scandal in FBI history, apparently. Incredible
>> I'm w to that congressional oversight and will continue
to do that work. >> Christopher Ray repeatedly warned this
committee that the Biden open borders policy had produced a significant
increase in terrorist threats that he said kept him up at night.
Um, the particular concern he said was a >> Okay, hold
on, hold on, hold on. Uh, important context here, guys. Important
context. All right. So, factor nine, this is for why they want
to seal the grand jury testimony. Factor nine, the additional
need for maintaining secrecy in the particular case in question.
The Epstein grand jury materials are subject to the provisions
of federal rule of criminal procedure 6E, including rule six
exceptions. See pages 4 to 5 supra, and in the second circuit,
unsealing applications are subject to special circumstances,
jurist prudence, blah blah blah blah blah. The information contained
in the Epstein grand jury transcripts pales in comparison to
the Epstein investigation information and materials in the hands
of the Department of Justice. See discussion at pages 8 to9 supra
concerning victim's rights and importance of protecting victim's
safety, privacy, and dignity. Factor 9 favors continued sealing.
So they basically go, "The reason we'll seal this these transcripts
is because we have such an overwhelming amount of evidence. You
actually don't need the testimony from this these transcripts
to publicize whatever you need to publicize. this can be remained
private because it just doesn't need to be made public. There's
way more information in the actual Epstein files themselves,
the actual investigative materials. So, when he says, "Oh, this
has all been sealed." >> Well, I'm just saying when he
says, "This has all been sealed." None of the investigative materials
have been sealed. All that has been sealed is the grand jury
testimony. Yeah, but I'm I'm saying him focusing on the the testimony
to have that unsealed.
You would say that's almost like offiscating and just muddying
this entire scenario so that people scrutinize the victim statements,
victim testimony, probably directs harassment to the victims
when they don't need that. >> Oh, you could say you could
say things like that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. that like that would
be why that I mean that is a part of the the factor n is they're
saying it's actually better that we maintain victim secrecy here
because there is no new information essentially like we could
keep them anonymous we we don't have to release any of this.
Yeah.
>> Cool. Great time. So cash is a liar as if we didn't
know. >> Two million gotaways that entered the country
during the Biden administration. I think the the to me the big
thing there is that uh all of the evidence there all of the the
investigative evidence the the broad basis of the investigations
that's where a ton of material is that's where a ton of the information
is the actual and I I would assume right there right they're
basically saying that this testimony is not required for in any
case pales in comparison the information contained in the Epste
jury pales in comparison to the investigation materials. Yeah.
Were the other two court orders though? He said there were three.
I have no idea. I assume they're they're perpetually going on
the same things, but that would be my assumption without uh any
basis. So, I'm just saying that like without any information,
that would be my guess. We'd have to look up more information
to know for sure. >> That's an average of 41,000
every month. Uh what are the monthly gotaway numbers >> Sir,
I'll have to get back to you on the exact gotaway numbers, but
identifying that there are gotaways is step one. Going and manhunting
them is step two, and that's what we're committing our resources
to. Well, that's that's that's my next question is is what progress
has administration made in apprehending and removing terrorist
threats that came in during the Biden years? >> I think
you're talking about if you're not, let me know. No known or
suspected
>> Oh, obstacle says the grand jury release has been blocked
by three judges. That's what they mean. Oh, so it's the same
testimony that's been blocked three times by three different
judges. >> And we've encountered almost zero at the southern
border since the southern border has been sealed. But the problem
that we are running into is our northern border. It's largely
expansive. The enemy has adapted and we need more focus on the
northern border to stop known or suspected terrorists from coming
in from places like China, Russia. We need more focus on that
we are >> Am I the only one who heard this? >> Running
into is our northern border. It's largely expansive. The enemy
has adapted and we need more >> Do you hear that in the
background? Am I Am I insane? Am I the only one hearing like
a photocopier going off in the background? Yeah, there's like
a photocopier. You guys hear that? >> They're printing
out the tweets on the >> That's what I think they're doing.
I think they're printing >> concealed. But the problem
that we are running into is our northern border. It's largely
expansive. The enemy has adapted and we need more focus on the
>> it's like objectively a photocopier like a fax machine
or something. I can hear the the printing spools like going back
and forth. That's funny. >> Northern border to stop known
or suspected terrorists from coming in from places like China,
Russia, the Middle East, Africa, Afghanistan. >> And what
can you tell us about the remaining threat posed by potential
terrorist cells here in the United >> that the the terrorist
threat continues from the Canadian terrorist part? The terrorists
of the north go back >> border since the southern border
has been sealed. But the problem that we are running into, we've
encountered almost zero at the southern border since the southern
border has been sealed. But the problem that we are running into
is our northern border. It's largely expansive. The enemy has
adapted and we need more focus on the northern border to stop
known nor suspected terrorists from coming in from places like
China, Russia, the Middle East, Africa, >> And what can
you tell us about the remaining threat posed by potential terrorist
cells here in the United? >> Dude, he didn't. Okay. But
actually, unironically, Ben Stellar, what the India is the country
that is sending actual people to his people in Canada and the
US, I believe. Why the ar why didn't he just name India there?
>> United States. The the >> Oh, by the way, guys,
we got a a kick thing. I think it's 300 kicks and up showing
the stream. I might I I could try to fix it later so it shows
like less conditional ones. I just don't want a sound notification
for like 50 cents that like can distract from the content. But
uh if you guys do want to use kicks, okay, kicks now, I'm actually
tracking them, so they'll go towards more time in the stream.
I think we are we're like one one sub and 250 kicks away from
another hour on the stream. Just so you guys know, >> terrorist
threat that is continues to be posed by international terrorists
here in the United States is one of my highest priorities. We
are working through our intelligence community partners to identify
those individuals and we've taken down numerous individuals in
numerous rings across this country to neutralize that terrorist
threat, including places like New York City, Los Angeles, and
I believe Dallas, Texas most recently. How extensively did criminal
cartels like Similoa, Halisco, New Generation, MS-13, Tarendua,
and others infiltrate our country during the Biden administration?
>> By the tens of thousands. >> Well, and what progress?
>> I'm sorry. I don't I literally uh we're good with this
old man. >> I need to be right back. >> Okay, we're
good with that old man. >> Does Donald Trump appear >> I'm
probably just going to start skipping the Republicans at this
point. Okay, guys. How many >> anywhere in the Epste files?
>> I'm sorry. Could you say that again? >> It's not
a complicated question. Does Donald Trump appear anywhere in
the Epste files? I didn't. >> So, he has to say yes. >> Say
it was a complicated question. I just didn't hear you. So, my
apologies. Um, we have released uh where Mr. where President
Trump's names in the Epstein files and everybody else um and
all credible information that we are legally allowed to release
has been released. >> All right. So, let's go through that.
You're you're referring to court orders that prohibit you from
releasing grand jury testimony. >> This guy knows this
knows that. Is that Mr. Mosquitz? Mr. Jared Moscowitz. Doesn't
he share the same name as the Facebook founder? Am I saying Jared
or is it a different a different name for him? Hold on. This
is This is the Congress. Wait, never mind. That's not Moscowitz.
That's I'm looking at Moscowitz is to the left. Never mind.
>> Under rule 6E. >> I thought he is what you're
referring to when you say is the law allows. >> He's got
a name tag behind the the >> Really? What other What other
evidence >> Hold on. I'm pulling it back a little bit.
I cut that off. I listen. Sometimes I only know the names from
reading them. I don't know the names that go to the vases. and
Mosquitz was one of them. Although now I recognize him now that
I Googled the picture. But anyway, this is Daniel Goldman. Got
it. >> Um, and all credible information that we are legally
allowed to release has been >> All right. So, let's go
through that. You're you're referring to court orders that prohibit
you from releasing grand jury testimony under rule 6E. Is that
what you're referring to when you say is the law allows? >> That's
a piece of it. >> Really? What other What other evidence
does the do those three court orders you cited prohibit from
being released? information that was collected pursuant to those
search warrants that were limited fashion. >> Wrong. That's
not what the court order says and that's not under 6E. >> And
you're talking and I said that's 6E and I said there was others
and I'm answering that there are sealed court order documents.
There are protective orders for >> they are unsealed as
part of discovery given to Gileain Maxwell. They are no longer
sealed. >> That's just not true. We can argue about it
all you want. >> Okay. Well, you agree that there are So,
wait. Your testimony here is that the reason why you are not
releasing all of the videos that you >> There's like an
there's an objective answer to this. You have acknowledged there
are so many and that the FBI spent thousands of hours of reviewing
the photographs all of the and the photographs that you have.
You're saying that you're not releasing those because there's
a court order requiring them to be sealed. Is that your testimony?
>> Never said that about the videos. And the totality of
the videos of the thousands of images that were seized pursuant
to the search warrants executed at the time. The overwhelming
majority of that video is material that was downloaded from the
internet and child abuse material. We will never release >> Well,
as you should not release the victims, but if there are videos
that relate to others who Epstein traffic to, such as maybe Prince
Andrew or photographs
that you have total control to release. >> Yes. And if
it exists, >> so why haven't you released it? >> Why
are you supposing that that is a fact when in fact it is false?
Are you saying that >> you're saying? >> So I guess
it's Cash's testimony that this this Jeffrey Epstein guy had
no videos of other people. Zero videos of other people. Zero
videos of people who were clearly like any of these trafficked
women. How do you even know they were trafficked women? Wait,
Cash, weren't you one of the guys who was telling us this is
like a ring? How the [__] did they get a blackmail
ring with no blackmail? How? How? >> None of the videos
relate to anything relevant to the Jeffrey Epstein >> Every
single video that we have collected pursuant to the prior search
warrants has been examined for the last 10 years. And every single
video has been utilized for whatever prosecutions were able to
be legally brought. I'm not asking about prosecutions. I'm asking
about why you aren't releasing the full Epstein files, including
the names of people who were involved in the ring that you promised
to do before you became FBI director. >> I just told you
I'm not going to release >> I'm not asking about that.
Fine. I'm >> He said, "Yeah,
>> man. Uh Goldman Goldman should sense this that where
this goes, he's basically saying there is no video evidence.
There's we've collected no evidence of any wrongdoing on the
part of Jeffrey Epstein with regards to like a a blackmail ring,
a ring, nothing like this. There's zero evidence. That's what
he's saying. I want cash fell on the record saying there's zero
evidence of this. Zero.
I was going automated
portabeller. I don't know why. It's very frustrating to me. >> You're
asking about all the other files. >> What other videos?
Tell me. Tell me. >> You're That's what I'm asking. You're
saying there are no videos that would be relevant to anyone else
involved in the Jeffrey Epstein >> pursuant to Mr. Aosta's
collection of information based on the search warrants. That's
all we have in our >> And I'm I'm asking you that stuff.
>> That's all we got. >> I'm not asking all you got.
I'm asking you in that stuff. There's nothing that's related
to the uh to any other traffic, any other people engaged with
Epstein in underage. >> That's correct. To my knowledge,
no. >> Okay. Let's talk about the witness interviews. 302s
of witness interviews. Those are not subject to the court order.
Those are not subject to any fictional sealed order for a search
warrant. Why aren't you releasing those with the redacted names
of the victims? >> We are releasing as much as legally
allowed. That's why we went back. >> How is that? How is
that not legally >> Sir, do you know how court orders work?
Do you know how protective orders work? >> Actually, Mr.
Patel, I was a prosecu a real prosecutor for 10 years. I know
exactly how
>> and I want to understand. >> You weren't a prosecutor,
you dump. You were a public defender, you [__] idiot.
Hello. So, I wasn't a real prosecutor. No, you weren't.
What? The court order prevents you from releasing witness statements
that the FBI took. >> You should know that as a real prosecutor,
when the court hand downs a protective order and a motion to
seal, the material is sealed. >> I'm pretty Wait, I'm pretty
sure. Hold on. I'm pretty sure he wasn't. Maybe he was maybe
he was a prosecutor at some point, but I'm positive he's also
a public defender. >> Unless that testimony here is all
>> Am I gaslighting myself? >> All of those witness
statements are under a court order, a protective order. We are
providing everything we can legally provide. No, that's not my
question. My question is, >> oh, he served as a federal
prosecutor after he was a public defender. Oh, hold on. He did
he did go back. No, he did he did apparently serve as a federal
prosecutor after being a public defender. He was a public defender,
though. He did serve later on as a federal prosecutor. >> Why
are those witness statements that are not grand jury testimony
that if they were under a protective order are no longer under
a protective order, why are they not being released? >> How
are they not under protective? Why are you not going to the court
like you did for the grand jury testimony to unseal those records?
>> The DOJ did go to the court. >> No, not on those
records. Why aren't you going? You just went on grand jury. >> Time
of the gentleman is expired. The >> You are hiding the
Epstein files. >> The gentleman is expired. >> You
are part of the cover up. >> Can I respond? You >> sure
can. >> Any allegations that I'm a part of a cover up to
protect child trafficking and victims of human trafficking and
crimes is patently and categorically false in the work of my
>> So, I hope you will talk to them when they have requested
to speak with you. the victims have you are not
>> okay this is um he's just testifying that there there
was nothing bound that Jeffrey Epstein was not doing these things
they have no evidence Jeffrey Epstein ran any blackmail ring
this was never collected >> responding to them >> director
yes or no is the FBI still spying on parents at school board
>> uh no sir >> is the FBI chair uh chair now recognizes
>> sorry you're skipping through Jim Jordan is the FBI
now done spying on parents gentle lady from >> go ahead
>> because this is a blackmail mail ring. Even if the people
did something illegal, do they still get to be considered victims
of the blackmail
>> Uh, probably. But in this case, if it as it's proposed
in like the generic case, probably. But in this case, if it were
exposed, uh, I believe the way they gain the blackmail is by
getting them to [__] the underage person.
So, it's like, well, they didn't like force you to rape them.
It's not like they had a gun to your head making you that. He
kind of just did it and they have evidence of it. So, right.
It's not like Yeah, it's not that kind of corion as far as I
know. Did Jimmy Boy cover up his own set of crimes? Yeah, he
was a part of some university that covered up crimes. As far
as I know, it wasn't Penn State, right? It was a It was Ohio
State. Jim Jordan, Ohio State, was
it it was an Ohio State like wrestling team scandal. I think
>> in California. >> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I'm
concerned by reports that FBI agents have been diverted from
their important work on crime and anti-terrorism to work on matters
that are not critical to our safety. I'd like to play the video
the whole video. >> Jeffrey Epstein's >> black book.
>> But who that is? That I mean there >> Oh, that's
under direct control of the director of the FBI. But the black
book, it's not just sitting. I mean, that's >> that's Hoover
power times 10. >> And and to me, that's a thing I think
President Trump should run on on day one. Roll out the black.
In contrast to that attitude of let it all out, we're getting
reports of uh actions that run contrary uh to getting everything
out and that also involve diversions of FBI resources. For example,
an FBI whistleblower reported that you were pressured by the
attorney general to place 1,000 personnel on 24-hour shifts to
mine roughly a 100,000 Epstein related records to redact President
Trump's name from the files. Bloomberg uh reported this that
you directed FBI special agents from the New York and Washington
field offices to join the bureau's foyer employees uh in Winchester
uh and another building a few miles away. And that while reviewing
the Epstein files, FBI personnel >> Nadler, what are you
doing?
Jerry, turn your phone off. Jerry, what the are you doing? No,
that's that's definitely Jerry's ringtone. Look at him pick up
his phone right there. It's getting picked up through her. >> Why
is he got the rotary phone ringtone? The hell? >> Cuz he
wants to remember what his 50s were like. Okay. identified numerous
references to Trump in the documents and people familiar with
the matter said that Trump's name along with other high-profile
individuals was blacked out. Now, the New York Times reports,
and this is a quote, "Justice Department officials diverted hundreds
of FBI employees and federal prosecutors from their regular duties
to go through the documents at least four times, including once
to flag any references to Mr. Trump and other prominent figures.
Details of the review were based on accounts by three former
FBI and Justice Department officials who spoke on condition of
anonymity because of fears of
>> Are they getting this on the record, by the way? Like
I want this on the record like a yes or no. Was this order to
go through the FBI the the epste files in full with an eye for
Trump's name to redact it
to clarify it maybe >> and further that the FBI finished
uh after they finished its review of the files and materials
was sent to a team of justice department lawyers who double checked
the FBI's redactions and quote were instructed to flag any mentions
of
I know that everything here's on the record. I'm saying I want
her to narrow the question so that you have Cash Patel on the
record answering this question >> And other uh celebrities.
Now, I have three questions for you uh Mr. Patel about this.
Uh first, how many times did President Trump's name appear in
the Epstein files? Was it more than 100, more than a thousand?
Um, were the agents who were pulled from their duties to redact
the president's name from the Epstein vials working on criminal
cases or national security cases or child trafficking cases?
And are the number of agents that have been uh reported diverted
for these purposes? Is that
>> No. What? >> You asked if it was accurate. I said
it >> So, you're saying that none of >> the other
ones? >> There are two other questions. >> No, I'm
saying it was inaccurate. >> You said she had three questions,
bro. >> How many times did President
>> I'm sorry. This is like awful. They usually will ask
a question and then have the person answer and then reclaim their
time so they can ask an another question. These are monologuing.
>> Yeah, that that's been all of them. Usually what I think
you you can even do is you could say you can ask yes or no questions
and then if they try to monologue from the yes or no question,
you can say >> reclaim your time. >> Yeah, you just
reclaim. So yeah, I don't know. It seems like this is I don't
know if they just switched over maybe like people who are on
the judiciary committee. Maybe there's some new people here who
don't know like the normal procedure, but it's kind of weird.
>> Uh, in the Epstein files, more than 100, more than a
thousand? >> No. And what we've been able to release is
what we've been legally able to release. And that is >> No,
that's not >> That wasn't the question. >> Question.
I asked you how many times did the president's name appear? >> I
don't know. >> It's your testimony. You do not know that
answer. >> The number of times. No. >> Um, could
you tell us how many agents were diverted for this task and what
they were working on? Well, when you say diverted, you make it
seem as if agents were pulled off what they do all the time.
Agents at the FBI masterfully do double duty and triple duty.
And because of the public's interest,
>> we just listen, these guys just, you know, didn't sleep
for a couple days that so that they could get Trump's name, you
know, redacted out of all this. Okay. It didn't affect anything.
>> In this case, we flex resources to make sure that we
could answer the public signal demand. So, do you want us to
look through the material and provide it to you or you do not
want us to do that? >> So, it's your test it's your testimony
that no one was diverted from a criminal matter that this was
a top priority to go through these uh this material to look for
Mr. Trump's name. Is that your testimony that's the highest priority
for the FBI? >> What's one of the most impressive things
about the FBI leadership and the careers that are in place is
that they make the decisions on who to send where on priorities
and make sure the mission needs are not hurt. And that's what
happened here. >> It's shocking to me that the FBI would
think that erasing Mr. Trump's name from the Epstein files is
a high priority when we have crime, we have national security
threats, we have terrorism threats, we have murders such as that
that occurred unfortunately with Mr. Kirk. It's shocking to hear
that that's your highest priority. And with that, Mr. Chairman,
you >> literally not what I said. Gentle yields back from
Wisconsin.
>> Uh, director, is President Trump implicated in any wrongdoing
related to
>> Based on the entirety of the evidence that we have,
absolutely not. The president is not implicated. Correct. Thank
you. Um I want to talk a little bit about China's malign influence
here in America and uh you know we've seen spy balloons traverse
the United States. We've seen police stations in communities
around America and uh sitting in the chair you're in just two
years ago. There was a sheriff from Coois County, Arizona, Mark
Dan that was >> Oh, don't care. Don't care. Boring dusty
Republican. No thank you. No thank you. doing
the >> I believe you had primary >> gentleman from
Tennessee is recognized. >> Thank you, Mr. Chair. Director
Patel, I believe you had primary importance and and starting
operation Viper. And >> to be clear, I believe I do this
in in a lot of cases if it was like a dem allied person like
sometimes you get Dems who will actually ask like reasonable
questions, but most of the time these things go like, "Oh, it's
it's just partisan. It's like totally partisan." And anybody
who's not against the person who they're questioning, they'll
just like glaze the whole time or they'll talk about irrelevant
[__] the whole time. It's just boring. >> Memphis,
is that correct? >> Yes, sir. >> And Operation Viper
brought in the FBI, the DEA, the ATF uh to help Memphis police
in policing the city. >> That'll be phase two, sir. Phase
one was um FBI and local law enforcement in Memphis for the last
few months.
you you did a good job and and police director and the mayor
have told me that that was been helpful. uh the FBI working with
the police and the FBI are trained in law enforcement. They know
Miranda rights. They know how to do policing and they do a good
job working with the police. Do you think that the National Guard
is necessary to do the work that the FBI is doing now? >> Thank
you. I I do think it's necessary to finish it. What we've done
is 500 arrests in Memphis and 110 federal indictments. But what
we need to do is we've only secured a piece of where the criminal
conduct is incurring in Memphis and we can't work inside uh perimeters
that are not established and safe and we don't have the manpower
to give us the space to fully go into the areas where the criminal
activity remains. >> Well, are you suggesting that the
National Guard is going to go into the more crime, heavily crime
areas? >> They're going to establish like they did in Washington
DC perimeters where local law enforcement and the FBI, DEA, ATF,
and US Marshalss can go into. Um, we can't be going into all
these areas knowing that they're extremely volatile and jeopardizing
the safety of our >> But the national >> Wait, so
like the FBI is too scared to go conduct investigations in American
cities are so dangerous you can't conduct a normal investigation
there. Is that what you're saying? Are the FBI is the FBI like
kind of like totally made or are these guys little or I saw you
guys you're on a cute little military APC when you're investigating
the Charlie Kurt thing. Couldn't you guys get something like
that? Really? Apparently the hood the hood is very terrifying.
Okay. He's saying the FBI's It seems that way. I would have thought
you guys were like operators. I thought you were going to see
each other in Valhalla. I thought you were warriors. Are you
saying that these guys are sort of like totally made or what
are you what are you saying right now? Cash >> guard do
anything in in Washington to to help the FBI stay safe from these
dangerous elements? >> They established perimeters. >> Established
perimeter and the criminals knew about it. So they >> it
was a visible force, sir. So they kind of saw it. Well, what
you did, I commend you for what you did and I think the FBI coming
in. We have a crime problem in Memphis. The FBI has helped. DEA
will help and the uh ATF will help. I don't think the National
Guard is going to help. And what I've seen, they're not trained
in They're not trained in law enforcement, are they? >> No,
sir. >> And then so that could be a problem. Who will direct
the National Guard in Memphis? Will it be uh will they have control
over your agents? >> No sir, they won't. >> Who will
who will have control over your agents? You >> Well, the
SACE and then ultimately the chain of command up to Washington
DC will control the FBI. There's a task force that was put together
that is going to be led by an inter agency the heads of US Marshalss
DEA and FBI will be working together with DHS collectively on
this. >> Have you visited Memphis before? >> Yes,
sir I have. >> So you know how good a city it is. >> I
love Memphis. >> A lot of us do. And Memphis is a great
city, great history. Civil rights museum might say something
about slavery, but that's that was the history needs to be taught.
Blues Elvis Street be street. >> Okay. This this old Democrat
is he I thought he was buttering him up. I thought he was going
to go, you know, with the the good cop bad cop in the same statement.
Okay, now he's just like, I love Tennessee. I love Tennessee
>> barbecue and people should come. It's not a troubled
city. We've got some crime, but it's not a troubled city. We're
not troubled and we love our city and we hope that the National
Guard doesn't come in and cause people to have questions about
Memphis because it's a city they should visit. Uh, let me ask
you this about you said that the homicide rates are coming down
to an all-time low. >> Uh, in modern recorded US history,
yes. >> When does modern recorded history start? I think
the FBI, and I'll get back to you on this, um, has stats on that
going back about 30 years, sir. >> Okay. I was thinking
back to Aussie and Harriet, and I didn't think you could beat
Aussie Harriet's time. >> Oh,
um, secondly, you you
>> What was that? >> A time.
>> you you mentioned the Epstein case. Did any of the women
that were victims and they came up here and had a press conference
and all, did any of them contact your office and ask to give
>> To my knowledge, no, sir. If they did, let me ask you
first. Is there a statute of limitations on crimes like that
with the minor? >> The DOJ is the expert, but I do not
believe there's a statute on that limitations on that. >> So,
there's not a statute of limitations. Should you not be interviewing
those people who know who them and the names and the places and
give you that information that seems like that's a treasure trove
of information and it's a serious serious serious number of crimes.
>> Sir, I couldn't agree with you more. We've been very
public about asking individuals to come forward with new information
and we would run out every single lead on that. Well, I'm sure
the women will come forward, especially today to be sure that
they will get an opportunity because that seems like something
we ought to do. Uh the uh
you Mr. Driscoll, what was his >> I can't comment on Mr.
Driscoll's matter. It's an ongoing litigation. >> Yeah,
but his reputation you can tell us >> I can tell you I
can't tell you about his reputation. His work um has been laid
out in that.
>> How many of the FBI agents who >> Wait, no, you
haven't. Is there is there some evidence that they're not going
through and and interviewing all the people who have come forward?
They've been requesting to speak with the FBI. Do you have anything
on that portabeller? Any links? >> Worked on nine the nine
January 6 case have been fired. >> I don't have that number,
sir. >> You have a ballpark figure? >> No, but I
can tell you that individuals based on case assignments in the
FBI that I have led have not been terminated for case assignments.
>> Thank you, sir. Come back to Memphis and you work with
Kevin Kane and our in our tourism bureau. Thank you. And thank
you for your work in Memphis. >> Mr. Chairman, I have a
unanimous consent request. Gentleman's recognized. So, uh, I've
got four documents I'd like to introduce into the record. The
first one is Jeffrey. This is the guy. We're not skipping this
Republican. Okay, here he is over here. You see him with his
little documents, his little mustache? This is the guy. >> Who's
the big Gryffindor scarf? Not Gryffindor. It would be Slytherin.
>> Yeah, that green ass scarf. >> No,
no idea who that be, but this is our guy coming up. >> Years
in plain sight, >> I think. >> And Aosta is quoted
in here saying, "I was told Epstein belonged to intelligence
and to leave it alone." The second document is entitled, "What
Epstein's bodyguard warned about his CIA connections." The third
document is from Fox Digital. It's titled Epstein's private calendar
reveals planned meetings with Obama admin official CIA chief.
And the last document is Wall Street Journal article that highlights
Ahood Barack's 36 meetings with Jeffrey Epstein. He was the former
prime minister of Israel and head of milit. Why does this guy
meet with Ahoud Barack, the prime minister, former prime minister
of Israel all the time? They were doing a joint venture. They
were trying to make um Israeli Palunteer. Okay. Israeli Palunteer
together. >> Terry intelligence for Israel. >> It
may have held that title when he met Epstein and then Yes. Objection.
The gentleman will hold for a second. The gentleman from Maryland's
recognized. >> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Just one UC request.
This is Judge Engel mayor's decision from August and US versus
Epstein stating the government's 100,000 pages of Epstein files
dwarfs the 70 odd pages of Epstein grand jury. >> Uh without
objection, gentleman from KY is recognized for five minutes.
>> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Uh Director Patel, I watched
some of your Senate hearing yesterday when Senator Kennedy asked
you, you've seen most of the files, who if anyone did Epstein
traffic these women to besides himself. You replied, according
to the transcript, there is no credible information that he trafficked
them to anyone else. You also said somewhere in the hearing and
here today that the problem is that the case files are constrained
by limited search warrants from 2006 to 2007 and that the non-prosecution
agreement hamstrung future investigations.
Those constraints only apply to Southern District of Florida.
They do not apply to Southern District of New York, the location
of the 2019 trafficking indictment which produced many Okay,
hold on. Hold on. I need to back this up because I just got sent
this article. Okay, it's from about a week ago, week and a half
ago. No outreach to Epstein victims despite Trump's vow to investigate,
lawyers say. Nine attorneys tell Guardian they have not been
contacted by the Justice Department. State affair state of affairs
they call atrocious.
So apparently there are people nine attorneys who've represented
approximately 15 Epstein survivors told the Guardian that they
have not been recently been contacted by the Justice Department.
So apparently Cash is not reaching out and these people are complaining.
So it's a little weird that he's like, "Yeah, no, of course we
of course we should do this." That's but that's why I like that
Tennessee guy and the questions he asked because he's not attacking
him, right? He's just asking for information to put it on the
record so that now when somebody says, "Hey, Cash, why do we
have a bunch of these people saying that they reaching out?"
They're reaching out to you and then you said they weren't that
you have not actually had anybody reach out or or come forward
about this, right? I like the Tennessee guy's way of approaching
it cuz he didn't just like clam up or anything. He just kind
of spoke freely because the guy was being nice to him. catch
more honeys with uh catch more flies with honey than vinegar
as they say. I don't know what catches honeys. >> Hamstrung
future investigations.
Those constraints only apply to Southern District of Florida.
They do not apply to Southern District of New York, the location
of the 2019 trafficking indictment, which produced many things,
including a series of FD302 documents. According to victims who
cooperated with the FBI in that investigation, these documents
in FBI possession, your possession, detail at least 20 men, including
Mr. Jess Staley, CEO of Barkclay's Bank, who Jeffrey Epstein
traffked victims to. Victims including minors such as Virginia
Roberts Euphr, may she rest in peace. That list also includes
at least 19 other individuals. One Hollywood producer worth a
few hundred million dollars. One royal prince, one high-profile
individual in the music industry, one very prominent banker,
one high-profile government official, one high-profile former
politician, one owner of a car company in Italy, one rock star,
one magician, at least six billionaires, including a billionaire
from Canada. We know these people exist in the FBI files. The
files that you control. >> Oh, Thomas has been talking
to people. >> David Blaine, no. David Blaine, no. >> I
don't know. I love street magic. >> Exactly who they are,
but the FBI does. Have you launched any investigations into any
of these people? And have you seen these 302 documents? Sir,
I >> Kev Kevin, are you sweating? Dude, there are not a
lot of Canadian billionaires. Okay, there are a couple, but there
are not a lot. O >> have asked my FBI agents to review
the entirety of the Epstein files and bring forth any credible
information. and we're working with Congress not only to divulge
that information and produce it to you, but any investigations
that arise from any credible investigation will be brought. There
have been no new materials brought to me launching a new um indictment.
>> So, is is the loophole here or is it your assertion
that these uh victims aren't credible, that the 302s maybe didn't
produce credible statements that rise to a probable cause? >> It's
not my assertion, sir. It's the assertion of um two different
United States attorney's offices from three separate administrations
who investigated those same materials >> Are the 302 documents
in the FBI's
>> They reviewed all that. Yes, sir. >> And and so
have you reviewed those 302 documents that where the victims
name the people who victimized them? >> If I personally
know, but the FBI has. >> So how can you sit here and and
in front of the Senate and say there are no
>> I said all >> I named one today. I I said we are
not in the we are not in the practice at the Department of Justice
FBI of releasing victim's names. That is >> not what Wait,
what? That's not what he's saying. What >> that's why I
brought up who can be considered a victim because I do feel like
he's using the word victim to speak about the people who are
blackmailed and not so much the victims of the crimes of
>> Oh yeah, maybe maybe that's not you're also not in the
habit of >> Yeah, I think he's being slippery here. This
guy, this guy's a piece of [__] >> Releasing
incredible information. That's not what we do. But multiple authorities
have looked at the entirety of what we >> Okay, I got to
move on here. Were you present when the AG uh had the White House
event when she released the binders to the social media influencers?
>> I was. Yes. >> So, if you're willing to meet with
social media influencers who stood to benefit from the sensational
and sad stories of these victims, will you meet with the victims
as well? >> The FBI will meet with anyone who has no information.
Will you personally meet with them? Oh,
that's a good question. Cuz here's the thing. Cash can just walk
up here and say, "I have no knowledge of this. I don't know about
this. I don't know about that." Right? And now Thomas is saying,
"Well, I feel like you're kind of full of so why don't you actually
go talk to these people and then come back and tell me that you
don't know anything about this?" >> The FBI and the professionals
were handling the cases. Will, >> were you instructed that
it was important to release the documents to the oversight committee
on the day of uh my introduction of the discharge petition to
release these files? >> I don't know what day that was.
So, no. >> Well, they were released that day and there
were victim's names who weren't redacted because it was they
were in such a rush and the victims are not happy about that.
Um, have you investigated any of the CIA connections? Have you
seen the CIA file on Jeffrey Epstein? And if you wanted to see
it, would they show it to you? >> Well, I can speak for
the FBI and that's presuming there's a CIA case file and I've
reviewed everything that the inter agency, not I, the FBI, that
was provided to us. Would you would you be willing to look at
the CIA file on Jeffrey Epstein? if there is such a file and
if it has not already been been turned over to the FBI. The FBI
will look at any new investigative leads. >> Um, have you
made any progress on the pipe bomb investigation January 6th?
And have you made any progress on the motive of the Las Vegas?
>> Uh, on as to the first, it's an ongoing investigation
and we have made progress as to the second, sir. I'll have to
get back to you. >> All right. Thank you. I yel back. Mr.
>> Chairman of back. >> Dude, this this guy's just
Thomas Massiey's awesome. Okay, just asking about the Vegas shooter.
So remember guys, we have no idea what the [__] happened
with that Vegas shooter. We don't know what the motive was. That
[__] just evaporated into thin air, okay? There's
just nothing. There's just
>> Consent request from gentle New York. >> I ask
unanimous consent to introduce an unsigned memorandum from July
7th, 2025 that says we did not uncover evidence that could predicate
an investigation against uncharged third parties with the insignia
of the Department of Justice and the FBI. Without objection,
>> Mr. Chairman, I have a unanimous
consent request. Uh it's a article entitled DOJ deletes study
showing domestic terrorists are most often wing
>> objection you >> from
George is recognized for >> I heard about this. It'd be
cool to hear him answer questions on this cuz I had that
basically the the FBI was showing like a they had like stats
that were basically showing yeah most political violence being
right-wing and they were just out basically they were told like
hey take that throw that out get that out of here.
>> Thank you Mr. Chairman. Uh Director Patel thank you
for being here today. I want to um first uh talk about the um
significant role that the FB FBI plays in uh combating the national
security threats posed by our nation's greatest threat, our nation's
greatest security >> He's going to say
white nationalism, white nationalism, white authorit white identitarianism,
white blah blah. Maybe not white. Uh, right-wing violence, right-wing
militias, right-wing >> China and the Chinese Communist
Party. >> Oh, China. Oh, that's that's refreshing. I thought
it was going to be maybe like right-wing militias, right-wing
reactionaries, just China. Thank God. A normal guy. >> Um,
it's a fact that um China is America's most significant national
security threat. Isn't that correct? >> I would say so,
sir. And you would agree with me that China wants to uh dominate
the United States of America. >> I think that's largely
their plan. >> And it want they want to dominate the world
both milit. >> Oh, cuz he's black. No, cuz he's a Democrat.
There's a black Republican saying this. I would never have guessed
those things. And economically, isn't that correct? >> I
think so. >> And sir, uh you've been FBI director for the
last uh what 8 months? >> Seven months. Yes. >> Seven
months. And um and during that time, have you held any stock
in any companies founded in China? >> I don't believe so.
>> Well, you do own stock in a company known as Elite Depot,
don't you? >> Which one? Sorry. >> Elite Depot. You
own stock. >> I think that's I I'll have to get back to
you. I think it's a law firm and it's a company out of Singapore.
>> Okay. Well, no. The company out of Singapore which is
owned by Elite Depot is the Shaheen company which was founded
in China. Correct. That company operates out of Taiwan. >> Well,
they changed their headquarters from uh China back in 2022 to
Singapore for tax purposes, but it's owned by a Chinese billionaire.
I think his name is Charlie Zoo. And um and you own stock in
the company that owns Shien, >> which I disclosed during
my confirmation >> Yes, you certainly did. And um now,
do you still hold that stock in that Chinese company? in pursuant
to the um the Department of Justice who reviewed my material
that was submitted during my confirmation process. Um I was able
to hold certain stocks and they made the >> You still hold
the stocks that you have? You still you still hold on to these
uh Chinese stocks? These stocks in this Chinese company? >> I
disagree that it's a Chinese company, but I was in the DOJ when
you're appointed makes a call on what you can and can't. >> But
now let me ask you this. Chinese companies steal trademarks.
They produce counterfeit products and sell them over the internet
on platforms such as Shien.
Uh they steal intellectual property. They steal data from uh
American companies. And to me, it seems inconsistent with your
role as FBI director that you would own stock in a company that
is based in a country that is the nation's premier national security
threat. It's like you are uh >> I don't know if this means
anything. It would depend on how he got the stock, right? to
me. See here trying to get links something. Let's check this
out. Cash Patel set to make millions off of Chinese fast fashion
brand fast fashion brand Shien. Cash Patel, President Donald
Trump's pick to lead the Federal Bureau of Investigation, could
join a list of people who are set to make a fortune when Chinese
fast fashion brand Shien goes public as soon as this year. Cash
or Patel formerly consulted for Shien's parent company, Elite
Depot, and was compensated with stock worth anywhere from 1 million
to $5 million, according to the financial disclosures he submitted
as a part of his confirmation process to lead the FBI. His financial
disclosures state he plans to keep the stock if confirmed. Now,
critics in the national security sphere have told the Wall Street
Journal they're concerned about Patel maintaining ties with the
company. While Shien relocated its headquarters from China to
Singapore in 2021, the company still uses thousands of Chinese
factories as part of its fast fast fashion model. Uh Charles
Coopermanman, former deputy national security adviser during
Donald Trump's first term, who worked closely with Patel, said
the 44year-old should devest divest all of his interests if confirmed.
This is not a US company and it's a conflict of interest financially,
Coopermanman said. Patel's stock has was invested as of January,
the journal reports, but the shares will become available to
him in quarterly through November. The FBI also cited a remote
likelihood that his duties would involve the company. Compensation
experts still warn he will in effect still have a continuing
relationship with a foreign company. The journal says, "Okay,
so this is what was he doing to get awarded this? Like what was
he consulting on? And when was he awarded these these shares?
They must been must have been recent." Hold on. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I I get that they're going to go public, but his shares haven't
even vested yet, it doesn't sound like. So he must have gotten
them very recently, right? if he got them in the past like two
years since he was trying to be publicly like politically involved.
I think this is total bull, right? This is obviously but I don't
see when he got it doesn't say here when he actually got them.
To be fair, the agency that is meant to prevent this. Yeah, we
uh that's another thing we have to look up is apparently the
FBI used to have a public corruption uh department that was dissolved
straight up. Countable did a whole thing on this. Okay, we might
have to check this out in a little bit. I'm opening this on a
side screen. We're going to continue on with the hearing for
now. And I also want to say hello >> cuz I was looking
this up and some of the things that you want like on the record
actually already exist on the record saying that there is no
um blacklist or client list. >> Yeah. Yeah. He said apparently
said that >> He submitted that in an he submitted that
in an FBI like memo or disclosure in July. >> I vaguely
remember that. The other one was uh there's no credible evidence
that Jeffrey Epstein like engaged in trafficking with anyone.
like he just trafficked the women for himself. He didn't he didn't
like actually send traffic to other people. There's no credible
evidence. I I believe is what he said yesterday. No credible
evidence that Jeffrey Epstein trafficked anyone to a third party.
>> Here in this one, it says um their systemic review revealed
no incriminating client list. There is also no credible evidence
found that Epstein blackmailed prominent individuals as part
of his actions. We did not uncover evidence that could uh predicate
an investigation against uncharged third parties. And this was
uh published by the FBI July 2025 and it's listed on um the justice.gov
website. I'll link it to you, but just so you know, the things
that he's saying here, it's not new
>> or this is not like a new note that he's >> I'm
I Well, I It's a lot different when it's a memo. And it's a it's
different when it's a memo versus like your face saying it into
a microphone. >> Yes. Yes. True. >> I want him I
want him to say it. Say that Je say that you lied to everybody
about Epstein. Okay. Say it directly. That's what I like. He
He engaged in his lying campaign to become head of the FBI through
microphones on podcasts. Okay, put it into the microphone right
now. Say that you were wrong. >> And these are the same
people that moved Gizlain Maxwell to like a a nicer prison or
whatever
after she said that she'll just release the client list. Like
what the is going on? Uh man, I don't know the I need to also
look into the the Gla Maxwell like why she got sent to that Kushier
prison. It's uh some goofy stuff as well. >> Yeah. Why
did she say she would share the list, but the FBI's like, "No,
that don't exist. Don't worry, guys." >> Uh listen, I think
Golain is confused. There's no credible evidence that there even
would be a list. There's just there's no list. What did he lie
about? Moody Morgan. He lied when he was a podcaster that there
was a black book that the FBI could release that black book that
he sources who told him about all of this. everything he said
to be put in charge of the FBI. Everything he did to build his
profile, use this Epstein controversy, Epste conspiracy to build
himself up, that was all lies. That was just populism. He's just
ringing uh sorry, he was just riing people up. He was just doing
critical theory. He was telling them America's run by and and
they're protecting Epstein and I'll get it all out there for
you. But he didn't think that. He didn't know anything about
that. He was just the whole time cuz he is a artist. He's the
worst. one of the worst snake >> security over the security
of the >> I disagree with that characterization. >> Well,
I think the American people look at it like it's a classic situation
of the fox guarding the hen house. If the FBI is charged with
investigating
uh espionage, economic espionage
uh by companies uh controlled by the Chinese Communist Party
and you are the director of the FBI, you've got a conflict of
interest. Sir, I would just show if there's any intimate in intimation
that I'm >> Why are you holding on to this stock? >> It
wasn't a decision. >> This is absolut Wait, what? Hold
on. The article we read said that his financial disclosure said
he would not devest himself for the stock. It sounds like it's
a decision he made. >> And it's valued at up to $5 million
as of when you last reported. Correct. $5 million in stock. >> I
don't follow it. The department >> follow it, but you're
still making money off of it. I don't have any money off of anything,
but I have done >> Trump's trade policies. >> This
is just lies. Like like Patel's like, "Listen, yeah, I own it,
but but like hasn't vested. I I couldn't have possibly made any
money from this." Brother, if you wanted to transfer those shares
to somebody in a private equity deal, how much would you get?
You'd get at at worst 50% of the money it's worth, right? If
you if you were able to transfer that stuff privately, you'd
get at worst like 50% of the value. Like it's worth a lot. Trying
to say it's not worth anything is insane. >> is directly
impact the value of that Chinese stock. Won't you agree with
>> Which trade policy? I'm not a trade >> Okay. All
right. >> But I want to tell you this, dude. >> You're
not an expert at anything,
>> Let me ask you this question. Why are you hiding? Why
are you shielding?
Why are you protecting?
>> That is maybe the most offensive thing you could say
to me given the numbers. >> Well, you have not released
files
>> aware of the client list that was published in the 18,000
>> the gentleman has expired
the gentleman
>> Jim Jordan actually working against his own interest
here
cash gets no no time to actually answer that question and like
give it any response why are you
uh gentleman yields his time gentleman must end okay >> I
can answer the question of course the gentleman can answer the
question >> since I took over the FBI there has been a
33%
Sir, all of that started under >> Your time is done. But
I didn't. The witness gets to answer the question and then we'll
go to our next director, sir. And you're coming in here trying
to take credit for something that a previous director instituted.
>> Find him in contempt. Jim, get him out of here. >> Largely
brought to conclusions. >> It's pretty clear that the the
director >> has numbers so much better than the previous
director.
You want to answer the question? >> I take no credit. The
men and women of the FBI have seen a 33% increase in the number
of counter intelligence arrests out of the PR. So all of a sudden
when you coming in 7 months ago
>> and on the pedophile
for that >> we have arrested 1500 child child predators
in the last 7 months >> under investigations initiated
by the prior director >> the director's good work and we
really appreciate that the time the gentleman has expired. We
now go to the gentleman from Texas. >> I thank the chairman.
I thank the FBI director for coming before the committee. I assume
the FBI director Mr. Patel, I believe uh you probably agree with
me that there is a significant organized effort uh on the left
uh side of the political spectrum to advance criminal organizations
being able to put more criminals out on the streets. Now what
we Yes, leftwing
Democrats are coming together with Mexican drug cartels to get
more drug dealers on the street, guys. So true. So awesome. So
cool. Wait, we coming back to this guy again? >> Data from
US companies is not >> without gentle yields back. >> Mr.
Chairman, I have a couple of unanimous requests. Uh, one is uh
a uh letter from Tom Senator Tom Cotton dated last year urging
the US to quote ensure that data from US companies is not harvested
by the Chinese Communist Party through the purchase of Shien
software and technology. >> Objection. And uh also a uh
a um
statement by uh Marco Rubio, then Senator Marco Rubio, which
warned our UA our UK allies about quote Shien's deep ties to
the People's Republic of China.
>> Also, uh a um
Okay, I will say it's pretty funny to get all of those comments
or sorry, all of those like answers from him about how like,
oh, it's a company. No, no, no. I think it's in Singapore actually.
And then he's like, I'm going to roll out all of the all of this
info here. I'm going to roll out all of this stuff showing that
Sheen's like tied to the People's Republic of China. Senator
Marco Rubio. Senator Marco Rubio archive. This is archived from
when he was a senator. Sheen is a fun is fundamentally a Chinese
company that evades US customs laws and has links to slave labor.
Its attempt to go public should prompt a closer look at its business
practices by regulators and investors. Oh wow. I do love Listen,
Cash Patel hates and is a massive defender of children's
right to work. Okay. Children's right to work 18 hours a day.
Let's go, Cash. Make sure these kids can work 20 hours a day.
Cash. They don't need sleep. They're young. They'll get through
it. So cool. >> Crime is a uh the record crime is down
in 2025. Trump doesn't deserve credit, which demonstrates that
the crime rates have been decreasing since 2023, which was published
by the Vera Institute. Also a um uni unanimous consent request
uh to uh enter into the record a NPR report uh from July of 17
July of 2024 GOP vows to make America safe again statistics contradict
their growing crime claim
>> Also a report uh out of the American Presidency Project
dated January 17, 2025
record low crime during the Biden Harris administration.
Without >> Also, Joe Biden is correct that violent crime
is near a 50-year low, which was a uh Politifact publication
of May 2024. And last but not least, a uh FBI releases 2024
reported crimes in the nation statistics. These are FBI statistics
published uh on August 5th, 2025,
which details decreases
in murder, aggravated assault, and robbery. Does anyone ever
read the documents people put on record? What is the point? Well,
with him, I thought he was making a a solid point about Shien
being a Chinese company. And he was using his unanimous consent
request here to actually drive that home >> in 2024. >> Without
objection. Gentlemen, gentleman from KY's recognized for unanimous
>> Mr. Chairman, I ask unanimous consent to submit uh two
sets of documents. The first is a series of emails from the victims
of Jeffrey Epstein. They are >> Thomas Massie is doing
it now, too. So, you're telling me that you'll talk to anybody?
Okay. I'd love unan unanimous consent to submit emails from the
victims of Jeffrey Jeffrey Epstein saying they'd like to talk
to the FBI. Apparently, Mr. Patel is unaware of these emails.
Foyer requests to get their own FBI files and not having any
success. So, um I want to bring attention to that by submitting
that to the record. The second document that I want to submit
to the record uh for the record. I know we don't usually read
these. This one's not readable. Uh it's completely redacted
uh for the most part. the first 50 pages. This is actually the
search warrant that was served on James O'Keeffe uh for a diary
that he had already given to the government two months before.
And as it turns out, there were no indictments here yet. He still
doesn't know why he was raided. And I think he deserves to know.
So,
>> Oh, that's a really cool story. I've never heard that
one before. So James O'Keefe, founder of notable notable Pulitzer
aspirations
journalist Pulitzer winning aspirational aspirational Pulitzer
future nominee James O'Keefe. Okay. Of Project Veraritoss. Apparently
he was raided. That seems sketchy as [__] though,
doesn't it? That's crazy to me. Sorry, I was trying to say I
was trying to joke about how untrustworthy James O'Keefe is.
Okay, obviously I was like trying to make a joke about how obviously
untrustworthy he is, but that does seem pretty nuts that he would
get raided for some journal he has connected to Epstein
and then they just redact the entirety of the search warrant.
It's like, "Hey, could you tell me why you thought raiding me
was a good idea?" Remember James O'Keefe is now the champion
of the left after exposing that FBI guy. Um, what James O'Keefe
what did he do for that? Was that was that a Epstein related
thing tourniquet? I actually don't know. I know James O'Keefe
did something that some people were joking about him being redeemed
for. I don't really think James O'Keefe can be redeemed. Kind
of a It's kind of unfixable. Um,
but I do think that's very interesting. I'd never heard about
that. The search warrant that that is totally blacked out. That's
kind of crazy. Wasn't it the diary of one of Biden's of the Biden
kids? Oh, it was for Ashley. Oh, >> about the secret recording.
>> Oh, no, no, no, no. That's the Ashley Biden diary. Ooh,
that one where she talks about having showers with her dad. That
one, that's a rough one. I I know why they I know why they rated
her for that. Okay, that's a that's a very yiky pages in that
diary. Okay, not good. Can we Can somebody fill me in on that
diary? So, hold on. Am I I'm not making that up, right? Wasn't
she talking about basically when she was like she was at least
10 or 11 or 12 when she was like it was a weird time to be showering
with your dad, right? Am I wrong on this? I thought she was quite
old. >> That's a Ew. >> Yeah. Ew. I'm looking. I'm
looking. I'm looking. Hold on. What is this?
>> You ever just get like a memory and it just makes you
start laughing and you're like, I can't tell anyone why I'm laughing
cuz this probably is just going to make people worried about
me. >> Fair. Well, I don't know how trustworthy Snopes
is all the time. Did Ashley Biden call childhood showers with
her father probably inappropriate in leaked diary? I will forever
have to deal with the fact that my personal journal can be viewed
online. Ashley Biden wrote to a district court judge.
Hold on. A diary authored by US President US President Joe Biden's
daughter Ashley Biden described showers taken with her father
when she was a child as probably not appropriate. Okay. Can we
get can we get a timing on this? >> Do we get a do we get
a timeline on this at all? I'm looking I'm looking for dates.
Can we get dates? I don't see any dates on here. I see a lot
of stuff about uh
dude, I don't see it. I don't see it
An often cited page from that leaked diary which chronicled this
author's addiction recovery in intimate detail makes reference
to trauma and poses questions in search of an explanation for
being a young age along with mentions of not liking to visit
a certain family's house being with a female friend and having
sex with friends at a young age. The author noted taking showers
with her dad probably not appropriate or sorry with my dad probably
not appropriate. So all of these things put together kind of
not cool man. I can't find an age here or a date. Why are so
many of the Biden's children addicts? Maybe it has something
to do with that thing. I don't know. Difficult to say.
Back to back to this >> Thank you. The chair now recognizes
the gentleman from California. >> Director. The first time
you saw Donald Trump's name was in the Epstein files. Did you
close the files or keep reading? I have reviewed not the entirety
of the files. So I have >> You haven't reviewed all of
the Epstein >> Personally, no. >> You're the director
of the FBI. This is the largest trafficking case the FBI has
ever been a part of. Buck stops at the top. And your testimony
today is you have not reviewed all the files. What I've been
doing is been busy providing the safest country this country
has seen in modern US history in historic speed because the men
and women of the FBI are given the resources to reduce the homicide
rates, to reduce the drug trafficking rate, to reduce the amount
of children that are being trafficked and the number of >> sounds
like those children being appreciate the director reviewing the
files. You said you don't know the number of times Trump's name
appears in the files. So it could at least be a thousand times.
Is that right? >> The number is a total misleading factor.
We have not really anyone I >> I love when somebody like
Unhinged gets up. Okay. Mr. Swallwell gets up there and he's
like, "Okay, could be like a thousand times, right? Could be
could be like 10,000 times. We don't know. >> We have not
released anyone's name files that has not been credible. Director
could have released every piece of legally permissible information.
You can characterize the numbers however you >> Claim me
my time. Director, >> it sounds like if you don't know
the number, it could at least be a thousand times, which >> it's
not. >> Is it at least 500 times? >> Is it at least
100 times? No. >> Then what's the number? >> So,
did he I I thought you weren't allowed to legally release this
cash. How did this guy break you so quickly? I can't legally
discuss this information. So, it could be at least a thousand
times. No. Was it at least 500 times? No. Uh, this guy just broke
you. You're now actually releasing all this information. Okay.
I uh Congratulations, Eric Swallwell. You broke this guy. You
broke him completely. >> I don't know the number, but it's
not >> Do you think it might be your job to know the number?
>> My job is to provide for the safety and security of
this country. My job is not to engage in political innuendo so
you can go out to the sticks and get your 22nd hit in your fundraising
order. Keep going reclaiming your time because the people of
California are being underserved by your representation. >> Is
not implicated. Why not release everything that involves >> we
have released everything the president and anyone else's side
that is credible and lawfully be able to be released. Your fixation
on this matter and baseless accusations that I'm hiding is disgusting.
Anyone that says that needs to look at the stats alone and go
back to the state of California who's receiving the biggest surge
in FBI resources through my redeployment because the cities of
Los Angeles, San Diego, and San Francisco, director, remembering
your oath to tell the truth, did you ever tell Donald Trump his
name is in the files? >> I have never spoken to President
Trump about the Epstein files. >> Did you? >> What?
You talked to Trump about everything. What do you mean you've
never talked to him about the Epstein files? Isn't that like
the biggest Wait, that can't possibly be true. That was the number
one thing you ran on to be Hold on. You literally told us that
was in a clip from this same testimony where you said you would
recommended Trump campaigning on releasing the Epstein files.
Are you saying on record or and under oath he said that? Yeah,
dude. What? Maybe he means he must mean like after he was director
he must have. >> Did you ever tell the attorney general
that Donald Trump's name is in the Epstein files? The attorney
general and I have had numerous discussions about the entirety
of the Epstein files and the reviews conducted by our >> Did
you tell the attorney general that Donald Trump's name is in
the Epstein >> and we have released where President
>> That's a simple question. Did you tell the attorney
general that the >> this is unfortunately
everybody becomes piscoiled in the end because unless you point
out that they're refusing to answer your question yes or no.
Yes or no? Yes or no? That's like the only way to ever get somebody
who is determined not to ever tell you the truth. It's the only
way to push them towards telling you the truth because you make
it very clear that they're just refusing to answer basic questions
that you are going to go in a direction. You're just going to
keep filibustering in whatever direction you can. So yes or no
is this true? Yes or no? Is that true? It's like the only way
to actually push somebody towards actually answering your questions.
>> Name is in the Epstein files. During many conversations
that the attorney general and I have had on the matter of Epstein,
we have reviewed >> The question is simple. Who did you
tell the attorney general that Donald Trump's name is in the
Epstein files? Yes or no? >> Why don't you try spelling
it out? >> Yes or no? Director's the alphabet. Yes or no?
>> No. ABC. >> Director, it sounds like you don't
want to tell us. Did you tell the attorney general that Donald
Trump's name is in the Epstein files? >> Why don't you
try serving your constituency by focusing on reducing violent
crime in this country and the number of that are legally harbored
in your sanctuary cities in California? work with you on that
regular
ladies and gentlemen. >> Wait, does Cash Patel is Cash
Patel protecting? You have leads on potential in these places
and you're not blowing the whistle on this and just sending it
to the press. Cash Cash, do you have evidence of that you're
protecting in sanctuary cities? >> Why don't you What's
up? What's up with these people holding all their info on until
they need like some political win? >> That's like everybody
we didn't realize. Okay, the deck of cards. Okay, the ace and
the ace of every suit in a deck of cards is allegations against
some powerful person. Okay, these guys all hold them. It's why
there's so many. They just all know like listen, I might need
a favor in California at some point. I can't expose there. I'm
going to need a I'm going to need a favor. What am I going to
do? None of these people ever go to prison from >> Did
you tell the attorney general that Donald Trump's name is in
the FC files? >> Question has been asked and answered.
>> You've not answered it and we will take your evasiveness
as a consciousness of guilt. Director, did Donald Trump ever
say to you, "Just find and release the entire truth. Don't worry
if I'm in it." >> The instructions from the administration
were to release all credible information, and we have done that.
>> Did Donald Trump ever provide information about Jeffrey
Epste as an >> Donald Trump has not been, and I can only
speak for the FBI, an informant of the FBI. >> So, director,
you've played this cute shell game where you say you can't release
everything because the court has said that it legally is not
allowed to be released. But the court calls, judge Richard Burman
said that when you went to the court, quote, "Information contained
in the Epstein grand jury transcripts pales pales in comparison
to Epstein investigation information and materials in the hands
of the Department of Justice." So, let's move on. Director, you
wrote a book called Government Gangsters. You identified 20 individuals
in that book. You put me on that list at the top of the list.
Thank you. My children find it flattering. 20 of those individuals
have been investigated or have had adverse actions. Director,
considering that you have identified these people as quote government
gangsters, will you recuse yourself from making any investigation
decisions about these individuals? >> Anyone that has been
terminated at the FBI has been done failed to meet the >> Wait,
what is he just guessing the direction he's going here?
>> I will work on the audiovisisual
>> I'm going to borrow your >> I mean, he's he's
correct as in like, oh, these people have, you know, these people
didn't disclose some some what do you call like bias against
Donald Trump and they investigated him and we're letting them
go for that reason. I think that's where Eric's going. But uh
oh this is just weird that that he like he he guessed where he
was going. He just started answering that question instead. >> Your
terminology and called on your entire career. >> He's talking
about himself too in Congress. You've been a disgrace to the
American people. >> You can reclaim your time all you want.
Mr. Chairman, you're going to allow a witness to Mr. Chairman.
The gentleman has no time. Mr. Chairman, would you admonish the
witness not to insult members? >> Gentleman has no time.
Mr. Chairman will >> quick point of order. Um, could the
gentleman be extended an additional 20 seconds to complete his
thoughts since the witness decided to interrupt him? >> And
the witness will be able to respond if he wants. We'll make sure.
>> My question is, will you, director, recuse yourself,
yes or no, from investigating or making decisions about the 60
individuals, including myself, that you identified as government
gangsters? Yes or no? >> Time of the gentleman has expired.
The witness may respond if he would like >> and the answer
was no, as I heard. >> Correct. Okay. The gentleman from
Wisconsin, the gentleman yields back. The gentle from Wisconsin
is recognized for five. >> Guys, bias is really bad. Anybody
who doesn't like Trump, why would why would anybody be able to
investigate Trump who doesn't like him? Will you recuse yourself
since you obviously identified me as somebody you want to prosecute?
No. No. I'm coming for you. Okay. All right. Dave. >> Thank
you, Chairman. Uh, thank you, Director Patel, for being here
today. I wanted to talk a little bit about the assassination
of Charlie Kirk and the FBI's subsequent investigation. I know
it's really sensitive and, uh, you know, you can make the call
as >> I'll give this guy five 10 seconds, 15 seconds to
cook. Okay.
I think it's
identifying the suspect and and apprehending him. Uh, according
to public reports, and I think this is what maybe it's um I I
still have questions about and maybe the public does. According
to public reports, the alleged shooter arrives at on the Utah
Valley University campus nearly 4 hours before the shooting.
Is was that your understanding? Is that kind of >> I'll
let the public reports reflect themselves. I don't have the exact
timeline on. >> Okay. So, we don't have any idea kind of
his prep or how he set up or how he utilized that time when he
first showed up on campus. >> All of those are being currently
investigated through our cell phone analysis and through our
witness interviews. And the state of Utah has now announced charges
seeking the death penalty against this suspect. So, we're a little
limited in what we can >> We're just going to skip past
another Republican here. I It's possible. >> I believe
that happened
because it's part of an ongoing >> Thanks for being here
today. I yield >> Yields back. Here we go. A >> gentleman
from California is recognized. >> Thank you, Director Patel,
for being here today. The FBI searched Jeffrey. >> Wait,
what is this guy's name? It's this Asian guy, right? Short Kim.
Mr. Kim. I'm going with Kim. That's my best guess. Kim >> Epste's
Manhattan residence. Correct. >> I believe that happened
in 2018.
I think there's two locations. 2019. In that residence, the FBI
found a >> Lou. Damn it. >> I don't know. Okay. I
feel like these guys are like just taking L's for no reason.
Every time Cash defers to the
why don't they bring up Okay, perfect. Cuz Pam Bondi had brought
up that she has the client list on her desk. Pam Bondi has brought
up that Donald Trump's name is referenced in the Epstein files.
>> I don't know why. I don't know why they well maybe I
think it would probably be I would think some experience of when
you ask a question about what a third party has said or knows
they go ask that third party right I'm guessing >> unless
I mean if you have those statements like on record if you have
them on recording I don't understand why you need to not why
you shouldn't just reference that in response >> yeah well
I feel like he would just go so I agree with you that it's compelling
it can be compelling but I think the issue is they probably just
don't want to have him Oh, uh, I can't speak to why she did that.
I don't I'm unaware of anything she's talking about. Whatever,
blah, blah, blah. Like, you maybe get her get him to throw her
under the bus, but like it's beyond that, you don't get much
out of him. So, I I feel like it's like some kind of concern
or strategy that I think referring to other people and what they've
said doesn't really work very well in these hearings. Um, unless
it's Trump. Okay, these people will will fall on a sword for
>> Trump has also referenced his name in those files where
he's like, "Don't believe." What did he say? Do you remember
that? I have to find that quote or to find that. >> I he
was like there are names in those files that like could be used
to like hurt people, lie about people. I don't know. He he had
some whole cope about it. I can't remember. Yeah, obviously he
said Dems put his name in there, but I'm saying that like he
said like, "Oh, you know, there's some people in those files
like it would destroy lives if we just released that willy-nilly,
right?" That was like one of his earliest statements. He's like,
"We can destroy people's lives if we just release everything
in there." Oh, no. >> It's like a quote from him saying
that like, "Yeah, I know my name is in those >> It's likeing
that his name appears multiple times. Yeah. >> Yeah. It's
essentially something along those lines. Little little weird.
>> Correct. I don't have the catalog of evidence in front
of me. >> In that residence, the FBI found a safe. >> I'll
accept your representation. >> Okay. And in that safe,
the FBI found topless and lewd photographs of girls.
>> Again, sir, I'll accept your representation. I don't
know. >> Thank you. It was um all over the media of the
time. There's a New York Times article that says Jeffrey Epstein's
indicted on charges as discovery of nude photos is disclosed
dated July 8th, 2019. And the Times reports a trove of loot photographs
of girls was discovered and safe inside financier Jeffrey Epste's
Manhattan mansion. Author Michael Wolf has conducted numerous
interviews of Jeffrey Epstein. I'm going to play for you a video
clip of what Michael Wolf said Epstein told him was in the safe
and what he showed the author was in the safe. So, let's please
play that clip now. >> Elected um and I was sitting talking
to Epstein and he said, "Wait a minute. I got to show you something."
Um, and he went into his safe and he came out with with um with
with photographs. They were they were polaroids, I I think. And
um and he kind of kind of they were he kind of spread them out
like playing cards. And it was Trump. I mean, I think there were
a dozen of them. And and it was Trump with girls of an uncertain
age at Epstein's Palm Beach House where all all of the things
that he would ultimately be accused of took place. And I remember
very vividly three of them. There are two in which Trump is uh
the girls topless girls are sitting on Trump's lap and then a
third in which he has a a a stain on the front of his pants and
the girls are kind of kind of pointing at it sort of bent over
laughing. Oh god, your president's a quick shot guys. Unlucky.
Mr. Trump is a premature ejaculator and he's being or he's got
uh you know what what small humiliation. I don't know all the
fetishes they could be doing there. There's a lot of things they
could be laughing at him for. Okay. It's rough. Nothing good.
Nothing good happening there. Okay. Jesus. >> Director
P. I'm going to ask you a very broad and general question. As
you know, Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epste were friends. There
are, of course, photos showing Donald Trump together with Epste.
Correct. >> I don't have the entirety of the photographs,
but I think they've been photographed in public together. >> All
right. Are there any photos showing Donald Trump with girls of
an uncertain
>> How do you know that? because that information would
have been brought to light by multiple administrations and FBI
investigators over the course of the last 20 years. >> Well,
you know what? That's just not true because no one knew about
the creepy birthday message that Donald Trump wrote to Jeffrey
Epstein until the Wall Street Journal disclosed it and then all
of a sudden the Epstein estate provides it to Congress. Certainly,
you weren't there at the
>> Oh, Mr.
>> didn't I think Trump sued the Wall Street for saying
that that was a lie that he didn't write that letter and then
that's why they released it, right? Um
I well he Ted Lou or Mr. Lou here I think it's Ted Lou is saying
that the Epstein estate apparently released it but um I don't
know if he dropped the lawsuit with the Wall Street Journal or
not. I think he I think it was with the Wall Street Journal's
parent company right to Trump I don't I didn't keep tabs on it
here. Trump files $15 billion lawsuit against New York Times
just recently and then sues Wall Street Journal for liel over
publishing of alleged Epstein letter. He had to have dropped
it though. Like the the letter just factually exists. There's
no reason he'd keep going with it. Right.
>> I just feel like Yeah, there's no possible way. Let's
see here. Wa Rupert Murdoch and some reporters. Well, I I think
the Wall Street Journal one was in there. Like this is the um
this is the Wall Street Journal one. Trump's Wall Street Journal
lawsuit raises a new qu constitutional question. And this was
over the Epstein letter, but >> yep, the birthday letter
to him. >> So, we'll see. Think it's out now, like as of
a week or two ago. Think it's out now. I don't know what that
means. Out now. The letter's out now. Yes. Anyway, we can just
continue. Who's controlling Epstein's estate? I have no idea.
Um, yeah, I I would assume he has to drop this lawsuit if it's
just like straight up published. It's like factually there. >> Has
not been dropped yet. It's not been crazy. That's weird. I don't
understand
>> you don't know >> what Epste may or may not have
done with those photographs even prior to the search. Maybe someone
has it. Maybe the Epstein estate has it. >> You rais a
great point. >> So, so I'm going to ask you, have you um
asked to talk to Michael Wolf? >> You rais a great point.
I haven't personally asked to talk to Michael FBI as the FBI
I'll get back to you if the FBI has ever about a 100 hours of
testimony of Jeffrey Epstein. Would would it be good for the
FBI to interview Michael Wilson? >> I'm not saying they
haven't. I just don't know. >> Has FX subpoenaed the tapes
that Michael Wolf has conducted of Jeffrey Epste? >> I
don't know. >> All right. So, if you could provide us an
answer, that would be terrific. Well, let me ask you this question
then. Um, have you looked at all the photos in Epstein files?
>> I have looked at all the information that the investigators
who investigated this case have provided to run out credible
leads. >> And in the Epstein files, was there that creepy
birthday message that Donald Trump had written to Epste? >> No,
that's what I was trying to tell you. You raised a great point.
The estate of Jeffrey Epstein has a voluminous amount of information
that they have not released before. >> Okay. So that's
great. So um wouldn't it be great if FBI subpoenaed the estate
of Jeffrey Epste for all that information? >> The estate
is under no obligation to provide that material even pursuant
to a subpoena. That's a great point. >> Yeah, that's just
that's just false. >> that's just false. You're the freaking
FBI. You can subpoena the information from the estate and you
better do that.
I'm going to move on now and talk about Epstein's client list.
You confirm >> um Wait, hold on. What? Why would they not
be able to subpoena things they think are related to a criminal
investigation? Oh, this guy died. Yeah, actually, you know what?
>> Tip $10.
>> Medium term lurker. Just want to say keep up the good
work. Quality streams
>> Oh, thanks Big Red Tank. Appreciate it, buddy. That
also conveniently adds an hour onto the stream. Let's go. We
had another hour here. >> Oh my god. Yes. Maybe we'll have
time to watch. Here's Morgan continue
to pull in the most relevant influencers of our lifetime. Tonight
was Jeffree Star. >> Wait, who the [__] is
Jeffree Star? What? Make YouTube makeup influencer?
>> Trans infamous for just being like a [__]
human being and probably having a lot of blackmail on black rappers
who don't want people to know that they've with a trans person.
>> Nope. Nothing. Literally no clue. Literally nothing.
Literally the face. Nothing about this person. >> Do you
know who James Charles is?
>> Uh I know who James Charles is. Yeah, bro. This is >> James
Charles basically wanted to be this person. James Charles just
grew past this person. >> You know, this person >> kind
of destroyed James Charles.
>> You ever see Gerald's game before? This person looks
like the uh like the murder or monster from uh Gerald's game.
You guys know you guys know what I'm talking >> What's
Gerald's game? Jeffree Star is still relevant cuz Jeffree Star
is a trans person on the internet willing to say, "You trans
people are too much and you can't ever be mainstream and you
guys need to be locked up.
really up what you're doing to these people. Even though like
for the most part, like trans people at large did not do this
to Charlie Kirk. It was like this one person who did it. But
Jeffrey is willing to throw all of the trans people in the world
under the bus for like 10 minutes of relevancy on a Pierce Morgan
like panel.
>> Okay. All I can >> isn't trans. What the [__]
is this if it's not trans?
>> Drag I assume. So there's a there's a >> horror
novel. I think it's by >> the that he wears he cannot still
have a >> I feel like I've watched like at least a half
season of Rupaul's Drag Race before and I know for a fact that
Trust me, you think you think they can't tuck. Okay, they can
tuck. >> That's not tucking. That's magic. That is a disappearing
act. That's not tucking. Why would I know about tucking? Okay,
I'm sorry. Explain who the person >> Oh, yeah. So, there's
this horror novel by Stephen King called Gerald's Game. Some
woman goes on a vacation with her husband. They're doing some
BDSM. He handcuffs her to a bed and then he dies of a heart attack
and she's stuck to in this bed and she starts hallucinating a
guy like a demon in her house. She's like hallucinating this
demon in her house. And the punchline of the movie is eventually
you find out that the demon was not a demon. It was actually
like a weird looking serial killer. Um, >> oh yeah, Jeffree
Star likes to shave
their eyebrows off and like Yeah, they got like a whole thing.
They do look pretty demonic sometimes. >> Like this is
this is uh this is what he looks like. I got I got the scene.
>> Oh, that's [__] up. >> I get the scene
here. Uh
>> you're not real.
>> You're made of You're not real. You're only made of
>> I'm sorry, but it's like it's like exact. I'm sorry.
It's like exact. >> Okay. The image of that thing alone
is why Jeffree Star still gets Botox and lipo. So stop it. >> It's
real. Okay. It's like I'm sorry. So I'm just telling you. All
right. That's the first thing that came to mind.
>> That scene is actually disturbing. The the footlicking
scene is the disturbing
>> Okay. Well, I apologize to all trans people if Jeffree
Star is not trans. That's that's my bad, >> dude. Google
is killing me. It's actually just killing me. I'm trying to find
this video and Google is me. Why? Google is constantly I have
like a dedicated IP through my VPN and it's like no I'm still
going to check you as a robot all the time. >> Uh that's
why I go incognito.
>> Um one second. Gerald's game footing scene. Trying to
find this. Okay. Is that it? No, that's not it. Oh, I can't even
find it. It's not even here. It's not even on Oh, there it is.
She's like hallucinating from her phone getting like pulled off.
Hold on. I uh she like had really badly >> begin with and
look how he ended. >> No mother >> career always.
You're wasting precious time here. I can't get out. You have
to I am chained to the godamn bed. >> Don't wait.
>> Oh the thumbnails just >> she was so good at the
haunting of Hill >> Was she that actress? I can't find
the scene. So lucky you guys. We're we're just going back. Okay.
I was going to show a goofy scene. I'll I'll show Cherry the
movie at some point. Okay. It's actually good. It's a good movie.
a good movie. >> You're already made one freaky movie.
>> It's like a very okay movie. It's like a very okay movie.
I I don't mean to say it's a very good movie. It's a very okay
movie. Yeah. Anyway, we continue. >> Confirmed that exists.
Attorney General Pabody confirmed earlier this year that it exists.
I just want to ask you a simple question. Is Prince >> There
you go, Jerry. Right there. Ted Lou got your back. >> Let's
go. >> Andrew on Epstein's client list. >> The material
related to Prince Andrew has been made public. >> Is Prince
Andrew on on the client list? We have released the index of names
that were in Jeffrey Epste. >> Is Donald Trump on Epste's
client list? >> The index has been released and the index
will speak for itself. >> I'm just going to say America
is a huge red flag. FBI director could not answer whether Donald
Trump was on Epired
recognizes the gentleman from Virginia. >> Thank you, Mr.
Chairman. I want to thank the director for being here and for
his work over the last several months um
>> What's that? I'm just like putting it together now that
the first Indian director of the FBI is scamming us all out of
the Epste files.
>> Uh America
America wants to redeem and he won't let us now. Now >> he
will not redeem the files. >> We cannot redeem.
It's the taint of partisanship that has infected the intelligence
community over the uh past several years under the last administration,
under the last several directors. standing up for law enforcement,
standing up for the brave men and women who work in your agency.
Uh, but >> thank you for standing up for law enforcement,
Mr. Cash Patel. >> To set the record straight, you know,
we have to correct the record and and the record um early days
of the first Trump administration saw a dramatic spike in news
stories that contain sensitive and sometimes classified details
about the FBI's bogus Russia probe about a leak a day. It's unacceptable
that senior FBI officials coordinated to leak classified information
to try and harm President Trump. Um, documents produced to the
committee in August of this year revealed that the FBI interviewed
a former uh, intelligence committee staffer who gave details
on a systematic process through which leaks of classified information
were affected by then chairman, now Senator Adam Schiff. Were
these findings escalated within the bureau's chain of command?
And if so, to what level? >> Sorry, were the findings >> were
these findings that were given to us escalated within the bureau's
chain of command and if so, what level did you receive this information?
that that entire matter is currently under investigation by the
people at the FBI that handle leaks of classified >> All right.
It's good to know that there is an ongoing investigation. Um,
can you tell me whether these leaks uh to the media compromise
any ongoing FBI investigations during the Trump Russia >> I
can tell you generally speaking, the leaks of classified information
are detrimental to any work the FBI is >> Now, former Director
James Comey testified before the Senate Judiciary Committee that
he had never been an anonymous source nor authorized >> Don't
care. Don't care. Don't care. Uh, don't care. Republican offiscation.
We're done. We're done. We're done. >> Mr. Chairman, Mr.
Patel, before you joined the FBI, you had very strong opinions
about what the FBI was hiding regarding Jeffrey.
I This is one of the good Trust me, this woman is the only woman
who's truly enraged. All right. This is a hardworking Indian-American
woman who had to fight for her position, and this guy scammed
his way to the top of the FBI. Okay. Ain't nobody hate someone
who's a bad representative of the race, like somebody from that
race. Okay, she's not going to take it. She's not going to be
okay with it. She's going to be Epstein. In a September 2023
interview with Glenn Beck, you said the blackbook is under the
quote direct control of the director of the FBI. In December
2023, you said, "Let us know who the are even for a short time
after becoming FBI director." In February of 2025, you tweeted,
quote, "There will be no cover-ups, no missing documents, no
stone left unturned." In June, you told Joe Rogan, quote, "We've
reviewed all the information. We're going to give you every single
thing we have and can." But then suddenly in July, everything
changed. You and Attorney General Pam Bondi released one video
and said that there was nothing more to see. Your July memo says
you uncovered more than 300 gigabytes of data and physical evidence,
but that you had decided no further disclosure would be appropriate
or warranted. That is a quote. I think what happened, Mr. Patel
is that suddenly you >> okay the funny thing here is okay
just as a small slight itty bitty defense okay it's possible
that through social media through like a long-term campaign Jeffrey
Epstein's like legacy has been you know sort of bastardized into
people feeling like they're guaranteed that he had this like
huge child p like trafficking ring right it's possible that this
person was looked into. It wasn't like that. They were just like
a degenerate who had a bunch of this. And Cash is now like, well,
I can't release like the videos of the victims or anything. And
it's possible that like he's actually in a place where it would
be inappropriate. It's possible that he's not protecting people.
It just would be inappropriate to release what they have, right?
I'm not saying I believe that. I'm saying it's possible. But
is it not like the most beautiful of ironies that that obviously
if that were true then probably his previous his sorry, his predecessors
would have been in that same position. the predecessors he said
were protecting
and now he has to sit here and be accused of protecting the same
thing he did to them. Like that is that is the best case scenario
for Cash Patel right now is he just has to take the same drubbing
publicly this he has to be labeled a protector publicly the same
way he did to all these other people. Like that's just a beautiful
irony to me that even in the best case scenario this guy is still
going to get stuck with that reputation like he tried to stick
other people. Okay. That is to me that makes this all a little
bit a little bit easier to to sit through. >> Discovered
that Donald Trump's name was all over these. >> Oh, hold
on. I'm going to back it up. >> Had decided no further
disclosure would be appropriate or warranted. That is a quote.
I think what happened, Mr. Patel, is that suddenly you discovered
that Donald Trump's name was all over these files and you started
a giant cover up. So, you are under oath, Mr. Patel. You just
testified to Mr. Swallwell that you did not speak to the president
about the Epstein files. To your knowledge, did Attorney General
Pam Bondi speak to the president about what was in the Epstein
>> I can't speak for attorney general Pam >> So to
your knowledge, you don't have any information. The question
was, do you have any knowledge? Do you have any >> You
are refusing to answer the question. So, let me tell you that
the Wall Street Journal reported that in May, Bondi told Trump
that he was in the Epstein files and at the same meeting said
that the DOJ did not plan to release the files. Yesterday, you
testified to Senator Kennedy that there was quote no credible
information that Epstein trafficked girls to anyone else and
that you have quote continuously and publicly asked the public
to come forward with more information and we'll look into it.
Today, in response to Mr. Massiey's question. You appear to say
that the survivors were not credible. These are survivors. That's
not at all what I >> Okay, great. I'm going to ask you
this in a second, but let me tell you about the survivors and
let's bring them up here into the room. These are women who came
to the Hill and testified that they were groomed and raped at
the age of 14 and 16 years old and they called to meet with the
president and to meet with the FBI and to have people investigate
their claims. Some of them have never testified before. If you
are so interested in getting the public to submit any information,
why have you not met with them? You said you haven't met with
them. Have you met with them? I'll give you one more chance.
>> My job as the FBI director is to inform. >> Not
my job. Not my job. Okay. Wait. What was the job of the previous
FBI director? Sounds like the previous FBI director. So, you
had a direct authority over some things. Sounds like nothing
was their job either. Do they not have the same job as you, brother?
What are you talking about? Yes or no to whether or not you met
with these women who were abused and >> any insinuation
by you or any people on your side that I am not manhunting child
predators and traffickers just look at the stats and you talk
about coverups
where you during the Obama and Biden administrations when these
so-called coverups were going on in those administrations talked
to any of these reported witnesses regular order single person
to provide credible information >> time belongs to the
gentle lady from Washington.
You accuse the witness of something, he's allowed to respond.
That's how it works. >> Listen, he didn't even accuse me.
You have always been fair. But this is not fair.
This is my time. And he said that the witnesses were not.
I'm going to get an additional minute of time because >> as
a as a powerful
um what do you call it? As a powerful woman of color over there,
Jim, you better sit down. You better sit your white ass down
and listen, Jim. >> You'll get a minute. You'll get some
seconds. What we think is is under five minutes. You don't get
to demand how much time you get. That's not how it >> Mr.
Patel, are the victims of the Jeffrey Epstein horrific trafficking
ring? Are they credible? >> Any person with information
about ongoing trafficking? >> I'm asking you if they're
credible, >> ma'am. I'm commenting on the evidence we have.
We have routinely asked for people to come forward with more
evidence and we will look at it. And the evidence that we have
was the same evidence that the Biden and Obama Justice Department
had. They did. >> Didn't one of them just file a thing
of the like emails saying they hey they reached out to the FBI
to talk to them to get their own files like what their own testimony
was unredacted back. They've been unable to reach the FBI. Hey,
could you commit? Could you make commit here and now cash to
speaking directly to the women who said they've reached out to
the FBI and have been unable to get anyone on the phone? Could
you commit to talking to them? I feel like that would be the
bare minimum. No. >> Determined. Not me. They determined
that >> talking past each other. I think there's like some
strategic talking past each other because Cash Patel does bring
up earlier some of the stuff that happened in Florida because
I think a lot of assault against minor charges unless trafficking
is involved that is covered by the state. The state has to handle
that. The state has to prosecute that. Federal does not get involved
unless it happens on federal land or unless it is trafficking
crossing lines. >> Yeah. Crossing state borders. Yeah.
Interstate commerce. Sure. when he con when he mentions
um trafficking here, but he also brings up what the Florida state
governor did and what the um attorney general in Florida offered
with Epstein, that like sweet ass deal. Like I I feel like there's
something that he could say to appease her, but he's just choosing
not to. Like he could clarify here, but it feels like he's choosing
not to. Oh, well I think um like I see what you're saying. I
don't know if it's over that although that probably seems like
the best if I had to guess that would be the best case or the
sorry the best explanation. But yeah, it seems like he is intentionally
like like he knows there's something that excalates him in some
way. There's something that exonerates him rather exonerates
him in some way that like puts it out of his authority but he
refuses to elaborate on what it is and that makes him look suspicious.
Right. Because what if the thing that exonerates him, it doesn't
exonerate Trump? Like, oh, okay. Yeah, but I'm not the person
who should talk to these women. Uh, I've heard some of their
stories, and that would be handled by the states, but they are
credible. >> Hey, hey, >> that's not going to satisfy
the guy he wrote a book for. >> Yeah. Yeah. Well, oh, this
might Trump off a lot. Like, if Trump, especially if Trump has
some idea that like he's actually quite involved in one of those
cases, right? Hey, you need to go focus on Florida. you need
to go focus on start hammering Florida. They have the answer.
And then it's like, oh, the answer is Trump [__]
some kids. It's like, oh, well, Cash Patel was put in front of
the on the White was shot on the White House lawn today. Okay.
Court uh what? Not court marshal. Executed for treason. Yeah,
not good. But sorry, I also wanted to highlight this one to message
from a little bit earlier. What was it? Yo, how thick are this
[__] shoulder pads? That's actually What the >> What
is going on here? This guy's in his armor right now. Guy behind
him's in his armor, too. >> He's in his armor. >> Yeah.
I thought guys didn't really do
You seem to be doing it. I'm looking at the shoulder pads. I'm
looking at the shoulder pad. >> But you keep centering
it on her >> cuz that's what puts the shoulder pads in
frame. >> You're missing all of the men's shoulder pads
and it's like perfectly centered on her rack. >> I scanned
along. I scanned along. This is as far as it goes to the left
though. >> Teenly asked for people to come forward with
more evidence and we will look. >> No. Oh, those socks
are cute >> with that tie. With the tie, they're >> That
tie it's a crime. >> Yeah, with the tie it's really [__]
up actually. Yeah, it's actually super [__] up with
that tie. >> Person with information about ongoing
>> I'm asking you if they're credible. >> Ma'am,
I'm commenting on the evidence we have. We have routinely asked
for people to come forward with more evidence and we will look
at it. And the evidence that we have was the same evidence that
the Biden and Obama Justice Department had. And they determined,
not me, they determined that that information was not >> He's
not letting me even ask my >> You ask the questions, he
gives an answer. You don't you may not like what he says but
I don't mean you get interrupted answering my question. >> Mr.
Could we restore the gentle lady 45 seconds so she can give her
30 seconds which is what I said. >> I'm going to keep taking
my time because the time that you get >> you are not answer
>> sorry. Go ahead. >> You're aren't you supposed
to ask for permission to treat him with like he's hostile or
something like that. >> No, that's in a court. I don't
think you have to do that in Congress. I I don't think you have
to do that in in Congress. She is proclaiming her time. >> I
swear I've seen it happen in Congress >> like asking person
is hostile. I feel like they just always do that. I've never
heard it, but I've seen them definitely treat people as hostile
>> Yeah, Jim Jordan used to be famous for this. Used to
do this [__] all the time. Him and Trey Gaudy used
to
they used to have some actual Republicans who could ask good
questions and make people look pretty bad. I don't know if they
really exist anymore. Don't really see them get their job done
very often anymore, but they used to. Congress people always
treat witnesses as hostile. Yeah, that's what I thought. I thought
they did it a lot. I know Trey >> I mean like the performative
asking I could have sworn I've seen like several clips of that
but maybe not >> Trey Gouty on Fox News and stuff now what's
weird is Trey Gouty left Congress because he said that he didn't
like the part like how partisan it was becoming and then he went
to Fox News and he's just like a partisan hack. I feel he said
something along the lines of I like Trey Gouty too, but he said
something along the lines of there's like something less respectable
about the way he left because he left Congress saying I can't
be I'm not like I'm not like these people. I can't, you know,
put my party above my country. I can't. He literally said out
loud basically like these people are all lying crooks and I can't
be a part of it. And then he went on Fox News and he's just a
he's just a talking head now. I'm sitting here like, dude, this
brother, you you can't say that you don't want to be with these
people because they lie in their scum and then you go and join
their propaganda network. That's pretty that kind of gets rid
of any, you know, any upside to you leaving or any uh I don't
know any sacrifice, any nobility to your leaving. It just gets
rid of it. It kind of erases it. I don't know. Weird. Too >> Answering
the question. The question is, you just don't like these women.
Are these women credible? It's a yes or no answer. have answered
the question. I keep telling you I'm the only FBI director that
has welcomed new information in this case. This administration
is the only one that has welcomed any new information in this
>> Is there a yes or no? >> Present new credible
information. Present new information. >> Are the victims
credible or not?
>> I'll tell you what happened in the last Trump administration.
>> Credible or not? You >> victims credibly came
forward and you know what happened? President Trump authorized
the indictments of Jeffrey
not Obama. President Trump called the entire thing a a democratic
hoax. So I would like to ask >> the gentle lady time is
expired. I gave her the additional 45 seconds he
>> That is a good thing to refocus on quite often that
Trump isn't even in line with Castell or Pam Bondi or anybody
who's done any investigations at all. He just calls the whole
thing a damn hoax and moves on like all the time. >> The
gentle lady yields back. The gentleman from New Jersey is recognized
for his meet with the women who were not
and and groom
years old. Are you going to cover up? Are you going to continue
from powerful men including those that might be on this committee?
>> I can yell too, Mr. Chairman, but I don't want to yell
about the time belongs to the gentleman from New
>> I think I think Rasin's supposed to step in and say
something, isn't he? Go ahead. >> Will you allow them to
testify to you >> as like the ranking Dem on the on the
committee? I think he's supposed to step in and go like, "Hey,
you got to chill,
>> I think Patel, >> Mr. Patel, thank you for being
here. I know it's been an interesting and difficult two days.
And I wasn't going to talk about the Epste thing because there's
a lot of other issues that affect the FBI. But I >> Is
is Cash Patel protecting people? She's saying is she is that
a shot at Jordan explicitly? I feel like that was a shot at him
>> exp. I just I've sat here. I've listened to this. I've
watched it. And you know, my Democratic colleagues are so concerned
now, Mr. Patel. All of a sudden, where were they last year? Where
were they the year before? Where were they the year before that?
Where was the last president in any of this? All I know, the
only thing I see is a single letter from the ranking member that
was sent in 2019 that he didn't like the plea deal. And some
people signed on to that. Most of the truth, the real truth,
let's be honest. Let's be intellectually honest. The real truth
is, >> wait, were Republicans freaking out in 2019 about
it? They might have been. I'm actually not totally sure. Hold
on a second here. >> An article titled Justice Department
>> deported back to El Salvador even though he was charged
with murder. >> To the record, an article titled Justice
Department told Trump in May that his name is among many in the
Epstein files. Uh, I have another one um that is uh a July 2025
article by the New York Times entitled, "How a frantic scouring
of the Epstein files consumed the Justice Department stating
that DOJ and FBI employees reviewing the Epstein files were instructed
to flag any mentions of Trump and other celebrities."
>> And I and for names I am chairman and
recognize the dele. >> Thank you, Mr. Chairman. And thank
you, Mr. Patel, for coming before us to testify today. Um, I
I am concerned by your repeated claims that you're not able to
disclose anything further about the Epstein investigation in
files and that there's no evidence of a broader conspiracy or
other people who should be charged because the American people
aren't be buying that you've been transparent or that there's
nothing further to be seen. Um, in your exchange with my colleague,
Mr. Roy, you reiterated something that I heard you say yesterday
in your Senate testimony, and that is under your direction, the
FBI will always follow the money. Is that right? >> The
money. Did you say? Yes. >> Yes. You said you'll follow
the money. That's great. And just now you said you welcome the
opportunity to investigate new evidence. So there has been sign
there have been like new developments kind of in Jeffrey Epste's
financial network, right? The fact that he met with Peter Teal,
the fact that he met with um Barack, I think that stuff's been
coming up in the past year or so, right? So it' be very interesting
to get him on the record about like are you looking in these
directions? Are you looking at his financial ties? Like clearly
this is a bad guy. Are you going to start looking into his financial
ties? ificant recent reporting just in the last couple weeks
that after Jeffrey Epstein was arrested, four major banks flagged
more than $1.5 billion dollars in suspicious transactions connected
to him that suggested a massive conspiracy related to his child
trafficking activities. Director Patel, has the FBI reviewed
the 1.5 billion in suspicious bank transactions flagged to the
government relating to Epstein and his >> I know the
we're aware of it. I have no idea what happened. I didn't look
at any of it. >> Reviewed numerous SARS. I don't know the
totality of that number. >> Okay. Do you can you provide
us with that number? >> I'll get back to you. >> Okay.
And have you initiated any new investigation of those bank transactions
since say September 8th when the new reporting came out? >> I'll
check with the Treasury Department because they're the lead on
that. >> Okay. So, Director Patel, how many individuals
or entities um has the FBI interviewed, subpoenaed, or compelled
to testify? Can you give us those numbers with respect to these
bank transactions? Uh, not off the top of my head. I'll have
to work with Treasury. >> Okay. We're concerned, you see,
because you say you're going after child predators, but obviously
this is how you follow the money is if you follow the bank transactions
that um apparently enabled the child sex trafficking. Would you
agree? >> It's one of the valuable investigative tools
is to follow the money. >> Okay. Um, have Jeffrey Epstein's
victims have asked us to ask you whether or not you've investigated
Epstein's lawyers, the lawyers who facilitated those payments.
Have you um subpoenaed or questioned any of those lawyers? >> So
in 2018 and 19, what I recollect is many if not every one of
those lawyers was part of the investigation. >> But you
weren't there at that time. I wasn't there. Okay. So can you
get us the names and the numbers of who was investigated then
with respect to those >> As long as I'm allowed to release
it. >> Okay. Well, if we provide you with subpoenas, I
assume you can release it. Is that right? >> We have a
current subpoena and we're working with Congress to provide it.
>> Okay. Um you've said that the Aosta investigation had
an original sin. What do you mean by that? Basically, if you're
looking at an actual ring, what you should not do is limit the
time frame in which you're legally able to collect information.
So, search warrants that Mr. Aosta utilized in 2006 and 7 leading
to the 2008 plea agreement had a very specific narrow window
of years. I think three or four years. And so, information pursuant
to legal process wasn't collected for 10 years or 15 years or
20 years. It also in uh subpoenas were not sent out to hundreds
of witnesses at the time, hundreds of victims at the time. None
of that was done. None of these people were put in grand juries.
And so the totality of information from the >> like is
he saying that they haven't reached out to any of those same
people or they don't have the ability to. Maybe he's saying something
along the line along the lines of what you were saying Cherry
is like, "Hey, there's hundreds of victims and hundreds of witnesses
that we can't access. We we don't have access to anything from
them." Is he saying that they can't subpoena them now >> instead
of being this big was like this? And that in my opinion is not
how you run an investigation if you're trying to break a traffic.
So you're now in >> narrow window. >> Okay. Um >> this
should be the question. >> You've said that the Aosta investigation
had an original sin. What do you mean by >> Basically,
if you're looking at an actual ring, what you should not do is
limit the time frame in which you're legally able to collect
information. So search warrants that Mr. Aosta utilized in 2006
and 7 leading to the 2008 plea agreement had a very specific
narrow window of years. I think three or four years. And so information
pursuant to legal process wasn't collected for 10 years or 15
years or 20 years. It also in uh subpoenas were not sent out
to hundreds of witnesses at the time, hundreds of victims at
the time. None of that was done. None of these people were put
in grand juries. And so the totality of information from the
jump instead of being this big was like this. And that in my
opinion is not how you run an investigation if you're trying
to break. >> So he's saying, okay, there's hundreds of
witnesses, hundreds of uh of things we need to look for, right?
Hundreds of witnesses, hundreds of victims. Like what is he what
is he saying there? Why is he not going out like >> No,
what he is he's saying this is something that he can do. He gets
to scrutinize how the state handled it. He gets to scrutinize
how Florida handled their Epstein investigation
and that's corruption. What that person did was corruption and
that's that's not what the federal government would do. that's
not how he would have handled the investigation and it's probably
prevented
um his ability or Florida thereafter's ability to have like as
much information as they could right now if somebody corrupt
wasn't leading that investigation then but the federal government
the FBI does not oversee what Florida does they would not he
would not >> but I'm saying if he's aware of those victims
why is he not reaching out to them now >> well that would
that would have those victims would have to be trafficked for
the FBI to have the ability to investigate. Like they need to
have >> I don't think so. I think they could just be persons
of interest. They could just reach out. The FBI, the cops can
reach out to whoever they want who's a person of interest in
the case. If you want to force them to come in, you want to force
them to give testimony, then I think you need some probable cause.
Or if you want search warrants or something, you can just ask
>> if this is the No, they absolutely have to have they
can't just go investigating things that they have no jurisdiction
to
>> Well, I think they would investigate Jeffrey Epstein's
federal crimes and say like we we
>> Yeah. Like they would just say we suspect you have information
like on his trafficking ring and they would reach out and say
hi. Oh, well that's why we know all the details that we know
about
um what went wrong with the Florida uh investigation and stuff,
right? That's already been they they scoured through that. He's
he's telling you what those findings were. I don't understand
what you're looking for more. >> So, it sounds like they
have not talked to that many victims, right? He says there's
hundreds of victims and like hundreds of pieces of evidence that
we they didn't have in scope. And it's like, okay, why wouldn't
you be able to just say
you can reach out to? Okay. I just I think he's talking about
like
>> because they >> Well, I don't know that they have
the names. It it sounds like because these people went back only
3 four years. They they should have gone back further are like
were limited to how much information they pulled. >> So,
do you feel like he's lying here when he says hundreds of victims
that he doesn't know that he's saying like hypothetically there
could be hundreds of victims they missed? Well, I don't think
he's lying. I think he's
>> Okay. He's fabric. He He's He doesn't know what that
number is. He's just saying there could be hundreds of >> I
imagine.
>> Okay.
I thought I thought he was going to I thought he was like saying
basically this is what I think they up and I'm like, couldn't
you fix that [__] up or is that just a [__]
up we have to live with forever? I guess seems kind of odd, but
>> make a trafficking ring. No, it just to me it feels
like the more he talks about what Florida did wrong, it's just
going into territory that he has no jurisdiction over.
>> it's like a win-win. Yeah, we could talk about Florida's
up because it's in the past. There's nothing we could do about
it now. And I literally have no jurisdiction over
and of a Well, I don't know. Do they have over child? I don't
know if they >> There's going to be file
laws. Yeah, there are federal child laws for sure.
>> Um, but I would still say that probably I I don't know.
Yeah, it's I it's not important. We We can wait and see if they
bring anything else up about it, but it just to me I >> maybe
I'm confused. I don't know. >> If you got if you got by
Osama bin Laden, I feel like I could probably like ask you to
speak on 911 or something. I I just be like, "Oh, you're related
to a person of interest in that case like in a tangible way is
probably the wrong word, but if you're like a part of a terror
cell for a different thing, right? If you had like information
that was tangibly related in some way, like I feel like I could
go and talk to that person without forcing them to and say like,
do you have any information on this case on any of the broader
stuff that we could prosecute on?" >> And I would think
you'd want to leave >> unturned. We do like when our agencies
cooperate, but we don't like it has to make sense when they cooperate,
right? >> Well, I'm not even saying cooperate. I'm saying
if you have names
related, >> you just say, "Hey, if you have any information,
could you give us a shout?" >> I think you end up with
more questions from other people. If like the FBI just starts
interrogating somebody who has that the only thing that they're
telling you is um that they were a victim of a assault. Well,
I don't know if that's the only thing. That's the problem is
I have no idea what they'd be telling me. >> Yeah. Yeah.
That's that's why I feel like he's he's doing something slippery
here because I I don't believe that he hasn't that he has no
idea what those uh witnesses have to say. I don't believe at
all that he hasn't heard or doesn't know what they're testifying
to. >> Okay, that's fair. So, you think this is more with
regards to the witnesses that at least um uh Jipal, the the congresswoman
is is referencing. You think he knows what they have to say?
He he knows that probably he can't do anything with that testimony,
right? Like they could testify to crimes that happened there.
Maybe even somebody from the FBI's talked to them or something.
Maybe they have testimony from these people and it's like, well,
it's outside the scope of what we can handle. Fortunately, that's
like covered by the Florida immunity agreement or the Florida
prosecution agreement or something, right?
>> All right. Uh, we continue. >> That in my opinion
is not how you run an investigation if you're trying to break
a trafficking ring. >> So, you're now in charge of the
FBI. Why haven't you done that investigation?
>> Great question. And here's the answer. Simply because
I am >> I think we could have just saved about 10 minutes
or 15 minutes of discussion like by hitting for five. I think
he's about to answer that exact question. >> All right,
let's Well, we got to see who was right. >> Champ right
there. Yeah, I know. I know. I'm just laughing that like we just
speculated on that and >> and not able to go back 20 years
and collect information that the courts had decided was already
subject to search warrants. They have said this was in the investigation.
there's a nonprosecution out of that plea. And when the case
was reopened, and this is where it comes into play, when the
case was reopened in 2018 and 2019, the search warrants again
were limited to the conduct of Jeffrey Epstein. Now, whether
that's right or wrong, that's a different discussion, but I'm
telling you that's the >> Well, I think that is a different
discussion. And I think the discussion we'd like to have today
is why you aren't following the money with respect to the broader
um >> is this dim? >> Uh, probably. I'm sorry, but
the whole point is, hey, when it was first started, they didn't
gather all of the evidence that they should have. They limited
their scope. And then when it was reopened, they still limited
their scope. This is a trafficking ring.
You think that I'm still going to have the best chance to investigate
this? You think anybody still got the best chance to investigate
this? I'm letting you know the battles in front of me. These
been dropping the ball. What? What do you mean? Oh, well, can't
you just like go back 20 years and get all of this information?
Huh? >> I think I think the other thing that he might be
hinting at here is something similar is that he might they might
have signed agreements that just said like, "Okay, we've done
like you can't look into me for crimes like this anymore." Like
he might have signed some kind of like plea deal that says, "Okay,
this is like he's basically like double jeopardied out or something
somehow." like he he's it's possible he signed like a prosecution
or non was it nonprose prosecution agreement or something where
like basically they can't go after him for certain things there
anymore and so they can't even really subpoena the evidence to
go >> I don't even I don't even know if it's that we like
think about this entire year where people are worried like oh
my god you said something a month late or two months too late
all the evidence might be wiped this is in front of Congress
in front of your face saying yo for 20 years they limited did
this. You want me to go back 20 years in time? I'm telling you,
I wouldn't have run this this way. >> I get what he's saying,
but that's like unfortunately people are basically never going
to be satisfied with like, >> oh, if they have questions,
it's I have no sympathy for him because he did it to people,
right? Directly. But if he had done itirect to people, bad person,
>> but no, I'm saying I'm saying it's ironic that he's
going to get because people as long as people can ask a question.
If as long as people could say uh as long as people could say,
"Hey, did you do this? Hey, did you do that?" As long as there's
a no anywhere around that, they're they're always going to say,
"You're covering for right." >> Yes, I agree. And it's
funny to watch him have to eat his own [__] right
now cuz it's what he did. But if this was like a good actor in
this seat, it's utterly to hold him accountable and tell him,
"Hey,
>> go back and investigate from 20 years, 30 years ago,
and do as good a job as they should have done back then." >> I
think that's not what they're saying, but like they're saying
like, "You wouldn't be able to do as good of a job, but wouldn't
you go and try your best because it's like important to?" That's
what they're saying. They're not saying like you have to go and
do the job they didn't do before. or it's like can you go and
try your best, right? Like I think they would understand that
it would be like almost impossible to conduct the investigation.
Like there would be lots of things people wouldn't remember,
lots of evidence that would just be gone, >> but it's like
could you go and like try >> I think it's fine to say here
are five women and they're willing to talk to you. Can we talk
about that? I think that's fine, but they keep going back to
like because these five women exist, go find every other person
that was missed.
Mhm. Yeah, it's probably a little unreasonable and keep going
with this. See, see if he has anything else to discuss, but I'm
telling you that's the >> Well, I think that is a different
discussion and I think the discussion we'd like to have today
is why you aren't following the money with respect to the broader
um conspiracy that it has been reported in the New York Times
and elsewhere. and that if you really want to attack the issue,
if you wanted to attack the issue, if you wanted to get to the
bottom of it, if you wanted to disclose what really was involved
in the Epstein files, the Epstein coverup, that you would be
taking very different actions that you are today. Um, I do want
to seek unanimous consent to enter into the record the uh New
York Times September 8th, 2025 article, how JP Morgan enabled
the crimes of Jeffrey >> Without objection. >> And
also an article dated se uh July 17th, 2025 in the Epstein case,
follow the money. >> Without objection. >> Okay.
Thank you. Gentle lady yields >> Mr. Chairman, >> gentleman
from Maryland's recognized. >> Thank you much. Um, pursuant
to clause 2K6 of rule 11, I move that the committee subpoena
the CEOs of four banks. JP Morgan, that's Jamie Diamond, Bank
of New York Melon, Robin Vince, Bank of America, Brian Moyahan,
and Deutsche Bank, Christian Sewing. Uh, in order to get the
suspicious transaction reports, these four banks have flagged
to the government $ 1.5 billion dollars in suspicious transactions
related to the sex trafficking crimes and conspiracy of Epstein,
Maxwell, and all of their collaborators. And as you know, Mr.
Chairman, we got the SARS reports for Hunter Biden totaling around
$20 million and so these $ 1.5 billion in SARS reports we should
get especially since the director doesn't seem to be forthcoming
and I requested you know that we do this immediately. >> I
think the director has been very forthcoming. We will hold any
motion to subpoena and abance until the conclusion of the hearing.
The chair and I recognize the gentleman from Texas. >> Uh
thank you Mr. Chairman. Thank you Director Patel for being here.
It is quite clear is quite clear that certain members of this
committee, you know, they want their 15 seconds on TV stamping
and coming. Maybe it's for fundraising. Maybe they're struggling
in their district. They need a little bump, but they they turn
a committee into a clown show and and that's what we're seeing.
You're being unjustly attacked today. I watched the Senate hearings.
>> Why is someone saying objection every so often? Uh I
think I think we're not catching the no. I think what's happening
is there's unanimous uh is it unanimous consent submissions?
They they submit like pieces of evidence for the the committee
and he I think he's technically saying no objection, but it sounds
like he's saying objection. I think that's what's going on >> yesterday.
You were attacked there. We know there's an agenda. There's always
an agenda. It's the same characters with the same personalities,
the same objective, and that is destroy the mega movement. You're
being attacked, director, is because you're effective. You highlighted
what you've been doing in DC with >> Holy F.
>> uh actually disgusting actually disgusting tell there
were 26 uh the gentleman mentioned the select committee there
were 26 confidential human sources at the capital in January
6th 2021 four entered the capital and thereby broke the law do
you know if those individuals were being paid by the ray FBI
so we've provided 600 pages of documents to this committee loan
regarding January 6 that's 600 pages more than any of my predecessors
generally speaking confidential human sources are always paid
by the FBI that's how it works I can't speak to the specifics
on each one and how much they make >> and we appreciate
it we reviewed some of that material and you give a lot of material
that we didn't get from director Ray. That specific question
I think is important to the American people. Um were people who
were confidential human sources of the FBI who broke the law.
One was one was recommended for prosecution. My understanding
is by the information we've received from you. Were they actually
paid by the very taxpayers who may have got charged with the
same same offense? I think that's important for us to understand.
>> I'll get back to you on that. >> Thank you. Chair
now recognizes the gentleman from California. >> Thank
you, Mr. Chair. Uh welcome, Director Patell. Um, I'm going to
focus a little bit on domestic terrorism. We have a graph here
data up to 2021, but as you can tell, um, domestic >> domestic
domestic terrorism. No, thank you. Come on, man. I'm going to
do maybe one or two and then I think I want to take a pause,
do a quick pallet cleanser. We may watch Apparently Ann and Chank
got in a fight over Jimmy Kimmel. Might want to check that out
shortly. Just for a short bit. We could do it. We're about halfway
through right >> They got into a fight. >> Apparently
they got into a fight. I have no idea how they got into a fight.
Actually, I know exactly how they got into a fight. One of them
said, "It's insane to ever take somebody's job away over this."
And the other one said, "I don't know, man. People are pretty
crazy over Charlie, and that's like misinformation." Or maybe,
maybe they didn't fight at all. I can't tell. Latigious Gamer
said he asked me if I saw them arguing. Uh-oh. Wait, wait, wait.
Was this timestamped?
>> Of course. >> Kimmel gets suspended by ABC.
>> Chunky chocolate chip cookie dude. >> Yeah. No,
they're the same person. >> [__] Y [__]
They're totally the same person. Yeah, of course.
It's a double chunk chocolate Democratic donor. Boom.
>> But in essence, that's what >> Okay, don't worry.
You don't have to laugh. I can laugh. >> Blah blah blah.
But in essence, that's what you're doing here. Look,
>> I really can. Okay. Is it him and Anna here? Are they
going to get into this? Yeah. Okay. So, Anna comes on. We'll
listen to him sum it up. And then Anna, I think Anna's >> number
on your screen today. >> We'll see. >> No. No. You're
>> I didn't actually watch this, so don't blame me if it's
not worth it. I can't believe you, bro. You came in and said,
"Did I see Chank versus Ann on this?" Are you serious? >> You're
making things up. Okay. And I know they didn't say that. To be
Look, they to be perfectly accurate. They didn't say that's what
Charlie would have wanted, right? They're saying in this context,
in our communities, blah blah blah. But in essence, that's what
you're doing here. And and I think it sucks. I think it's bad
for the country. It's bad for free speech. And I'm tired of Trump
and the right-wing look, Kirk, I would argue, was principled
enough on free speech. Trump has not been at all not close, not
within a million miles of close. And in fact, right after Charlie
Kirk died, Bondi and Trump backed him up, backed her up, said,
"Oh, yeah, hate speech. Anything." And Trump even said to a reporter
from ABC, "Maybe we'll go after you. Maybe what you do is hate
speech. Maybe we'll go after you, Ben. >> You're questioning
me. That's hate speech. No, it's not. No, it's not. That's a
reporter doing his job. >> Well, well, I hated it. >> That's
part of the first amendment, freedom of speech, and freedom of
the press. And Trump doesn't understand that. And so now taking
out people who uh make fun of the a politician
to serve that up on a silver planet to Trump. No way. Disgusting.
>> I think I disagree with you. Like the more I sit with
what he said and the more I think about it.
please. Anna, please. Anna, >> I also disagree with him.
I I'm with
>> Oh, soy. So, so toy. >> You don't say. You're
with >> You and Jenk are the soy ones. Okay. This isn't
a government position.
This isn't a a news network. All right. This is a cable news.
This is a a cable TV show. It's a Tonight Show. Uh he's a comedian
and guess what? If the network decides this is bad for business,
that is capitalism. >> That is capitalism and that is fair
and that's totally their right to do. But I >> I think
what he said was not insane. I think it could have easily been
dealt with with a correction. And I Yeah, I just think it's like
totally crazy to like take him off the the air for that. I think
there's every possible reason though if somebody said, "Oh, who
are we watching?" Tim P. That one Tim Pool guy might have been
totally correct. It's possible that if like oh they they just
have to pay him a lot and ratings aren't worth it and television
like mainstream television is just dying. It's possible it just
doesn't make monetary sense to pay Jimmy Kimmel anymore and they're
just like oh this is convenient. Let's get rid of him. Right.
It's possible. Or like having enough people drop out because
you're associated with them is is like yeah the monetary incentives
been destroyed. So it's possible it's just capitalism. Uh the
problem is they're not saying it's capitalism, right? They're
saying other stuff >> and it's also a nightly show. So,
like all 300 people across America who watched this, they're
logging into all 10 of their social media accounts and they're
complaining. It's the same people. It's the same 300 people who
cried when Conan O'Brien lost his nightly show or whatever it
was called. The the hype around these dudes, it doesn't actually
exist online. There are no actual fans of nightly shows. >> That's
I mean, there probably aren't honestly.
The biggest offense that is happening here is the idea that news
could come out of watching the Jimmy Kimmel live. >> That
is true. Yes. I would say streamers have just taken that actually.
Like streamers have straight up taken that. It's like meant to
be, you know, your little thing where it's like a a guy who's
funny and he's just making jokes. He tells you what happens during
the day. I think streamers have just totally taken that entirely
for anybody who's like 35 and under. And you got a writer's room
of like 20 for a 10 minute monologue that sometimes has a commercial
break in the middle of it. And there are streamers and there
are YouTubers who are doing it solo >> and they're going
on it for like seven hours. Like, okay, sit down. I'm just I'm
hoping Anna has this same exact
>> Only if you're a cheaper, okay, who doesn't support
the channel, guys? You can support the channel, too. Okay? You
can be one of the noncheers.
All right? All you got to do is get out your credit card. You
can sub on kick. You can give subs on kick. You can go to Oh,
you can buy kicks on kick. All right. Kicks are now we're tracking
kicks every stream. Okay. So, you can buy a TTS message exclamation
point donating the chat. There's Streamlabs. There's Kickbot
and there's Kicksubs. Okay. Or you can go over to the Twitch
and sign up there. Twitch.tvjsdk
now. Okay. One thing, one more thing for really quick.
>> Okay. Go ahead. >> Okay, just real quick, guys.
Uh I as soon as I can figure it out, if anyone can find something
where I could do conditionals for for showing kicks on stream,
I want to do conditionals so that if it's like over $3, I play
sound or whatever. But I would like to show the kicks somewhere
on the screen to like not make it totally pointless to buy kicks
at any point, right? Like I do like the $1 $50 thing. I think
it should show up somewhere, but I just can't get it to show
up without it like being kind of Oh, maybe I can. I I think I
got an idea for it. So, they show up in the chat, but they don't
show up anywhere else. I would like to show I I'd like to have
them like little ones show up on screen somewhere like top left
corner, top right corner or something. Anyway, sorry. What were
you going to say? >> Because Marmaduke said that we're
not topped in that a lot of people watch those shows. I am telling
you as soon as my abuela
they the old people they got like Obama phones they've got like
the they get the free iPad
if you're like on disability you get an iPad
okay these are on YouTube now >> yeah I was just going
to say that's where they're popular and also they have to pay
way too much money like like basically these guys can make on
YouTube probably close to the equivalent of what they're making
from their actual contracts with the networks. And the networks
can't make any of that money. Like, they're not making any money
anywhere near the money. >> The networks post their [__]
on YouTube.
>> Well, sorry. They post it on YouTube, but they can't
monetize it like in the same way. Nobody's going to go sign up
for like the >> like the CNN
premium YouTube channel for memberships and stuff. Like, you
can monetize when you're on your own completely. It's just very
funny that like yeah, I just I I think people do watch them on
YouTube, but also the networks like have a hard time competing
with the independent monetary model. I think I think it's just
difficult to do with with like cable TV. So yeah, I think they're
close to dying. They're like newspapers. Newspapers are dead.
Unfortunately, the one thing that I will say is the network gets
hurt for this because you don't have somebody like Jim Jimmy
Kimmel in that position for that long without everyone that he'sworked
with likes him way more than your entire industry. He's a likable
guy. He brings people on a show for laughs and giggles and a
drink. So, a lot of the um the networking in Hollywood probably
don't like that Jimmy Kimmel gets pushed out for something like
this. I think Hollywood leans left, >> Uh yeah, it does.
Yeah. Um
Oh, I I had an extraneous thought while you were talking. I was
just like, I wonder if Jimmy Kimmel still does um I wonder if
he still says sorry to Matt Damon. We ran out of time. Do you
remember that bit from before? >> Yes, I do. Cuz
uh what is it? He dated Sarah Silverman and then Matt Damon,
I >> Yeah, they did the whole I'm thing. Yeah. Yeah. >> I
loved that bit. >> Good stuff. Imagine how good that would
be if they streamed, but they don't >> No, they don't.
>> Yeah. Uh Porter Beller saying like Hollywood leans left,
but Sinclair, the uh the media company or whatever, like the
the conglomerate, is not a leftleaning thing. I think they have
a lot of local news stations in more Republican areas. I think
that's a big thing they do is they do like local media, right?
No. Kyle.
Kyle. He hit her with it again, Cherry. >> He hit her with
it again. >> When is this about K um Nancy saying Ilhan
Omar >> oneway ticket to Somalia with your name on it?
Ilan Omar. Don't you have a pound of beans to be eating? You
wretched.
I'm sorry. I'm just going to repost it. Let's go, Kyle. Let's
go. Every time. It's a lot of beans, you nasty [__]
Or whatever the [__] he tweeted. That's a We all
remember that, right? >> Yeah. Yeah, I remember that. You
nasty ass kids and their dad took me out for barbecue on my birthday
for my birthday. 47 never felt so good. It's a lot of beans.
You nasty ass. >> You just have to feel so bad. She didn't
ask for that serving of beans. >> We'll we'll double down.
We'll repost it again. Okay. >> It's an American place.
They probably just fill up whatever container. Whatever container
they put food in, they just fill it to the top. That's how America
does it. Okay. >> I feel like I've been to this place.
>> It's some barbecue some kind of barbecue joint. Looks
like fast uh not fast food. Uh, fast casual. >> A fast
casual place. >> No, not fast casual. That's a smokehouse.
That's either North Carolina or that's Texas. >> You think
so? No peanuts on the floor. I thought they put peanuts on the
floor. >> Who puts peanuts on the floor? What the [__]
are you saying? >> I thought that was a thing at barbecue
places. You put peanuts on the floor or some [__]
>> What in the hell are you talking about? >> I'm
not American. I'm not American. You guys are slobs. I don't know
anything about you guys. Okay. >> No one puts peanuts on
the floor. That's called not cleaning up. >> Apparently,
that's Texas Roadhouse. They do that. Apparently a bunch of places
do this. Bunch of people listing a bunch of places they do that.
>> What does the peanuts on the floor do for the food?
>> I don't know. I have no idea. Oh, you eat peanuts and
drop the peanut shells on the floor. I see. Apparently
>> Yeah, it is. Apparently Sinclair is going to honor Charlie
Kirk by doing a thing. They're going to do like honoring Charlie
Kirk instead of um running Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy
Kimmel. Sinclair run by right Well, check it out. run by right-wing
media mogul David Smith says suspending the Jimmy Kirk show Jimmy
Kimmel show not Jimmy Kirk Jimmy Kimmel show isn't enough is
going to run a tribute to Kirk during Kimmel's time slot Sinclair
stations will run not consider will not will run not consider
putting Jimmy Kimmel back on the air until he apologizes and
donates to Turning Point USA. Okay, this is now it's getting
even worse, dude. Now it's getting even worse.
>> Suck suck Charlie's Kirker. You can't have a job. Suck
suck his right now. suck his in his coffin right now or you can't
have a job. >> Oh, that keep your money and let them play
Charlie Kirk's 1-hour show or whatever and just sleep easy, >> I
guess. So, it's some goofy from these people. I'm getting pretty
pretty I'm pretty done with these people. Okay, pretty done with
these people. Uh, someone saying this is Brendan Carr from the
FCC as well. Just when while we're back on this Kimmel topic,
apparently this is him back during Biden's. President Biden is
right. Political satire is one of the oldest and most important
forms of free speech. It challenges those in power while using
humor to draw more people into the discussion. That's why people
in influential positions have always targeted for censorship.
This is the guy who said that it was totally unacceptable for
Jimmy Kimmel to say that about uh Charlie Kirk's assassin censoring
lawful speech based on its content. I'm with the First Amendment.
I'm a no. This is the director of the FCC now. Should the government
censor speech it doesn't like? Of course not. The FCC does not
have a roving mandate to police speech in the name of the public
interest. Oh, and he literally said it's in it is literally the
public interest. That That's the reason we need to actually go
and censor stuff from Jimmy Kimmel. It's crazy. We played it
already, Moody Morgan. I could I could play it again, but what
do you think, Jerry? Do we play it again? It was
we should run Dave Blunts back >> right now. You got to
run Dave. >> Yeah, right now. Real quick. Just real >> Oh
boy. Hold on. Hold on. I got to go find it. Give me a second.
>> I'm not
>> Wait, wait, wait. Just in case people weren't here earlier.
Okay. Dave Blunts. Brand new Kanye diss track. All right. Yeah.
I guess there's a couple people here who didn't catch this earlier.
Brand new. Yay. Diss from Dave Blunts. All right. Is fire is
fire. You guys need to see it. >> It is fire. Ignore the
closeup on his
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Never meant to be that type of Never meant to
be that type of Never meant to be that type of dude.
Never meant to be that type of dude.
Never meant to be that type of never meant to be that type of
dude.
Kanye West made me the juice
speaking out. This just my truth.
I'm so sick and tired of being groomed.
I'm so sick and tired of being groomed. He gave me millions of
dollars and made me switch up. It made me think he's a scholar.
He's tried to act like my father. I ain't even trying to ask
the
billionaire but from me he's stand out to switch up and treat
me like I'm nothing the same graduation trying to cousin this
is real
I am not bluffing
told me that you love me was never even my friend
that was
kiss again
>> that's twice by the way >> they don't want to
see me win. Thought this [__] was my twin. You ain't
never have to spin. You ain't never have to draw down on a [__]
just to get the paid. [__] made me right, but I should
have did it. Was a mistake. Cody when I intake. Why the [__]
are my friends fake? Roll on me so heavy. If I bust it down,
it's going to make my wrist break. I'm just trying to be a winner.
No, I don't support Hitler. Hating Jews, that is not me. So I'm
sorry I became a Nazi.
Yeah, I'm sorry I became a I lost myself. That is not me. I can't
let Kanye stop me. I'm not your cousin. You can't stop me. I'm
not your cousin. You can't stop me. I'm not your cousin. You
can't stop me. Yeah, I'm putting this to rest. Hell no. I don't
support. Two cousins should not have two cousins not 69. Kanye
get the off my line. Kanye need to go and find Jesus. Seven years
old used to have brothers breathing. Seven years old you were
sucking on. Seven years old you was swallowing semen. Five so
you can those demons got so you can solve those issues. You got
on your face. You got on your face it
and your cousin wasn't love. How could you do that to your c?
How could you do that to your blood? Never meant to be that type
of dude.
Never meant to be that type of dude.
Never meant to be that type of Never
made me the truth.
I'm speaking out. This is my truth.
I'm so sick and tired of being groomed.
>> Okay. Do you think Red Bared with this or does he turn
on Dave Blunts?
Oh. >> Oh man, you're making fun of a sevenyear-old with
nut on his face. >> I think that makes Red Bar find it
way funnier to be honest with you. I feel like the >> the
jokes about him being seven years old is that's going to make
Red Bar cover it. I think we'll see. We'll see. >> Yay.
Quiet as what is Yay going to do? >> Dude, I we we already
gave our thoughts on this, but just um I'm not your cousin. You
can't top me. I Dude, it's over. You can't respond. It's like
that's that's just a shot. It's over. There's literally nothing
you can do. Oh boy. Okay. Uh
that that is such a good It was such It was so good. The lyrics
were so good in this song. I was shocked. Like it's actually
really good. Not in a joking way. This ninja literally wrote
Cousins, though. He did. And he wrote NH. He said he says in
this song he wrote NH by the way. Nah, the Ninja baby song's
not that >> To put Dude, I forget who I pinned. Yap or
something like that, but yeah. Last year, Kendrick defeated Drake.
This year, Dave Blunts defeats Yay.
This crazy crazy times. >> Crazy times. >> They should
let him perform at the Super >> Dave Blunts comes out as
like a guy with like shoulder pads and a helmet. He could play
center. He could be a long snapper. Okay, Taber.
>> I think >> get this guy ready. Okay. He could
be a long snapper for sure. >> If he does the Super Bowl,
he's going to need so much more than an o oxygen tank. There's
going to have to be like a whole uh like traveling
surgical like room with him just in >> They should just
rig him up with like uh what suspenders and like straps and they
can just move him around. Okay. He'll glide. He'll fly like a
little angel. We'll put some angel wings on him and he'll fly
all across the field. Okay. >> That way in case anything
happens, they can just like instantly just helicopter him right
to the nearest hospital. >> Yeah, sure. Like he's a like
>> Okay. They get those things, you know, the the like
the bars with the the like net in the middle that they get whales
with. They him. Well, let's go. >> Let's go. H. Okay. I
think so. Apparently Dave Blunts is done with Kanye and just
wants to not be accused of anti-semitism. So, that's the start
of that. this clip. Um, the thing Jimmy Kimmel got, just to get
back to this, the thing Jimmy Kimmel was hit for is he basically
said MAGA is trying to paint this as anything but what it is,
that he was like anything but one of their own. So, it's kind
of the implication that this guy was MAGA, the shooter, rather,
the shooter, I should say. Uh, that is apparently, you know,
what got him fired, what got him uh not fired, what got his show
taken off off the air with ABC. So now Anna and Chank arguing
over I guess why this is okay or not. Anna is correct. I I can't
say like I think this is illegal. I'd never say this like a this
isn't really a violation of the First Amendment at all, but it
is I think it's just unprincipled. It's just weird. It's just
like it's because it wasn't that big a deal. People make mistakes
and it's like such a small
small mistake
that um like in the grand scheme of things g like get rid of
him entirely. I don't know. It's just a plate like a mob. Like
there's just a mob going around right now that shouldn't be plated
and people just keep plating it. Very silly. That was basically
what it was. Easy. It's still It's still weird and it's like
it's I I think it's wrong. It's It sounds like the way he phrased
it. It's just like it's like doing an implication in a way you
probably shouldn't, but if he just corrected it, it would have
been totally fine. I I don't think it's anything you should get
fired over. It's literally a quid proquo, but in appeasement
form. Okay. Uh I mean, yeah. Anyway, so we're back to this guy.
I'm going to back it up just a little bit. Anna disagrees with
Chank. Chank says, "This is totally [__] up." And
Anna comes in and goes, "Nah, you don't know what I mean by I
>> hate speech, anything." And Trump even said to a reporter
from ABC, "Oh, you're questioning me. That's hate speech." No,
it's not. No, it's not. That's a reporter doing his job. That's
part of the first amendment freedom of speech and freedom of
the press. And Trump doesn't understand that. And so now t taking
out people who uh make fun of the a politician
to serve that up on a silver planet to Trump. No way. >> I
think I disagree with you. Like the more I sit with what he said
and the more I think about it. Look guys, I mean you have to
consider even if you loathe Charlie Kirk, put your put your shoes
in the shoes of conservatives
who saw one of their, you know, top influencers
Put yourself in the shoes. >> He said you got She said
you got to put your shoes into the shoes. >> I'm sorry.
I'm nitpicking. >> Put your I guess put your feet in the
shoes. But yeah, put your shoes. >> She misspoke, so she
lost. >> Maybe she just wear shoes inside of shoes. I don't
know. Maybe she got really tiny feet. Maybe she got little hooves.
Little hooves down. >> I take it back. I'm not with her
on this
>> Someone who had a tremendous amount of clout on the
right wing. He he gets assassinated.
And so
to make a declarative statement and pin the blame on the very
people who are grieving the loss of Charlie Kirk before you have
any evidence is >> this is this is I I think this is the
wrong way to handle this. As much as I understand like why people
would be upset, why it feels like like blatant misinformation.
If we want to if people wanted to say misinformation on shootings
should be punishable by losing your job. If people want to, I'm
down. Okay, because that's going to end up in a it's going to
end with a lot of Republicans out of their jobs. Okay, that's
just factually correct. You want to you want to institute, but
that's not going to be the rules. It's like it's literally just
oh, it was Charlie. Like that's really it's just the emotional
response to Charlie. So, I don't I I hate that opinion from her.
I don't know. I think if I'm trying I'm trying to remember, Cherry,
that's a little different than your take, right? Where where
she's actually saying it's like kind of morally wrong to say
this. I think you're more just on the like it's the company's
>> I just think that the company if the company thinks
that this is going to be bad for business they have the right
to cut him. >> Yeah. I mean I would agree with that too.
I don't agree with what she's saying. But you just you you did
say you were going to be on her side but I think probably not.
I think you're on your own >> because I thought that she
was going to just Yeah. I thought she was going to be spitting
what I thought she just wasn't.
a declarative statement and pin the blame on the very people
who are grieving the loss of Charlie Kirk before you have any
evidence is yeah it's offensive it's irresponsible
I get that he's a comic so I guess we should hold him to a lower
standard I guess but my problem with it is it keeps feeding into
you know that divide and and it's all about like oh no it's your
fault it's the left's fault it's the right's fault it's just
like endless race to the bottom over which party sucks more.
And I look, I saw this happen with cable news, too, where before
we had any information about the suspect, before a suspect was
even apprehended.
Every debate, every conversation
was about left-wing ideology. Now, keep in mind, you know, it
does appear that Tyler Robinson's motive was he didn't like what
Charlie Kirk had to say about transgender people and he felt
that Charlie Kirk was
have yet to see that affirmed. That's she's doing a little misinformation.
I think he said he said Charlie was hateful. I don't know if
there's a solid line or any reason to think that it's more about
um trans people than it was about Charlie's thoughts on gay people
or gay people's right to get married or a bunch of like a bunch
of other things. I do think the person was like left-leaning
like pretty obviously left-leaning but I have not seen because
I've been following it quite closely. I don't think we've seen
the the transpecific
motivation here. As much as that's been a storyline the whole
way through, I and yes, he did have a trans partner,
but I don't know if that's like what actually motivated him here
or not. So, we'd probably just have to see >> spreading
hate, but this is before we even had those details about Tyler
Robinson.
And so, it's just, can we wait? And more importantly, why is
it more important to pin the blame on your political opponents
as opposed to taking note of where we are as a country right
now and how dangerous this situation really is as we move forward?
>> You know, like I guess my point is rather than >> rather
than quelling
violence, tension, the the constant blame game, he kind of fed
into it before we had the details about what Tyler Robinson actually
believes. So Anna, look, the part I agree with you on is, yeah,
can we cool it? So to your point, I saw a poll today that uh
more people believed that Tyler Robinson was on the right than
the left. So until recently, obviously now it's all over the
news, right? And that's just totally wrong, right? And why did
they believe that? Because so many people immediately and yes,
obviously on on the left jumped out and said, "Oh, he was probably
MAGA. He was a groper. He was this." Now, we speculated. We speculated
on the show. We gave you a range of options, right? I said, "These
people are saying this, this, and this, but we don't know yet."
Right? That's what I think is the right thing to do. So other
people jumped in and said, "Oh, we're sure he's on the right."
Okay. So that's a problem. But Jimmy Kimmel said it as a quarter
of a freaking joke. So now I think, you know, to your point about
shoe on the other foot, right? Okay. If Greg got >> That's
not Wait, I don't think it's shoe on the other foot. I putting
yourself in their shoes is feeling empathy for their >> You're
just doing about shoes. guys don't know much about shoes, but
they're >> Felt had made the similar joke when I said that's
it, Greg Gutfeld. I can't believe you made a joke. An inappropriate
joke was a course incorrect statement. That's it. Get Greg Gutfeld
Gutfeld off the air. A I wouldn't say it. B, no one would say
it. C, there's absolutely no chance in the world that would happen.
So now we're going to take off everyone on on the left, the center,
anyone who isn't right-wing. But the rightwing gets different
rules. So Gutfeld can say whatever he wants. Everybody can say
whatever they want on the right and there was massive spect and
Anna let's be honest were there right-wing hosts were there right-wing
media who are all saying from second one leftist now they didn't
know either now it turned out it was a leftist and I don't and
what my point is I'm not >> we don't know if he's a leftist
we know
>> my hold on let me finish the point real quick I'm not
blaming the right wing for
you know is a transm motivation either don't know either of these
things. Anna, come on, man.
>> I I don't know why it seems like quite hard for people
to like grasp some of this stuff sometimes.
I think right. I don't know if it's just like misspeaking. It
feels like it's there are just natural patterns your brain falls
into where like you'll go like, "Yeah, he was probably shooting
Charlie cuz he's a leftist shooting Charlie cuz Charlie's hateful,
right? What's her implication? Proch. Protrans?" No, no, no.
Protrans with like some lefty thoughts. Just not necessarily
leftist. Leftist to some people will mean like socialist like
socialist aligned Marxist Marxist Linist that that area of belief
more than just liberalism. Leftist would be like something beyond
further left in the political spectrum than liberalism. >> Dude,
I just I cannot understand having this much heat for a comedian.
First of all, the joke wasn't funny. Second of all, it didn't
it's not like he was joking about somebody dying.
Like the thing that is offensive to people is the idea that he
said he's one of your guys. That could be misinformation. It
one of his writers could have just been >> That's what
I think it is. I think one of his writers were just watching
like one of these commentators who said that that was the case
>> and they put it in there cuz they thought it was funny
and they just were misinformed. And when Kathy Griffin got she
got basically boycotted because she held up that uh bloody mask
of Trump, people understood, okay, that joke was too far. That's
like insane. That's like the sitting president, right? Her own
comedians had to be like, uh, I like free speech, but I don't
want to cross this line,
right? She got blacklisted from a lot. And people are reacting
to Jimmy Kimmel's monologue as if as if it's that controversial
like what Kathy Griffin did. >> So it's probably it feels
more controversial. It's not. It's obviously not, but to people
it feels more controversial cuz she was like faking get somebody
dying and this was like somebody did actually die and then they're
sort of not accurately reporting on that. And I wouldn't even
say it was a joke like you said like it wasn't really a joke.
It was him making a statement. He was not making a a joke there.
He's making a statement of fact. They're trying to paint this
as anything. He paint this guy as anything but one of their own.
That's not a joke. It's like a statement of fact in my
>> So, but yeah, he violated ABC's to it is what it is.
Stop acting like anyone cares. I mean, I guess that's a little
bit true. I is but that's that's just right. That's like um what
do you call it? It's it's [__] to me that you just
make a mob and like force all these companies to capitulate.
makes me actually appreciate unironically makes me appreciate
Twitch a little bit more. I'm not even joking that Twitch could
say like, "No, we think this is like a principled uh like a principled
stance on how we should hold people accountable for their statements."
No, I think we're we're going to let this Dude, they've got they
got way more pressure on them than Sinclair has on them, right?
Kush has been under like a pretty intense campaign against them
for months now and they're just like, "Nah, we're good. No, we're
good. No, we're good. I think it's pretty funny. Yeah, very interesting.
I mean, continue >> that he was that the shooter was on
the left because I get it. Charlie Kirk was on the right. So,
it's normal to think that the shooter was on the left as someone
who opposes him so much they'd want to shoot him, right? But
are we going to But they didn't know either. So, are we suspending
all of them? Are we firing all of them? No. It's a double standard.
And who is the double standard applied to? The enemies of the
president. Let's be honest. >> Yeah. And by the way, I
don't believe for a second that NextStar's motivating factor
here was that they were agrieved by what Kibble had to say. I
actually think the fact that the FCC needs to approve the merger
that they so desperately want. >> Uh tournates tourniquets
so brutally right now. Do these even mention that element of
this? And you're completely ripped. An anakus bar just raped
you. I'm sorry. It's over for you. Tourniquette
handed your badge. You just got destroyed. is the bigger factor
here. And I find that particularly gross. But, you know, I guess
my point is the left has always seen itself as people who operate
at a higher standard than the right. You know, they don't they
don't roll around in the mud the way the right-wingers do. You
know, they don't jump the gun when it comes to these shootings
and pin the blame unfairly on the other side. But I guess what
I've seen with, you know, at a higher standard than the right
is the left has always seen itself as people who operate at a
higher standard than the right. >> You know, they don't
they don't roll around in the mud the way the right-wingers do.
You know, they don't jump the gun when it comes to these shootings
and pin the blame unfairly on the other side. That's not that's
not operating. I don't know that like not lying as much as the
right is not the same as operating in a in a more like noble
way. >> But I guess what I've seen with you know partisans
like hyperartisans on the left who are like just constantly enraged
by Donald Trump. The entire entirety of their politics seems
to be, you know, guided by that hatred for Donald Trump. And
I get it. I get it. But sometimes it clouds your mind and it
leads to you making decisions under not the best judgment. So
I think it was wrong for him to pin the blame uh
on the right. Uh again, I'm just going to repeat that. But I
also think that what the Trump administration is doing in regard
to retaliating against any reporting or press that he doesn't
like is also a serious issue. I just don't know if the Jimmy
Kimmel example is the best example. I mean, he's catching feelings
over a comic, man. If Joe Biden did this and say, "I demand every
comic who criticizes me be taken off the air, otherwise I won't
approve mergers." People would have said, "What a tyrant. What
a what a ridiculous
>> What I don't understand is was this car guy. So, before
he was When did he get named? Hold on. Is it Brandon Carr? Brandon
Carr? No. No. No. That's cornerback for the Dallas former quarterback
of the Dallas Cowboys. Okay. No. What's his [__]
name? What was his name? Carr. Car car. FCC. Derek. No. What?
Brendan Carr. Brendan Carr. When was he appointed? So, he's appointed
this year. Okay. Okay. Before that, he was I pulled up his Wikipedia
here. I was just trying to see mission of the federal federal
communications. Oh, no. 2017. Appointed by He's appointed by
Joe Biden, right? Oh, no. He's appointed by Trump in the first
term. God, my timeline is just broken in my brain. Whoops. Trump
first term appointee, but Biden didn't get rid of him. So, he's
been there the whole time. I wonder what caused him to flip so
hard on this that he's like going the opposite direction and
where people feel like he would actually like poo poo this merger
over somebody saying something about Trump. So, Carr threatened
to use the power of the FCC against Disney unless the company
unless the company actions to punish Jimmy Kimmel for criticisms
of how the manga movement had responded to the Charlie Kirk.
This isn't even Carr said, "We can do this the easy way or the
hard way. these companies can find a way to change the conduct
and take actions on Kimmel or there's going to be an additional
work for the FCC ahead. Carr also encouraged local affiliates
to stop running Jimmy Kimmel Live. Shortly thereafter, NextStar,
one of the largest operators of TV stations in the US, announced
it would no longer run Jimmy Kim alive. Carr praised Nextstar
for its action. The company has a $6.2 million merger with Tegna
that will require approval from the FCC. Shortly thereafter,
Jimmy took, sorry, Disney took Jimmy Kimmel alive off the air.
H this would be insane. Uh this god damn
dude it's >> what why are you signing like something new
happened? >> Uh so tourniquet says read the paragraph above
about the peace sky merger. They literally approved it because
they agreed not to do DAI
Paramount Sky Dance Corporation. So the Federal Communications
Commission returned to a quorum with trustes confirmation
giving Republicans a majority. car moved to end net neutrality,
though a federal applet court had already struck down net neutrality
regulations and refused to enforce a rule that would have lowered
prison phone call prices. The commission approved Paramount Global's
merger with Skyance Media in July, achieving a commitment from
Skyance that the resulting company Paramount Skyance Corporation
would not have diversity, equity, inclusion policies. The commitment
included installing an ombbudzman an ombbudzman
budsman.
How do you say this word? Can you not? No. Pronunciation
>> Ombbudsman.
Okay. To ensure a diversity of viewpoint. So basically they said
you guys can't merge. Part of the agreement for merging is you
have to agree no DEI.
Why would they be a part of a merger agreement? Just agree no
DEI and then I'll let you do the thing that you're allowed to
do anyway. What the [__] Hey, just agree with our
with with agree. Am I reading this correctly? agree with the
thoughts and feelings on policy of the administration, the president
himself, or we're going to cancel. We're going to strike down
your merger. That seems insane. Very, very odd. Not good.
Dang. Trump was too late to save Star
and the Lord of the Rings from Amazon. Why couldn't he have Why
couldn't he have just been a little better? uh viz because the
whole point of the FCC, the whole point of the government is
to call balls and strikes to say whether something whether or
not something uh creates a monopoly, whether or not creates unfair
conditions for consumers for the average American. That's their
job. It's not to say, "Hey, I want to police your business practices.
Hey, I want to police your well, sorry, some business practices."
It's not to say, "Hey, I want to control how you make content.
I want to control you hire people." That's not really a part
of it. If that if they're doing that's illegal that you can actually
control as the government, then charge them for those crimes,
like actually like attack them for those crimes. And if not,
stop trying to control how they run their business. That was
under the pretext that it was/ wasn't an antitrust issue. So
if Paramount Sky Dance was deemed not a monopoly, then how the
is the merged entity Paramount Skyance about to bid on Warner
Brothers media? How is that not I don't know, man. I don't know,
man. I would imagine that probably we're not going to see anything
that there's probably going to be zero antitrust action the entire
Trump presidency, right? If companies want to create monopolies,
this is the time, I would imagine. Anyway, oh, I know as soon
as I look at any of the money stuff around the Trump administration,
I'm going to blow my brains out. So, I have not really done it.
I haven't looked into any of their crypto [__] either.
I know that's all going to be just a total
show. I think Trump basically pardoned somebody very recently,
didn't he? like like today or or the day before I was seeing
news about this. Some guy got let out who donated to him who
was like accused of a bunch of crimes and then was it the FC
dropped their investigation into him or the the FTC? I can't
remember. But there's like more there's so much corruption [__]
right now. Trevor Milton is who I'm talking about. Yeah. SEC.
SEC. Yes. It's like dude what? Founder of NKA the biggest meme
scam. >> People would have said what a >> I can't
I can't learn anymore right now. I'm too >> I'm too My
brain's too broken right now. I can't. His lawyer was Pam Bondi's
brother, right? Yes. And Trump took campaign contributions from
him. >> Criticizes me being taken off the air, otherwise
I won't approve mergers. People would have said, "What a tyrant.
What a what a ridiculous
thin skininned loser, right? Trump does it." And we're like,
"Oh, well, I mean, he did get a quarter of a joke wrong."
No, we would never apply that standard of gutfeld. And and so
I No. And Anna, to your point, I get it. I get it.
Can you find someone in in media that has a deeper loathing of
the mainstream media than I do? And so their whole fake pretenses
of like, oh, we are the truth. We are reality. Meanwhile, they're
framing everything for status quo is great, politicians are great,
corporations are great, etc. We've broken that down thousands
of times on the Young Turks. But we have to have the same principles
that apply to everyone. So that goes to your point. they should
be more careful, especially if they're going to talk down their
nose at people. I totally agree with that. Right. But at the
same time, taking them off the air for this type of microscopic
infraction
I realize I don't have room to joke on this. Okay. But that was
a rough one from Shank >> for this type of
micros. >> It's a scopic infraction.
And we know why they're doing it. to plate an outofc control
president who hates freedom of speech. So, no, I I hate this
decision. I think it's totally wrong. I I've got to read one
comment here because they >> So, I guess this is another
big problem is is it even it's not not like the market forces.
It's not like the customers that are upsetting people. It's people
going, I'm actually really scared that we're going to get attacked
by like the government itself. Like, I think the government's
actually going to [__] with us, so we're going to
fire this guy. That's like a different level of kind of like
when it's not even the capitalist system. It's like literally
like the state trying to crack down on cap on free market capitalism
in a way that's like totally incompatible with the entirety of
the administration or the the White House's history. >> Such
a good point that I forgot to make in the last story. Uh one
of our members on t.com next TYT reporter wrote in, "I don't
care about the opinions of the company. Once the FCC gets involved,
it's the government. The government policing speech is a violation
of the First Amendment. Thank you for being part of the show.
I love that we do the show with the members. I should have made
that point earlier. That is the >> Okay. All right. Um,
little bit of a disagreement here, I guess, on on all of this.
Uh, I didn't really like Anna's position to be honest, but I
don't know. It's fine. >> Yeah, me neither. Can you explain
this Hassan tweet? Do you guys know something I don't know about
Benny Johnson? >> My husband, Benny Johnson, made this
happen around and find out. ABC pulls Jimmy Kimmel alive indefinitely
after NextStar Backlash to host Charlie Kirk comments. Are you
going to let him go on work trips alone with men as a treat now?
Oh, I don't know. Did she make Maybe she made some comment. >> What
does does Benny Is Benny Johnson not allowed to go on trips alone
with men? Is he This is like making a closeted joke, right?
>> Benny's wife to Benny after the work >> said someone
left an eye. >> Sorry. I I think this is I don't know.
Just to be clear, I don't know. Sorry, I was playing this as
an answer. I actually curled
said someone left an eyelash curler in your room. >> Yes,
it was mine. >> Cuz I figured you hooked up with some girl
and she left it there. >> Yes, that would have made more
sense. >> You know, I I don't even feel like I know you
anymore, man. All right. Look, I was going to ask you this one
time. All right. And whatever you say, I'll believe you. Were
you or were you not on a gay cruise? Stay at >> Okay. Yeah,
it is. It is about him being gay. Quited gay. Okay. >> You're
next. So, we're sending you to
>> Okay, full disclosure. I think I've told people this.
I walked into work at the day after Trump was elected knowing
that every single person in my entire office of like a couple
hundred people hated this guy. And I threw this up on a big monitor
in my office that had like glass walls. Not my office, my my
team's like room actually. It was like eight people in there
or something, but glass walls. I threw this up on the biggest
TV we had in the room and I just hit play on this and then I
started coding in the morning just to I'm >> You sound
like an >> That's I didn't have to say it. That's who I
am. >> It's just this video and song playing on
>> Oh my god, that's Trump. I thought it was an Asian man.
>> Nope, that's Trump.
to be clear, I just thought he was a funny and borderline racist
guy. I didn't realize he was going to be like the end of democracy
and the world economy. Okay, at the time I was like, "Oh, this
is kind of amusing. This was kind of amusing in 2016. If I would
have if I could have seen the future
if I could have seen the future, I' been like, "This is really
uh >> you you were one of those people who was bored and
you're like, "Yeah, this seems interesting. Let's move around
and find >> Okay. I also Yeah, a little bit. I also showed
up in a manga hat and a Trump like tie-dye shirt that was like
full like screen printed a big picture of him." Yeah. >> Where
is the manga hat? >> Uh thrown out. >> I haven't
Oh, okay. I haven't seen a manga hat. I would have been throwing
it >> I had I had two MAGA hats. I had the red MAGA hat,
the classic MAGA hat, and I had a camo MAGA hat with orange making
America great on it again, >> bro. You guys, I feel like
you didn't throw it out. I think >> Make America Great
again on it. No, my parents threw it out in one of my moves.
They're helping me move and they chopped it up, man.
it up. Yeah. Unfortunately, um, by this election, I just I hated
this guy. So, unfortunately fortunately, yeah, buy an AF hat
instead. Let's go.
>> time for a closet. >> Hey, what? >> It's
It's very cute that any of you think that I have not combed top
to bottom of this entire place >> with a black light.
That's Trust me, guys. Just come on every surface and then black
lights don't pick up anything, okay? It's all just one uniform,
one uniform. Just come on every surface, okay? And then you're
>> That's not true. But also, now I feel like I should
buy a black light just to see what comes up. Don't do it. Um,
my parents, my my my
mom and dad are split and my mom is a hates Trump. My dad likes
Trump. So, I could probably tell a stories where it sounds like
my parents hate Trump or like Trump. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Anyway,
yeah, I threw this up on the big monitor, laughed at it, played
it. Um,
what are we looking at now? Oh, I have a couple different things
I was going to stop at. Apparently, uh, apparently Willie Mack
was just tweeting about some DJer that got fired. Apparently
a apparently a DJer
decided to go on Tik Tok and make a joke about Charlie Kirk.
Okay, now so this guy posts it right. Ashley Furniture, global
furniture store based out of Wisconsin, fired me after finding
my TikTok making a joke about the Charlie Kirk assassination.
I was in IT and the head of it is the founder's grandson, Cameron
Winnick, giant Nepo baby termally online. I'm not sure who asked
to fire me, but HR said it came up from way up top. I decided
to email Cameron and see if this is this hashtag I am Charlie
nonsense has any weight to it. I doubt it will get a response,
but I think my argument is quite sound. What do you think? First
of all, >> this is so cringe. >> Is this guy not
going to post? Do we have the Tik Tok yet, guys? Do we have the
Do we have the Tik Tok? I need the Tik Tok cuz I need to know
what the joke was. I can tell I can tell you if this is cringe,
right? >> Which DG or is this? >> I have no idea.
onseen Douggee. I don't even know if it's necessarily a DJer.
It's like it appears to be a DJ from the post. A lot of the posts
are in this uh in Destiny, but he has a Vosv post four years
ago. Oh, wait. Hold on. Poor Amazon workers. You think this from
his Tik Tok? Oh, it just says Tik Tok.com.
>> Popped up with Rei first. Weird. >> It's Re. >> I
think Rey's the only person I follow on Tik Tok, so it's probably
what it is. Uh, hold on. I actually need to go back and get my
my my subreddit back. Okay, here we go. R/ Wisconsin r/destiny.
And I wonder if anywhere if he put his his actual Tik Tok anywhere.
Haven't seen it. Haven't seen it. Can't see it. Okay. Well, I'm
going to I'm going to wait and >> Izzy, I don't think it's
This wouldn't be Des Scrub King. He would just post it on his
Twitter account >> instead of the subreddit. >> Email
Cameron. No, his name isn't Cameron. I decided to email Cameron
and see if this Cameron uh >> Cameron Wedick is like the
person who's the the founder's grandson or something.
>> So, dear, so my thoughts. Dear Cameron, you're an intelligent
man, correct? I would like to think the VP of technology at the
second biggest second. Wait, this is Does he understand how that
this sounds snarky, right? Not snarky in like the snarking way.
Snarky in like the kind of stuckup prick way. At the second biggest,
it doesn't sound like you're emphasizing that as a good thing.
I don't know. It gets so much worse, does it? biggest furniture
selling company in the world would be an extraordinarily intelligent
man. Well, if the answer is yes, I would like to make a case
to you. This is not a plea for my job back. I just want you to
seriously think about the precedent you're setting. That being
said, this email will have very fun language because I don't
care about being professional. Oh god,
no.
No,
dude. This guy This guy's going to get this like attached to
his resume somehow and he's like going to be unhirable.
Why would this guy do this? Why would this guy make this so much
worse? This is like actually, by the way, I probably, even if
the joke was insane, I'd probably agree as long as he didn't
have it like tied to his own account in a crazy way. Sorry, his
job in a crazy way. I would probably agree he shouldn't get banned
or not banned. I'm totally terminally online. He should have
been fired probably. But like, what is this cringe email after
conserv conservative broke into dude? Conservatives made fun
of Paul Pelosi. Do you know conservatives made fun of Paul Pelosi?
Did you know that conservatives I think you should I think you
shouldn't fire me. I think you should consider the president
you're setting. Conservatives like you're like you made fun of
Paul Pelosi.
Uh-huh.
I I wonder if it would help these people if you just told them
like probably principally you're correct and you shouldn't be
fired for this and conservatives are hypocritical.
I don't know. People have this really difficult time understanding
that the world is not what is fair. The world is not a fair place.
It's not going to give you what's fair. Even if you have a even
if you're totally correct, you could still get fired from your
job. You could be 100% correct and 100% fired at the same time.
Those those are both overlapping real conditions in the real
world. Right? This is like the number one problem for people
who are like in this space. I find like I I I see so many people
who are like this. They think that being right means you can't
just be like that you can be as big an [__] as of
an [__] as you want to be, right? It's just not how
the real world works. You can do it online. It can be funny,
but if you take that energy into the real world, you're just
going to have nothing but problems everywhere you go. It's uh
sad. Anyway, the conservative broke into Nancy Pelosy's home
with the intention of kidnapping her and torturing her. Donald
Trump spoke at a campaign rally and openly mocked his attack
for laughs. Uh the so this guy didn't include the Paul Pelosi
bit. He continued to repeat this joke until he was addressing
the police union right after the right before the election. Now
all the information on this attack is readily available online.
The trial is over and most of it is public. There's even a wiki
article summarizing the entire thing with links to sources. I'm
sure you understand how Wikipedia works. I will link it as well.
I'm sure you as an intelligent man understand how Wikipedia works.
Furthermore, Trump has clearly indicated that he is okay with
political violence when it is on his side. The best example of
this being the pardoning of the January 6th perpetrators, even
the most violent of them, which, let's remember, intended to
intimidate, harm, or even murder Mike Pence. They were responsible
for the most violence violence political act I've seen in my
lifetime. Police officers were traumatized and some even killed.
I would also go so far as to say Trump is directly responsible
for Ashley Babbot's death as well, dude.
Uh, so now that I've laid out that that Trump not only makes
jokes about political violence, but he also but he also
just full-on supports and encourages it, I think it's fair to
make my final point. It is absolutely absurd
that you would hold one of your lowest level employees that is
barely making it paycheck to paycheck to a higher public standard
than the president you and your family supported, donated to,
and chose to elect. No, you can't hold Donald Trump to that standard.
Uh oh boy. Okay. Uh I Dude, this is the most delusional
person. I Oh man, Cherry, you made a point about this like um
how like the laring laring's kind of got to stop that like people
think that this is like a moral thing. It's like bro this the
you're posting the Desty subre. He doesn't care. He's here for
like attention and money. He doesn't care. You are somebody who's
like principally committed to this in a way that he never has
been. Like this is really bad. You look like a total [__]
when you post this and you're like, "Yeah, here I I'm I'm living
paycheck to paycheck. I'm barely making my money and I posted
a Tik Tok that like got me fired or something. It just seems
>> I think and and to just for complete honesty, okay,
I've even heard Destiny tell people, listen, don't don't like
do anything weird. Don't like lose your jobs or anything, but
I would love to like figure out blah blah blah blah. Like he
tells people don't put your jobs at risk, right? But still, stupid
people do this. The LAR is just crazy that he's like he's he's
trying to like debate this. It's Yeah. >> Or it even outside
of DG like you saw those videos of people recording their boss
firing them and then posting that like that makes them look good.
>> I did not see that, but that sounds uh pretty good.
>> This happened a couple years ago. Or was this happening
around CO? Shortly after CO when people started getting let go.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. would recorded their
>> They were like debating their boss.
>> Like I had a really great performance review. Could
you please tell me why based on my performance review I'm being
let go? It's like >> I'm not here to talk about that. >> Yeah.
As if letting someone go is like isn't hard or complicated enough
and you know it's delegated to them that they have to
>> you you just know that and jeez it's like it's I don't
know those people. Those videos are so cringe. That's going to
live with them forever. >> Some very weird [__]
Yeah, but that's Yeah, that is what this is like. This is the
same thing. Uh, wait. Maximus said he couldn't find anything
on Tik Tok. Wait, are you just looking for the same name or something?
Who's Maximus looking for? I want to see the Tik Tok really badly.
But I'm guessing that if you find the Tik Tok that it didn't
take very long for somebody to tie it to his real person. So,
I'm guessing whatever the Tik Tok was, whatever the joke was,
like he's not going to share it because it would tie back to
him and his job pretty easily or pretty quickly, right? >> Yeah.
And Kendrick, why didn't he post the anonymous Tik Tok? I just
like the the person who posted her debating the person firing
her, they actually believe they look good. Unironically, they
believe that they are taking on like the capitalist pigs, the
the cruel upper management, yada yada yada. They're like going
against the system. >> They are going against the system,
but it turns out the system um the system they're going against
is just normally socialized like an acceptable behaviors of all
the humans around them. Wrong system. They thought they were
going up like against a unfair tyrannical fascist system, but
they're actually just going against like the normal human beings
who are like, "Yeah, it's kind of weird to make that joke." >> Yeah.
Also, Kendrick, we're saying two different things. Recording
versus posting it publicly to say like, "Look how gross this
is. Those are two completely different things. >> Raven
Ray, >> also can you um >> can you bring up my tweet
just so people can get behind me and help get support get Asmin
Gold's eyes on this latest person mocking Charlie Kirk? >> Uh
hold on, hold on. Where is this? Where is this? Uh Queen, thank
you. Thank you for the raid. Let me check this out.
Okay, hold on. Hey, Asmin Gold. This person is mocking Charlie,
too. Uh I'll like that. I'll retweet that. If you're a Charlie
jerk about Charlie Kirk getting Charlie Mert, they'll take away
your Charlie work. Wow. >> Classic classic Stardust bit
over here. >> You would think that she's in the writer
room for some of these late night talk show hosts. >> She
is that kind of funny. She's like the exact kind of funny writes
some of >> bad humor.
>> Yeah, it works. It works. It definitely works. All right.
Um where were we? We're in the middle of this uh this Reddit
post here. Okay. I'm I'm going to start again from the start
of this paragraph. So we can really lean into this. Okay.
>> Is absolutely Hold on. Actually, one second. Me move
this. I just have that tweet over here. Okay. I'm gonna put it
in the kick chat. Here we go. Here we go.
You have the joke. Uh, I don't even know what you're talking
about right now, Ry. So, GG. Oh, yeah. The joke's in here. Yeah.
Yeah. No, it's in the It's in the text of this. That's why I
was about to read it. It is absolutely absurd that you would
hold one of your lowest level employees that is barely making
it paycheck to paycheck to a higher public standard than the
president you and your family supported, donated to, and chose
to elect. What farcical nonsense is this? I made a video off
the clock on my own time that didn't even advocate for violence.
I was making a joke about how much better of a shooter this guy
was than the last guy, who was conservative, by the way. I am
no stranger to debate. If my words about Charlie Kirk hurt so
much that you had to fire me, therefore holding me to a higher
standard than your president.
I misspelled higher. Higher standard than your president. Then
may I ask for some severance in a form of dialogue. In the form
of dialogue. Oh god, this guy needs to go. They need to keep
this guy. Put this guy in an institution. Okay. Then may I ask
for severance, sir, in the form of dialogue.
Can we meet in the the marketplace of ideas as Charlie would
have wanted?
Oh god, no. He said he he says it unironically. Talk to me on
a stream or in a public Discord about this situation. Follow
in Charlie's footsteps and find me in the marketplace of ideas.
Ain't no way. Hey, I just tried to be as cringe as I could. Dude,
talk to me on a stream or in a public Discord.
Dude, this is okay. New plan. He's doing this to show that he
should be a ward of the state. Okay, clearly this guy needs a
caretaker. He needs some government welfare. This guy should
not be allowed to work anywhere. Okay, this guy shouldn't even
be allowed around power tools. This is a dangerous human being.
>> Holy sh market. Follow me. Follow in Charlie's footsteps
and find me in the marketplace of ideas and explain to me how
it makes sense to elect a demon who encourages political violence,
but you fire a man making $20 an hour for a joke. Oh god. He
was working it. He was making $20 an hour. Uh, sir, sir, will
you engage me in the marketplace of ideas? Sorry. I Well, it's
I I'm disappointed myself. I didn't have to go there. I didn't
have to go there. >> I didn't have to go there. Here. Here's
the uh >> I don't know why you're saying that. You're not
better. That is exactly who you are is going there. >> That's
true. What's the joke? Verbatim. Where was this guy last summer?
Huh? We got Captain Earhole in our greatest time of need. But
this can break necks from 200 yards away. Okay, sure. Yeah, I
don't think that's anywhere near offensive enough to get fired.
I think it's pretty gay to track him down over this. It's like
It's not that bad. It's not that bad. It's not like a great It's
actually not even that bad a joke for like a random Tik Tok.
Like, dude, really? I I kind of get it, but eh, dude. Okay, hold
on. No, no, no, no. This is an incredible joke. This is an incredible
joke given what that guy wrote for his email to his boss that
fired him. Okay, this is like the greatest the greatest feat
of wit this man has ever accomplished in his entire life. You
have to respect that. Okay, this is this guy's magnumopus right
here. He's never going to be wittier than this. This is the best
he's ever done. Oh, we found the we might have found the video
on Tik Tok. Hold on. What is this?
>> where the was this guy last summer, huh? We got Captain
Earhole in our greatest time of need and this is over here breaking
necks from 200 yards away. What the? Couldn't have picked a better
target. Charlie Kirk. Really? Okay. Rest in peace, I guess. That's
a little worse. Hold on.
>> No. He got the same eyes as the shooter. What the What
are the odds? >> That is a DGR. Oh boy. What do you mean
the same eyes as the shooter? Wait, hold on. What is this? What
is this? Tyler Robinson. I don't think this guy should have been
fired. Okay. I just don't I don't think so. >> They might
not look the same, but they're looking in the same directions.
>> Nah. Oh, like they both got the lazy eyes. I got it.
I got it. >> Where the was this guy last summer, huh? We
got Captain Earhole. >> Oh, this is like this is like white
terminally online Britney Venty, isn't it? It is like there's
a little Britney Venty going on here. Okay. >> I think
the glasses are helping with that. I think the glasses are helping
with that. What? >> In our greatest time of need and this
over here breaking necks from 200 yards away. What the couldn't
have picked a better target. Charlie Kirk. Really? Okay. Rest
in. I guess I'm just not going to show much more of that cuz
it I I do believe that could have his name there. Oh, there's
a there's a Twitch stream. Do you guys think uh do you guys think
that guy's got he's got dirt bagg leftist in his uh in his profile?
Do we do we wonder if he's got anything? Or Hold on. Hold on.
U
I'm I'm just going to look and see if he's got any viewers on
his uh on his Twitch channel. Okay. >> Give me a second.
Give me a second. >> Looking at Sully Gnome here. Has he
ever streamed on Twitch? Not in last year. He did some streams
on Twitch. Never broke seven viewers. Um >> sharing it
with
>> No, I'm not. Okay. I don't know. I don't know if that's
what we should be doing. Okay. He streamed a decent amount back
>> Did some streams around February 2020 2021. Yeah, he
streamed from 2020 to 2021. He streamed a decent amount. Usually
at, you know, one to two average viewers, not to a lot of people,
okay? Never to a lot of people. And we don't even know that that's
definitely him, but it's definitely him, I think. Yo, what? I
just Yeah. I don't know. Let's see. Let's see how some people
respond here cuz I I feel like a lot of people should point out
how insanely cringe this is, right? How insanely cringe the post
is. A lot of people should be able to identify that, I think.
Check it out. Uh, not this pointless, to be honest. I just move
on. Probably don't use them for reference. That's kind of doing
it like not giving the guy any any positive affirmation. Uh let's
see here. Higher standard. You mistyped, so therefore you lost
the debate by default. Joke. Asking VP of the company you formerly
worked at to a debate. This should be mocking, right? What is
it? Oh, it's a gigachad. Uh I think you made a dumb decision
to post an edgy joke on an account that easily ties to your personal
life. It's a well-written response. No, it's not. It's a horribly
written response, but that person isn't going to read it or give
a [__] about your position. Good luck. Uh, as a horribly
written response. How in the world could somebody How in the
world could somebody possibly think that's a well-written response?
That's crazy. You shouldn't have fire uh gotten fired for a joke.
With that being said, your email response makes me think that
you were probably fired for more than just a joke. That's the
That's the response. That's the real response. Okay. Yes. Like
listen, your email response tells me so much about you that they
were probably looking to get rid of you as soon as possible.
Like you are the problem. You might that's one of those people
where like your email response tells me that you might be fantastic
at your job and they were looking to fire you anyway. Like that
is that's just facts. You could be great at that job and they
could be like, "Yeah, this guy, right? Everybody has that guy
who doesn't make that much money, who's great at the job, way
better than a ton of people in the same job, right? But he doesn't
make that much money because realistically they're just hoping
he'll quit. They don't have cause to fire him. But he's just
a massive. He's constantly like kind of putting people off, right?
It's
We all recognize it. We all see it. We've all seen it. It kind
of seems like he was already in hot water and went down swinging
on his own terms. No, he what? In what world? I don't think that's
a fair assumption to make. Yes, it is. No, I never interacted
with this man personally. My boss, my actual boss loves me and
had no idea I was getting fired until we have both were both
called into HR together. I'm strictly mad at this man and his
his and his family's hypocrisy, such as being anti-communism/
leftism and having giant sections of their business in Vietnam
and China. Got to love that offshoring. Okay. In an atill state,
I think it's Wisconsin was where he posted it. He posted in his
thing that he's in Wisconsin. Hold on a second. Is
that Oh,
I was like trying to hide all of his um his not his like all
public all public. I didn't even see it, but I don't think he's
like a DJ as much. I don't know. Maybe he is a DJ now or something,
but he's he's uh seems to be pretty lefty from what I've seen.
Hey dude, sorry this happened to you. Yeah, that sucks now, but
I really advise taking this down. No company wants a hot head
that's going to blast executives. And yeah, you might not care
now, but you will when you need that paycheck. It's tough for
Hey, another good post. Dude, not a lot of people with jobs left
around here to make these posts. It seems like Wisconsin is where
the Ashley's home office is. Okay. All right. Do we pull the
Willie Mac tweet? I think Will I think Willie was posting about
this? I can't tell how he was posting about it. Like, I don't
think somebody should be fired for that. I could find the I find
the email amusing, but let's check this out. Destiny Beer gets
fired from his job for making a Charlie Kirk assassination joke
on TikTok. He's now trying to challenge his boss to a debate
on stream. Lol. This has me crying, man. Yeah, it's pretty.
Cameron Wayne, please inform me if this is true. Willie so mad
at Destiny. Damn. When the breakup is really bad. Like Britney
Benty posts. We like those. All >> Is he so mad or is he
just like that was his content, right? Reporting on what happens
on r/ Destiny.
>> Well, I think so. I'm just saying that like he really
wants to he just wants to drive it home that he's he's adding
the the VP guy on Twitter. The 50 viewer 50
>> VP guy. Why is this guy Why is this guy got a congressperson
photo? What the [__] This guy's like a random dude.
He's got like a congress person's Twitter bio. >> Twitter
PFP. What's going on here? What is this? Will he going to snark
on Destiny forever now? I assume so. Is there a VOD on his Twitch?
I don't think so. Apparently Destiny is pretty confused about
this though. didn't like that Willie reported it as a as a DJer.
Let's see here. Let's take a look. Destiny viewer guy makes a
single post in my sub and Mac makes a post claiming he's one
of my fans. Good journalism, mate. Bro, defend him. He's posting
your sources. Uh,
I do like that. I just feel like am I the only one who thinks
it's weird that this guy's got to constantly
just constantly muddy the waters on what is? I I don't know.
It's just a little odd to me. Okay. A little bizarre. >> Wait,
why is he calling Willie Mark? I don't know. No, no sources required.
Okay. He just calls people. He did this to uh what was it? Donut
operator, right? He called that guy as well. Who am I looking
for here? Oh, I'm looking for this Twitch clip. Somebody linked
this Twitch clip. Okay. Can you Can you not link me stuff that
has anything like that in it? Whoever just linked me stuff that
has information about this guy. Can we not Can we not do that?
Thank you. Be careful. We got a We got a Twitch clip. Twitch
clip. Twitch clip. Quick Twitch quick Twitch clip.
>> Britney Venty. The Britney Venty allegations are just
100% here. Okay, we got it locked in. >> Gross. He's a
Republican. >> Oh, what? >> I got beat by a Republican.
Feels bad. >> Oof. Anyone else feeling This guy's got to
be feeling a little deja vu, right? Getting let go. I got Guys,
guys, I got beat by a Republican. >> Gross. He's a Republican.
I got beat by a Republican. >> That's rough. How old is
this guy? I have no idea. No idea how old he is. >> Damn.
It's a lot of beans.
>> It's a lot of beans. You nasty ass. has a lot of beans.
Okay. Uh we do have the other half of this this committee meeting.
I do want to get to it. We should probably do What do you think?
I I'm not sure which direction I want to go in. If I want to
do this, like the rest of this, or if I want to do um Well, we
could do both. We've got a lot of time left. Actually, um we
could do this and techone probably. I commit to finishing this
after techone if you wanted to do techone for just a little bit.
What's the What's the Techone? >> Okay. The techone videos
are on, right?
>> Okay. But you have to play the music in the background.
I can't do another techone video without the dramatic music to
help make him entertaining.
>> The only thing is, okay, we we will do that, but we
might have to we might have to spend a lot of time on this. Okay.
It might be a long stream tonight. We'll >> A lot of time
on what? Okay. I'm going to make coffee, but what else? >> I'm
going to make a drink, too. Um, >> you're Are you going
to make an alcoholic drink or
>> Okay. I'm talking about getting caffeine. You're talking
about getting >> I'm not getting turned. What the I'm going
to have a drink. Jesus. Um,
>> I'm gonna play this and and then we'll do techie. But
yeah. Okay. Um, where are we going? >> Wait, you were going
to say this is going to take a while cuz I was talking about
playing music behind this video. Is it a long video?
>> for techone.
>> No, it's not a long video. It's not. >> Okay.
We're over to here. >> I'm going to focus a little bit
on domestic terrorism. We have a graph here data up to 2021.
But as you can tell, um >> Oh god, I lied. Hold on. I got
to find something interesting again. >> Wait, can you pull
up the
Okay, you can find another interesting part. But we're on today's,
right? Because yesterday he had like um what is it? Corey Booker.
He's like the super performative one. Every time there's one
of these hearings, Cory makes it so that he like has a viral
moment. Uh, and he had a back and forth with Cash Patel. It's
like a 13-minute video. Do you want >> Mr. Patel, I want
to start off where we left off last time. >> Put it on.
>> I asked you whether you had any knowledge or discussions
about removing FBI officials and installing political personnel
before you were confirmed to that position.
And I wonder, did you then understand or have conversations with
the White House about the intentions to do so >> before
I was confirmed? >> Yes, sir. >> Did I have discussions
with the White House to remove FBI personnel?
>> So, you're saying that you had no discussions with the
White House before you were in the position about the removal
of any personnel from the agency? As I was preparing for my confirmation
hearing, I had numerous discussions involving the type of people
that would be employed and that those that were failing to meet
the mark at the FBI would no longer be employed if I >> and
I'm assuming that mark had to do with loyalty to the Trump
>> No, you're wrong. >> Okay. I'd like to revisit
another subject uh from that hearing. Did you did you testify,
excuse me, you did testify before the grand jury uh that President
Trump had declassified the documents at issue in the Mara Lago
classified documents case. Is that
>> I don't have the grand jury transcript. That's why I
released it. Whatever it says is the best evidence. >> You
know, that's what you said to Senator White House that your grand
jury testimony was publicly released.
It has not been. In fact, in July, a court denied a news outlet's
bid to get that transcript. But you said, but the court said
quite clearly that you are free to discuss your grand jury testifi
testimony. So I ask you again, did you testify before the grand
jury that President Trump to classify the documents at issue
in the Mara Lago classified document case? >> And that
is why I took your invitation to work with the department in
the court to have that transcript released. And the transcript
is the best evidence of what I said then. So you're saying right
now this committee can have access
to what you said before the grand jury >> to whatever was
released under my understanding senator that the department of
justice >> you and I both understand the law. Let me finish.
You I understand under rule six of the federal rules of procedure
a grand jury witness in this case you
is not barred from sharing their grand jury testimony.
This is an oversight hearing. This is gerine to your integrity
and
You know right now whether or not you testified that Bar President
Trump declassified the documents at issue in the Mara Lago classified
documents case. Why are you refusing to answer that simple yes
or no question right now? >> Because the premise of your
question is inaccurate.
And >> there is no premise to my question but trying to
get to an order of what is truth or not. >> How do you
know? How do you know what was asked in the grand jury if you
weren't there? M >> Mr. Pelle,
this is a >> earlier today. This is from yesterday
question. If you have your nomination,
you promised that quote all FBI employees will be protected against
political retribution. >> You're drunk. When I haven't
even had any alcohol yet, brother, >> I ask you, are you
aware of any plans or discussions to punish in any way, including
termination FBI agents or personnel associated with the Trump
administration? You explicitly said under oath that you were
not aware of any plans to punish FBI agents associated with criminal
investigations of Donald Trump. I don't believe you were truthful.
Firing FBI employees based solely on the cases that they are
investigating, their case assignments, is illegal. And you know
that a new lawsuit that's been discussed numerous times filed
by three FBI officials alleges that you carried out Donald Trump's
campaign of retribution in quotes against FBI employees for quote
failure to demonstrate sufficient political loyalty.
One of those plaintiffs has been discussed today, Brian Driscoll.
Now we know 20 years of distinguished service to the FBI before
you terminated him. special agent in charge of FBI's Newark field
office where he operated with distinction. Medal of Valor winner,
Shield of Bravery Awards. He's a patriot. You terminated Driscoll
via a letter dated October 8th, 2025. And in that letter, you
said that you were firing him pursuant to Article 2 of the Constitution.
Well, you're not the president of the United States. And so I'm
wondering under what authority you were allowed to terminate
him. That matter is under litigation and I'm not able to discuss
it. >> Okay. Well, discuss this. Did you have discussions
with Steven Miller about firing this particular person or about
his continuence in the FBI?
>> Not that I
>> fired him under the executive authority of the president
of the United States. No way. >> That's article. >> How
often do you speak to Steven Miller? >> Frequently on our
homeland security task forces. You frequently talk with Steven
Miller about subjects other than Homeland Security Task Force
issues. >> I frequently talk to Mr. Miller about Homeland
Security task forces. >> Has Steven Miller ever given you
his opinions on how to run your agency?
>> Mr. Miller's inter agency operations are invaluable
to sex the FBI. That's what we talk about. >> So you frequently
discuss your job? >> Wait, worse. It's Hatch Act. I said,
"So, article two is article two is uh
just all of the like executive power and you said worse it's
Hatch Act." You're saying it's a violation of the Hatch Act,
but that's different than it being like article 2 is the the
authority he cites, right? >> Job and your responsibilities
with Steven Miller and Pampi, I imagine, as >> Absolutely.
She's the attorney general. >> Understood. Okay.
Donald Trump promised to make us all safer. You have pushed out
senior FBI agents with decades of knowledge and experience. In
fact, this is the first time in FBI history that neither the
director nor the deputy director have any experience with the
FBI. You've shifted the agency's priorities primarily to pursuing
Donald Trump's immigration enforcement agenda. According to ICE
data, the KO Institute, which is a conservative think tank, found
that 25 f 20% of all agents have been diverted from their work
to do assist ICE immigration enforcement. 20%.
Part of this operation is the work of mass law enforcement who
jump out of cars, snatch people off streets. >> How much
for the next hour? Uh, I believe that's 75 I got up there. I'd
probably do it for less. I think we're going to end up going
a little bit over today anyway. But guys, if you want to if you
want to have more time to the stream, go ahead. Donate. All right.
Donate, donate, donate. Let me reset this bar on Botworks here.
Where is this? Where is this? There it is. There it is. There
it is. >> Churches, schools, and their jobs and >> We're
back. >> Have there been any FBI agents who investigate
crimes against children that have been >> Yeah, I I guess
one to over you weren't here earlier when we discussed this.
Yes. Um, this entire section is about violations of the Hatch
Act. Yep. Yep. We've we've talked about that at length already
today. >> Assigned to immigration enforcement. Yes or no?
>> Premise of what you say is entire. >> Have there
been any FBI agents to investigate foreign domestic terrorism?
>> You don't get to say the America is not safer under
this
America is safer because of the
>> do another hour for 75 kicks for 75 cents. Would I do
another hour? I don't think so. But I would appreciate 75 kicks.
Okay. We love kicks. Kicks are awesome. You know what, guys?
If we actually get if we can get to what? So $75 would be 75
bucks. But if we can get to
3,000 kicks. All right. 3,000 kicks. I'll add another hour to
the stream cuz I just want you guys to get kicks. Go buy some
kicks. All right. So you can give them around. 3,000 3,000 kicks.
We'll do another hour on the stream. All right. Them's the rules.
>> A presumption of pre of >> 700 children. We have
>> Let's hit that kick limit, guys. That's a That's a $30.
It's actually $27 hour. I'm not even going to reset the kick
the kicks that are on there already. There's 333. I'm not even
going to reset them. Okay. Thousand weapons and denying that
FBI agents who investigate human trafficking have been reassigned
to immigration enforcement. You are not denying that FBI agents
who are on the task force that fight against Russian oligarchs
have not been reassigned. Public correction squad reassigned.
People who defend us defend children reassigned. You're not denying
that. I've seen you time and time again attack my colleagues
premises of questions as a way to not answer the question. So,
let me end with this. I believe you have made our country weaker
and less safe. I believe that we are more vulnerable to a major
event and I pray to God it doesn't happen. You've gutted the
Bureau of Institutional Knowledge and Expertise.
You fired or pushed out season >> that's the big one. Okay.
gutted the institutional the institution of knowledge and expertise
is the biggest one because you aren't willing to suck Trump's
okay you can't work at the FBI is an insane premise it's an insane
precedent to set and it is like directly beneficial to every
one of America's adversaries and hurts the American people it
is the worst policy to pursue it is a purely anti-American policy
okay there is nothing there's almost nothing more antithetical
to America than the things cash engaged in in terms of purging
the FBI. >> FBI officials, many with more than 20 years
of experience
and were working on cases that were critical. You've been p purging
thousands of serious law enforcement officials who spent their
careers keeping us safe only to lower hiring standards in order
to find anyone to replace them. And shockingly, you admitted
in this hearing to Senator Cook that it would take 14 years to
fill the vacancies at your agency. Many are the result of your
purge. 20% of FBI agents are doing low. >> Oh, Bruce Willis
with 500 kicks. That's five bucks. You could put a you could
put a little message on that, I think. But you didn't. Why'd
you put a little message on that, bro? That's 500 kicks right
there. >> But thank you very much for the rage >> Lowle
immigration enforcement instead of their mission critical work.
You've disbanded entire task forces that stop intellect in intellection
interference, foreign influence, public corruption, and who benefits
from this? Well, corrupt people benefit from it. Criminals benefit
from it. Vladimir Putin benefits from it. And it really makes
me wonder who you're looking out for. It makes me think, we can't
trust you as a nation. >> Senator, Afro Samurai. Senator,
>> you swear to release the Epstein files, but now you're
withholding the Epstein files. You claim that you have a suspect
in a serious assassination. Whoops. Then you don't have a suspect.
You know nothing about plans to remove FBI agents, yet you're
directly involved in those plans. In the words of an ex FBI official,
you are overseeing, and I quote, generational destruction of
the nation's premier law enforcement agency.
Mr. Mr. Patel, in just 8 months, you have assaulted the institutional
integrity of the FBI,
but I know FBI field agents. I >> Dude, Senate Senate hearings
suck. Why is this taking so long, dude? I'm sorry. You might
you might like Cory Booker, Jerry, but I I can't >> I did
not say that I like him. I just This gets heated. >> I've
worked with them in Newark. >> No matter how truly bad
you are, you can't undermine the legacy of agents who fight every
day to keep us safe. But you can tarnish the integrity of the
agency and under
>> gummy. Not even was holding for >> with a,000
kicks. That's 10 bucks. Says pack it in. That should read TTS.
I don't know why that didn't read TTS just now. I told it, hey,
when those come through, read the TTS. Just didn't do it. Broken.
We're We're 500. We're almost 500. 550 kicks away, guys, for
another hour on the stream. Okay. Get those kicks in. Kick them
in. Come on,
>> Okay. For as soy as this guy is, do you know who he's
marrying? >> Uh,
I should know. No, >> it blows my mind every time I see
and remember it is the who plays a stripper with AIDS from Ren.
>> Mimi. She's like my [__] favorite. And somehow
he's marrying her. What was her name? Rosario Dawson. >> Oh,
Rosario. Oh, yeah. Oh, Rosario Dawson was like big time. Uh,
what do you call it?
>> They call me.
>> She was like huge into Bernie's campaign and [__]
right? She was massively into Bernie's campaign. I think. Am
I wrong on that? >> Yeah, he is a lucky bastard. I have
no idea if she was huge for Bernie's campaign. Um, but yeah,
I love the movie run and the play. I guess >> they broke
up. Are you sure they broke up? But >> did they? I thought
I just saw wedding photos for them or engagement photos. He was
reading dating Rosario Dawson for a while. They broke up apparently.
They broke up. >> Oh, they broke up like three years ago.
>> They broke up three years ago. What? Oh, >> he's
marrying someone else. Who's he marrying now? Oh, well, thank
goodness they broke up. >> Oh, what the heck? >> What
a good day. >> Thank goodness. You mean thank goodness.
>> I'm sorry, but he looked like the type of guy. He looked
like the type of guy to marry a woman and then wait 10 years
to tell her, "Hm,
I might be gay." And what's the problem there? >> It's
Rosario Dawson. Don't waste 10 years of her life because you
couldn't come out of the closet. >> I mean, she's 46. I
I think they're fine. I don't think she's missing like uh She's
like She can make that decision. Okay. She can make that
>> Yeah, she can. She can make that >> Is she 46?
God, she's so beautiful. >> Rosario Johnson.
>> Very masculine jaw. Is Corey Booker dating a man? I'm
just I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. It was
a joke. It was a joke. >> The agency's capacity.
Failing is >> Rosario and Clerks Too. That was a good That
was good. Clerks, too. Okay. She was great in Clerks, too. Love
Clerks, >> The leader and that your failure does have serious
implications for the safety and security of Americans and our
families. We're more vulnerable to domestic and foreign attack
because of your failures of leadership. I don't think you're
fit to hand the bureau. Here's the thing, Mr. Patel.
I think you're not going to be around long. >> I think
this >> How does this guy have like like more than any
white woman I've ever seen, this guy has massive Karen energy?
Look at the way he closes that book and continues his sentence.
>> Mr. Because of your failures of leadership, I don't
think you said to him. It's >> the most highpowered Karen
I've ever seen in my entire life. >> But here's the thing,
Mr. Patel.
I think you're not going to be around long. I think this might
be your last oversight hearing because as much as you supplicate
yourself to the will of Donald Trump and not the Constitution
of the United States of America, Donald Trump has shown us in
his first term and in this term he is not loyal to people like
you. He will cut you loose. >> That's just true. That's
like totally true.
Oh, that's funny. I thought he was going to say not loyal to
the United States and I'm like, "Yeah, true." But it's going
to be hard to prove that one. No, no. This one's very Sorry.
Hard to prove that one to morons. This one's easily provable
even to morons. Yeah, Donald Trump doesn't like like most people
who work for him. I don't know if you've seen this, but uh what
how many people he fired so many people in his first admin? It
was crazy. I think it's been more stable this time, right? It's
been way more stable. Now he's got all the sick events. He had
to fire all the people who would stand up to him and now it's
just purely sick events. So, >> this may be the last time
I have a hearing with you because I don't think you're long for
your job. But I'm going to tell you this. I pray for you. I pray
for you that you can step up and defend your oath, defend the
Constitution, and do a much better job of defending this country.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. >> Do you want to say anything?
>> Yes, sir. That rant of false information
does not bring this country together. If you want to work on
bringing this country, it's my time, not yours. >> My god.
My god. You want to talk about this country? I follow you on
your social media posts that tear this country apart. >> Dude,
he's got the It's It's so crazy. I just see a white woman with
like the hair over one eye. >> It's such crazy Karen energy
every time from this guy
>> you can try all you want in this country to not say
for what you have said, sir. You're a blocker of this committee,
sir. You don't tell me my time is over. The people of New Jersey
tell me what my time is. You can't lecture me. >> Tell
me my time is over. >> You may be the charging anywhere.
I am not afraid of you, Mr. Chairman. >> I'm not afraid
of you. >> Mr. Chairman, point of order. >> Senator
Booker, I announced at the beginning of this meeting that >> Hey,
it's Ted Cruz. >> This back and forth talking over each
other doesn't work. And I said if that happened, I asked Patel
not to respond and I was going to give him some time
>> Jesus Christ, dude. Chuck Grassley's got one foot in
the grave. What is going on? What is happening here? >> That's
just what white people look like at 50. Calm down. >> This
guy This guy is like 80 years old. What the Chuck Grassly? How
old is this guy? This guy's 92. >> Oh my good. Why do they
not retire? They never go. They never leave. He's gonna be like
Diane Feinstein
>> wheeling the into Congress, >> bro. You can't
I understand that like Yeah, exactly. I understand some people
don't want to retire at like 65. Okay. I think like forcing you
to retire at 70 is a little questionable. Bro, after 80 you got
to go. You actually got to go at 80. I'm sorry. 90 it's actually
just elder abuse. All right. This is [__] crazy.
sing Frozen to these [__] on the way out of Congress.
Let it go. Let it go. Who the Why do they not want to take all
of that money that they got from lobbyist?
Where where is it going? If you are just going to serve in Congress
till your death, go on a vacation or something. >> Yeah.
I I just don't get it. How >> is it possible that they
get all of that lobbying money to drink the adrenochrome to keep
themselves alive and they have to stay in Congress otherwise
they don't get any more >> Oh yeah, I could see it. >> Baby
blood. >> Is that Is that what happens to Mitch McConnell?
Mitch McConnell like slides out of line. They stop giving him
his adrenochrome and he starts freezing up. >> starts turning
purple in the hands. >> Yeah. He starts He just starts
like melting live in front of the world. He He immediately falls
back into line. Okay. I don't even think Grass Grass is like
not the worst, right? I think he's like one of the I think he
was for a long time one of the better Republicans, right? One
of the like most tolerable Republicans. Am I crazy? I feel like
he's pretty tolerable. I'll see if anybody has that. I I feel
like I've never heard Chuck Grassley's name in like a horrible
context, I guess. But I say that I don't know, maybe he's got
some scandals or some [__] >> Yeah, Booker
is the senator for New >> Anyway, okay. I I'll finish Chuck
Grassley's interjection here. Senator's time was up to respond
and he he has the privilege to do that. >> And then I've
got a I've got a special treat as a follow-up to this and then
we're on to Techone. Okay, special treat right after this. We've
got our latest Okay, there's a new guy auditioning for right-wing
Grifter. Okay, >> new guy, new new streamer, new big streamer
is trying to get in on this. All right, we're going to see his
opinion. He he was out here defending Cash Patel. Okay, no spoilers
in the >> Interrupt, Mr. Chairman. Go ahead, Mr. I've watched
him talk over us and you've never once criticized him for us
not even be able to get our questions out. >> Well, he
has been rude and disrespectful to senator after senator. >> And
when the senators were not giving him a chance to answer, I didn't
stop the senator either. Go ahead. >> I'm equally bad at
my job, bro. What do you want from me? >> Thank you, Mr.
Chairman. If the FBI under my seven-month leadership were failing
this administration in this country, why do we have 23,000 violent
felons arrested this year alone? A 200,
excuse me, a double increase from that time last year. Why is
it that we have seized 6,000 weapons? Why have we found 1,500
child predators? >> You see 6,000 guns in the United States?
Seriously, that's your that's that's what you're bragging about.
6,000 guns. So, you raided like three homes in Alabama. Congratulations,
Cash. >> Arrest them. Why have we have 300 human traffickers
in jail? Why have we found and identified 4,700 children? Why
have we seen 60
>> traffickers in jail? Why have we found and identified
4,700 children? Why have
>> just found a Cash Mattel walking around like an elementary
school? One, two, three, four, five,
>> see, 1600 kg of fentinol in in enough to kill a third
of the American public. a 25% increase alone from last year.
88,000 kilograms of disease, 700 kilograms of disease and that's
just on our criminal operations in summer heat. How is it possible
that we're taking 8 kg off the streets of the cities in New Jersey
and >> I would love to just all these people he lists all
these things out. I would love for somebody to just ask Cash
like how's your budget doing? He keeps every time he talks about
doing [__] with the FBI, he just describes putting
way more money into than is in the budget, right? Have you noticed
that? That's every single time he speaks, he's just like, "We
put tons of resources into this. We put tons of resource." Are
you just getting a blank check to like pay people for overtime
and hire people, do whatever the [__] you want, or
like it sounds like you're just running everybody at overtime
all the time and paying out tons of money? That's what it sounds
like to me. Like every description he does is just like overtime,
overtime, overtime, overtime. I don't know. I I think that would
be concerning to people. No, maybe not. Republicans do kind of
justify whatever spending. Geez. >> I mean, to me, it just
sounds like the FBI is doing their job and he's like, "Okay,
give me all the stats of the that we got done so I could show
them how productive we are." Like, whether he was there or not,
they probably meet all these numbers. >> Uh, yeah. Well,
maybe. I I don't know what the summer heat thing is. I have no
idea what what it actually is, but yeah. I I don't think he's
doing anything special like you said. I think like crime was
broadly coming down in the first place. So yeah. Yeah. >> All
right. We
>> preventing the deaths of 600 >> more numbers from
>> 7,000 people this year alone. A failure of the FBI and
my leadership. How is it that we have counter intelligence arrest
already this year exceeding the numbers from the entirety of
last year. 33% increase in PRC, 83% in Russia, 60% in the CI
space as it relates to Iran. And we haven't even talked about
CT, the southern border, the northern border. before Senator
Cruz. I kind of feel like a broken record today. All this interest
in FBI termination, yet my colleague showed no intent
uh or interest in uh when I uh my whistleblower suffered retaliation
over the past years, particularly the past four years. Indeed,
one whistleblower has alleged that Brian Driscoll's insubordination,
whether an
uh whether an agent is on a hot button case or not, they ought
to be held accountable for misconduct and weaponization. Senator
Cruz. >> Okay. Thank